ALAN ARCHULETA ATKINS BABIES
BECKER BORJAS BRADFORD CABRERO
CORTEZ V. VALLEY DODD THE RAZA
EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE
HERTZBERG WE SELL HER TADO.
JONES CAM WALKER LAYERED LLEVA
THE MON MCGUIRE MELINDA'S MAN
NEWMAN NIELSEN A TRIO OF BOTH
PAN CERTAINTY NOW PRODUCT RUBIO
SKINNER STERN NUMBER WHY CASKEY
WINNER WELL. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY SENATOR- CHOKO
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. BY SENATOR STERN.
GRACIOUS AND LOVING GOD MAYBE
WORK THIS DAY AS IF EVERYTHING
DEPENDS ON US AND PRAY AS IF
EVERYTHING DEPENDS ON YOU.
WENDELL BERRY IN HIS FORM THIS
STAYS AS WHATEVER IS FORESEEN
ENJOY MUST BE LIVED OUT FROM
DAY TO DAY. VISION HELD OPEN IN
THE DARK FIRE TEN THOUSAND DAYS
OF WORK. HARVEST WILL FILL THE
BARN FOR THAT HAD MISSED EIGHT
THE FACE MY SWEAT AND YET NO
LEAVE OR GREEN IS FILLED BY
WORK OF OURS. THE FIT THE FIELD
IS TILLED AND LOVE TO GRACE
THAT WE MAY REAP GREAT WORK IS
DONE WHILE WE'RE ASLEEP. WHEN
WE WORK WELL A SEVENTH WILL
REST IN OUR DAY AND FINDS IT
GOOD AMEN. IMAGE MEMBERS JOIN
ME IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
ONE HERE'S A CIVIL LIBERTIES
FOR ALL. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS A
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED RED
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOVING
ON TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
SENATE JOURNALS FOR MAY TWENTY
FOURTH THROUGH THE TWENTY
EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILL
BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO CONSIDERATION. OF
pGONNA TAKE A SECOND READING
FILE PLEASE READ. SENATE BILLS
AT. 670-145-3940 EIGHT EIGHT OH
SIX AT SIX TWENTY FIVE AND
SENATE BILL SEVEN NINETY SIX.
MEMBERS MOVING ONTO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN SENATOR LARRY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- THE ITEM
THIRTEEN IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
DOCTOR CYNTHIA GLOVER WOODS
JAMES MCCLELLAN AND I THE
RODRIGUEZ FOR APPOINTMENT TO
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION-
DOCTOR GLOVER WOODS IS CHIEF
ACADEMIC OFFICER FOR THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION MR MCQUILLAN IS THE
DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION FOR THE
YUROK TRIBE AND MS RODRIGUEZ IS
A TEACHER AND AVID COORDINATOR
FOR THE CENTRAL UNION HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN IMPERIAL
COUNTY. THEY WERE APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON MAY
NINETEENTH I RESPECTFULLY ASKS
FOR NINE VOTE MEMBERS THERE IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THESE APPOINTMENTS. SEEING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA.
HI ADKINS FIVE BATES. BACKER
FIVE FORGES. BRADFORD. CABRERA
HI FOR TESTING HI DALLY. DOT
FIVE TORONTO HI ADNAN. GLAZER
FIVE DOLLARS I GROW. HERTZBERG
I WAS SO. HI HI HER TADO. HI
JONES. CAN LONGER I LAYERED I.
LEIVA. FIVE THE MON I REQUIRE.
I MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON. I A TELEPHONE. PAM
FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH FIVE
RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN I AM
BERG. FIVE WHAT KASKY FIVE
WINNER I WILL. WE'RE PUTTING
THIS ON CALL. MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO THE SENATE THIRD
READING. AND WE WILL START WITH
ITEM- VIOLATED NUMBER TWENTY
THREE SENATOR LEE MON ARE YOU
PREPARED. SHE IS PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY BY
SENATOR LEON AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH INSURANCE. SENATOR NAME
ON THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY WOULD
REQUIRE LARGE GROUP MARKET
HEALTH INSURANCE POLICIES TO
COVER MEDICALLY NECESSARY
HEALTH CARE SERVICES INDIVIDUAL
AND SMALL GROUP MARKET HEALTH
INSURANCE REGULATED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE LARGE GROUP MARKET
HEALTH INSURANCE IS NOT
REQUIRED TO COVER MEDICALLY
NECESSARY BASIC HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AS A RESULT LARGE
GROUP POLICIES ROUTINELY LIMIT
OR EXCLUDE PRE CENTRAL MEDICAL
CARE SUCH AS WOMEN'S
REPRODUCTIVE SERVICES OBESITY
AND ORGAN TRANSPLANTS S. B. TWO
EIGHTY WILL CODIFY THE FEDERAL
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT A
PROHIBITION ON DISCRIMINATORY
LARGE GROUP HEALTH INSURANCE
BENEFIT DESIGN AND MARKETING
PROCESS. PRACTICES THIS BILL
HAS THE OPPOSITION AND RECEIVED
BY A STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IN COMMITTEE AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I BOTH. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SAYING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA FIVE
ADKINS FIVE BABIES. BECKER HI
FORGES. BRADFORD. BY ADAM FIVE
COURTESY HI DALLY I DON. FIVE
THEY'RE AWESOME I EGGMAN I
LASER I CONSOLIDATES HIGH
GROWTH HIGH HURTS BERG I WAS SO
I HER TADO FIVE JONES FIVE KM
LONGER. I LAYERED I LLEVA I
LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE. I
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A CHILD OKAY I PAN.
FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH FIVE
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN HI
AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER
I WILL. HI SYNERGY MOON MOVES A
CALL MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY ONE. SENATOR MCGUIRE.
WHILE TEMPORARY PASS ON FILE.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
THREE. CENTER YOUR MIND HOW YOU
PREPARED HE IS PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FORTY SEVEN BY
SUNDERLAND MON AN ACT RELATING
TO OIL AND GAS. IS THERE ANY
ROOM ON THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
FORTY SEVEN ADDRESSES THE
SERIOUS PROBLEM OF DESERTED
WALLS IN CALIFORNIA HE HAS BEEN
ESTIMATED THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
AN ESTIMATED LIABILITY OF AT
LEAST FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IT COULD
BE UP TO FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
DESERTED WALLS ARE A FINANCIAL
LIABILITY TO THE STATE AND
DANGEROUS TO THE SURROUNDING
ENVIRONMENT RESIDENTS. THE
WELLS CAN LEAK DEGRADING AIR
QUALITY AND CONTAMINATING
AQUIFERS HARMING THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY THIS BILL
INCREASES THE ANNUAL AMOUNT
CALVIN CAN SPEND AND ALSO
ALLOWS CAL JAM TO POTENTIALLY
SAVE WE ARE WORKING WITH
OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS. AT THE END OF THE-
TO ENSURE A BALANCED SOLUTION
CAN BE REACHED WITH US THAT
WILL BE PROTECTED TAXPAYERS HI
IT'S LIKELY ASPIRIN I'VE OF. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST HAVE
TO SAY I APPRECIATE. THE CENTER
FROM- THE CENTRAL COAST EFFORTS
ON THIS AND- OUR EFFORTS TO
REACH A COMPROMISE OVER I JUST
I THINK IT'S WORTH MANAGING
EXPECTATIONS ABOUT THE SCOPE OF
WHAT THIS BILL WILL AND WON'T
DO ALL I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
MEASURE TODAY BUT WE'VE GOT A
BILLION DOLLAR TAXPAYER
LIABILITY ON OUR HANDS MEMBERS
WHEN IT COMES TO ORPHAN AND-
IDLE THEN ABANDON WELLS IN THIS
STATE- THIS BILL WILL NOT SOLVE
THAT PROBLEM WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO STEP UP AND PUSH ALL OF
OURSELVES AND OUR RESPECTIVE
JURISDICTIONS TO GET THE
CAPITAL TOGETHER. BOTH FROM THE
OIL INDUSTRY AND FROM THE
PUBLIC SIDE TO GET HIS WORK
DONE I APPRECIATE THE SENATOR'S
HARD WORK I JUST THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT GOING INTO THIS VOTE
TO NOT ASSUME THAT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IS GOING TO SOLVE A
BILLION DOLLAR PROBLEM SO
INCREMENTAL STEP FOUR I'LL BE
SUPPORTING TODAY BUT WANT TO
SEE S. DO MUCH MORE FOR ALL THE
PEOPLE LEFT BEHIND IN THEIR
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CENTER GROVE. PRESIDENT I TOO
HAVE HAD LENGTHY CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR HAND- MY
COLLEAGUE FRIEND IN THE VENTURE
AREA. I AM. I DON'T THINK THIS
IS A SOLUTION TO THE ISSUE THAT
WE HAVE WITH YOUR FRIEND AND
ABANDONED WELLS OBVIOUSLY ALL
OF US IN THIS IN THIS BUILDING.
AND HAVE A CONCERN WITH THE
LIABILITY EXPOSURE WITH YOUR
FRIEND OF ANNA WELLS AND THE
MINIMAL DOLLARS IN THE FUND TO
BE ABLE TO- TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM- I APPLAUD MY
COLLEAGUES. ALTHOUGH I CAN'T
SUPPORT THE BILL I DO APPLAUD
MY COLLEAGUES- INCREMENTAL TINY
ITTY BITTY STEPS TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THIS TO ALLOW CALCIUM
TO SPEND ADDITIONAL DOLLARS IS
GOOD SO THEY DON'T SWEET MONEY
OUT OF THE ACCOUNT BECAUSE
CALCIUM. OBVIOUSLYCAN'T BUDGET
FOR SOMETHING THAT'S A TEN
MILLION DOLLAR PROJECT AND THEY
ONLY HAVE TEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE FUND. SO I UNDERSTAND
WHERE THE AUTHOR IS TRYING TO
GO I DID HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR ABOUT HOW TO
REALLY SOLVE THIS PROBLEM AND
AS SOMEBODY WHO REPRESENT 70%
OF THE STATE OIL STATES OIL.
LARGE AND SMALL PRODUCERS ARE
IN MY DISTRICT I HAVE ONE
PRODUCER THAT PRODUCES ABOUT A
HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT THOUSAND
BARRELS A DAY AND I HAVE A
PRODUCER WHO PRODUCES TWO
BARRELS A DAY. AND I THINK THAT
THERE IS A REAL SOLUTION ON ON-
SOLVING THIS WITH A- IN MAYBE A
COST PER BARREL SO THAT IS
EQUITABLY DISTRIBUTED BETWEEN
LARGE PRODUCERS AND SMALL
PRODUCERS I DON'T THINK THIS IS
A SOLUTION BUT I HAVE COMMITTED.
TO WORK WITH HER MOVING FORWARD
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SINGMAN CENTER YOUR
MIND YOU MAY CONCLUDE THANK YOU
AND IT IS AND MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE EXPRESSED THIS IS ONE
REALLY SMALL PIECES TO A LARGER
PROBLEM AND I THINK IT'S GOING
TO TAKE MORE THAN THIS BILL- TO
TRY TO UNDERSTAND HOW
CALIFORNIA GETS TO ANYWHERE
FROM FIVE HUNDRED MILLION TO
FIVE BILLION- IN TERMS OF THE
WORK THAT'S NEEDED. I DO WANT
TO CALL OUT TO THAT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE I HE
PROPOSED USING TWO HUNDRED
MILLION OF GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
TAXPAYERS DOLLARS TO TRY TO GET
AT THIS AND WE ARE TRYING TO
FIND AN ALTERNATIVE AND ANOTHER
WAY. TO HELP TACKLE THIS
PROBLEM BUT I ABSOLUTELY AGREE
THAT THIS BILL ALONE DOES NOT
SOLVE THE PROBLEM IN FRONT OF
US WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I VOTE. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT
KENS FIVE BAIT. NO BECKER HI
PORGES NO BRADFORD. BY ADAM.
CORTESE. HI DALLY. NO DODD.
TORONTO HI ADNAN HI GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ HI BRO. NO HERZBERG HI
WAY SO HI HER TADO. JONES NO
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LABOR.
HI THE MON I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. NO A CHARTER OAK NO
PAN. FOUR TWENTY NOW HI RALPH.
HI RUBIO. SKINNER FIVE STERN HI
AMBERG. WHITE HOUSE E. FIVE
WINNER I WILL NOW SENATOR THE
MOON MOVES THE CALL NUMBERS
MOVING ITEM ONTO FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY SIX SENATOR
NEWMAN ARE YOU PREPARED HE IS
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL TWO
FORTY TWO BY SENATOR NEWMAN AN
ACT RELATING TO HEALTH CARE AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY OF ARABS
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY SENATOR
NEWMAN THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS DIE I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY TWO AND
URGENCY MEASURE WHICH DIRECTION
SHARERS TO REIMBURSE HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS FOR NECESSARY PP
DURING AN EMERGENCY PUB PUBLIC
HEALTH OR OR UNTIL SUCH TIME AS
CONTRACTS ARE RENEGOTIATED.
SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZED
PHYSICIAN PRACTICES ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN DECIMATED
BY THE PANDEMIC AND THE
DRAMATICALLY HIGH COST OF
SUPPLIES NEEDED TO KEEP
PATIENTS SAFE EVEN WITH RECENT
REDUCTIONS IN COVERT CASES AND
HIGHER VACCINATION RATES. LAST
YEAR THESE PRACTICES WERE
DEALING WITH ON AVERAGE WITH A
70% DROP IN REVENUE AS LATE AS
AUGUST AND THEY ARE STILL
EXPERIENCE ABOUT A 30% DECLINE
IN REVENUE OVERALL MUCH OF THIS
DECLINE. HAS BEEN A DIRECT
DIRECT RESULT OF A COMBINATION
DECREASED PATIENT VOLUME
COMPOUNDED BY STEEP INCREASES
IN THE COST OF PP AND OTHER
PROTOCOLS OVER THE PAST VERY
CHALLENGING YEAR MANY PHYSICIAN
OWNED PRACTICES IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE HAD TO REDUCE STAFF OR
EVEN CLOSE THEIR DOORS ALL
TOGETHER EVEN AS HEALTH
INSURANCE EXPERIENCE. HEALTH
INSURERS HAVE ENJOYED RECORD
PROFITS IN FACT DOUBLE THE
PROFITS IN SOME CASES FROM THE
PREVIOUS YEAR I THINK WE CAN
ALL AGREE THAT DURING A
PANDEMIC THE IMPERATIVE FOR
INCREASED PP AND MORE COMPLEX
INFECTION CONTROL PROTOCOLS
SHOULD NOT RESULT IN DECREASED
ACCESS. THE CLOSURE OF
CRITICALLY NEEDED CARE
FACILITIES OR REDUCTIONS IN
MEDICAL SERVICES AMENITIES
TAKEN FOR THIS BILLING
COMMITTEE ADDRESS THE HEALTH
PLANS CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
BEING OVERLY BROAD AS WELL AS
NARROWING ITS FOCUS SO THAT ITS
PROVISIONS WILL ONLY BE
APPLICABLE ONLY STATEWIDE
EMERGENCY PUBLIC HEALTH ORDER
IS IN EFFECT. I. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. VOTE TODAY. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SAYING NINE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN. ARCHULETA I
ADKINS HI BABES NO BACKER. I
FORTUS NOTES BRADFORD. CABRERA
I COURTESY FIVE DALLY NO DODD
FIVE TORONTO BY ADMIN HI GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HI GROVE. HERTZBERG
FIVE WITH SO. HI HER TADO I
JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED
HI LLEVA I LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE.
I MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO BUT SHOW A BUG. NO
PAN. FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH I
RUBIO. SKINNER FIVE STERN FIVE
NUMBER I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER
I WILL NOW. SENATOR NEWMAN
MOVES A CALL MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN SENATOR
GONZALEZ SHE IS READY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL TWO FORTY
FIVE BY SENATOR GONZALEZ AN ACT
RELATED TO HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
CENTER GONZALEZ THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
F. B. TWO FORTY FIVE WHICH WILL
REQUIRE ALL STATE LICENSED
HEALTH CARE PLANS ISSUED AFTER
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO COVER
ABORTION. AND ABORTION RELATED
SERVICES WITHOUT A COPAYMENT
DEDUCTIBLE OR ANY TYPE OF COST
SHARING CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A
LEADER IN PROTECTING AN
INDIVIDUAL'S RIGHT TO ACCESS
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND ALL THESE EFFORTS
HAVE HELPED MAINTAIN THE RIGHT
FOR DECADES THERE ALSO THERE
ARE STILL NUMEROUS BARRIERS TO
ACCESSING THESE SERVICES.
INCLUDING AFFORDABILITY THESE
HIGH OUT OF POCKET COSTS ARE
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO CARE
THAT CAN BE COST PROHIBITIVE TO
LOW INCOME WORKING FAMILIES AS
B. TWO FORTY FIVE WILL REMOVE
THIS BARRIER AND ALLOW ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO ACCESS THEIR
LEGAL RIGHT TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES BY
ENSURING THAT HEALTH PLANS
CAN'T REQUIRE COST SHARING FOR
ABORTION OR ABORTION RELATED
SERVICES. I THINK- IF B. TWO
FORTY FIVE WILL ENSURE THAT WE
REMAIN THE LEADER IN THIS FIGHT
AND MUST CONTINUE TO WIN WE
MUST CONTINUE AS A STATE TO
DEFENDANT AND EXPAND ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE IN ALL
FORMS. AND FOR THAT I THINK YOU
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
ON SB TWO FORTY FIVE.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA I AT KINS I
BASE NO BECKER. I FORGES NO
BRADFORD. BY ADAM HI CORTESE HI
DALLY NO DOG. HI THE RUSSELL HI
ADNAN FIVE GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATES. HI GROSS NO HURTS
BERG. I WAS SO. HI HER TADO I
JONES NO KAMMERER I LAYERED. HI
LLEVA I LIVE ALONE. I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S. MAN. FIVE NEWMAN I
NELSON NO A SHOW OF BOTH. NO
PAN. FOUR TWENTY NOW HI RALPH
HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. HI STERN.
HI HI AMBER. I WAKE OWSKI FIVE
WINNER I WOKE. SENATOR GONZALES
MOOSE CALL. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY EIGHT DR PENN. HE YEAH I
WILL I WILL PASS ON FILE ON
THAT ONE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
NINE. CENTERMAN HE IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL TWO
SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR MAN AN
ACT RELATING TO FIREARMS CENTER
MAN THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO PRODUCE PRESENT
TO U. S. B. TWO SIXTY FOUR WELL
TO ENSURE THAT THIS STATE IS
NOT PROFITING FROM THE SALE OF
FIREARMS AMMUNITION AND FIREARM
PRECURSOR PARTS ON STATE
PROPERTY OR FACILITATING GUN
SHOWS ON STATEPROPERTY THAT
COULD UNDERMINE CALIFORNIA'S
STRONG. FIREARM REGULATIONS.
LAST YEAR YOU MAY REMEMBER THE
WEEK WEEKEND WHEN WE HAD THE EL
PASO SHOOTINGS I GUESS AS A TWO
YEAR AND A HALF AGO. IN MY
HOUSEHOLD I REMEMBERED THATWE
HAD TO EXPLAIN TO OUR CHILDREN
ARE YOUNG CHILDREN YET AGAIN.
ABOUT ANOTHER GUN MASSACRE AND
TALK TO THEM ABOUT THE DANGERS
OF GUN VIOLENCE IN AMERICA. THE
VERY NEXT MORNING WE WOKE UP TO
LEARN THERE BEEN ANOTHER MASS
SHOOTING IN DAYTON OHIO. THIS
IS PERSONAL FOR US. BECAUSE MY
WIFE HAS FAMILY IN DAYTON AND A
NUMBER OF COUSINS WHO ATTENDED
THE UNIVERSITY OF DAYTON. AND
FREQUENT THE BAR WHERE THAT
SHOOTING HAD TAKEN PLACE. WE
HAD TO MAKE THOSE ANXIOUS PHONE
CALLS TO FAMILY TO MAKE SURE
THEY WERE ALL OKAY. AND FOR US
WE WERE LUCKY IN THAT THEY WERE.
AS IT HAPPENED THAT MORNING. WE
ARE SCHEDULED TO A FAMILY FUN
RUN. A FIVE K. ORANGE COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS. WHAT A GREAT TIME
UNTIL THE VERY END. AS WE PASS
THE FINISH LINE FOR. ALL OF US
INCLUDING MY CHILDREN FOR THEM
EIGHT SIX AND THREE. WERE
HANDED FLYERS OFFERING US FREE
ADMISSION TO THE GUN SHOWS
HAPPENING THE FOLLOWING WEEKEND.
WHEN I WAS GROWING UP THE
COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS WERE KNOWN
FOR BEING FAMILY FRIENDLY. IN
ADDITION THE COUNTY FAIR EACH
YEAR THEY HAVE RODEOS FOUR H.
EVENTS CONCERTS THE CIRCUS AND
OTHER EVENTS LIKE THAT. BUT
TODAY THEY'RE KNOWN PRIMARILY
FOR GUN SHOWS. THE AVERAGE
COUNTY FAIRGROUND ACROSS THE
STATE HOSTS FIVE GUN SHOWS A
YEAR. MINE IN ORANGE COUNTY
TYPICALLY HOSTS EIGHT TO TWELVE
COUNTRIES EACH YEAR. AND
CONTRARY TO THE CLAIMS OF GUN
SHOW PROPONENTS THESE SHOWS ARE
ANYTHING BUT FAMILY FRIENDLY.
IF YOU'VE EVER BEEN TO ONE OF
THE SHOWS YOU KNOW THAT THEY'RE
HOTBEDS OF EXTREMIST SENTIMENT.
IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR T. SHIRTS
MASTER OTHER PERIL IT SAYS F.
GAVIN NEWSOM OR F. BITE AND-
THIS IS THE PLACE TO GO. IF
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR SHOOTING
TARGET SUPERIMPOSED ON
POLITICIANS. TYPICALLY
DEMOCRATS THIS IS THE PLACE TO
GO. NOT AT THAT TIME I WAS
RUNNING FOR THE SEAT I NOW
HOLD. AND I FOUND THAT IF I
ENDED UP BEING ELECTED I WOULD
WORK TO END GUN SHOWS ON STATE
PROPERTY IN ORANGE COUNTY. AND
ACROSS THE STATE. AND THAT IS
WHAT I'M HERE TRYING TO DO
TODAY. HELLO PROPONENTS OF GUN
SHOWS CLAIM GUN SHOWS ARE SAFE.
AND ALSO LEGAL FIREARMS THIS IS
NOT TRUE. TENSIONS ARE
ESSENTIALLY A FLEA MARKET FOR
FIREARMS. THEIR RIMARY
MECHANISM BY WHICH UNLICENSED
UNREGISTERED AND ILLEGAL
FIREARMS OR TRAFFIC THROUGH
SECONDARY MARKETS. MY STAFF
RECENTLY ATTENDED A GUN SHOW AT
THE ORANGE COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS
AND WHILE THEY'RE WAITING IN
LINE TO GET IN THEY WERE
INUNDATED WITH OFFERS TO
PURCHASE VARIOUS TYPES OF
WEAPONS. BY PEOPLE WORKING THE
LINES TO TRY TO MAKE OFF THE
BOOKS TRANSACTIONS. ACCORDING
TO GIFFORDS LAW CENTER TO
PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE GUN SHOWS
OFTEN CREATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CIRCUMVENT GUN SAFETY LAWS. AND
ARE A COMMON VENUE FOR STRAW
PURCHASES AN ILLEGAL GUN
TRANSFERS. AT ZERO EIGHT
ALCOHOL TOBACCO AND FIREARMS
REPORT ALSO DESCRIBED GUN SHOWS
AS A MAJOR TRAFFICKING CHANNEL.
AND FOUND THE GUN SHOWS WERE
THE SECOND LARGEST SOURCE OF
ILLEGALLY TRAFFICKED FIREARMS
IN THIS COUNTRY. AND ALSO TO
SIX ARE NOT AVAILABLE BECAUSE
DATA IS NOT COLLECTED THE
SHOWS. IT'S WIDELY BELIEVED THE
GUN SHOWSARE A MAJOR CONDUIT.
PERHAPS THE MAJOR CONDUIT FOR
THE SALE OF GHOST GUNS. WHICH
ARE DONE PRECURSOR CURSOR PARTS
DESIGNED TO BE ASSEMBLED INTO A
WORKING FIREARM. BECAUSE THESE
ARE NOT TECHNICALLY FIREARMS
THEY DO NOT HAVE SERIAL NUMBERS
AND NOT REGISTERED AT THE TIME
OF SALE. INDEED WHEN I RECENTLY
VISITED A GUN SHOW THE MOST
POPULAR VENDORS. BY FAR WERE
THE ONES SELLING THOSE KIND
KITS. DESIGNED TO BE TURNED IN
FIREARMS I CAME TO GLOCK
PISTOLS AN A. R. FIFTEEN RIFLES.
THIS AS YOU KNOW IS A TOP
PRIORITY FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
GHOST GUNS HAVE BECOME A COP
USED IN CRIME. BUT I SAY EVEN
IF THEY WERE ZERO SALES OF
ILLEGAL NLICENSED OR GHOST
GUNS. I WOULD EVER DO YOU THAT
YOU SHOULD STILL SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE GUN SHOWS ARE
DESIGNED FOR ONE PURPOSE. TO
SELL GUNS INDUSTRY BE GUNS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. AND THEY ARE
INCREDIBLY EFFECTIVE AT THAT.
THERE ARE NO REPORTED
STATISTICS ON HOW MANY GUNS GET
SOLD FROM THESE GUN SHOWS. IT
IS CLEARLY A MASSIVE NUMBER.
THOUSANDS OF FIREARMS MAYBE
MORE ARE SOLD EACH DAY THERE'S
A GUN SHOW. THAT'S THOUSANDS
MORE FIREARMS THAT GO INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES EVERY TIME THERE'S
A GUN SHOW IN YOUR COUNTY. AND
THIS IS SUCH A DEADLY DEADLY
PROBLEM. AS STUDY AFTER STUDY
AFTER STUDY HAS SHOWN. MORE
GUNS UNSURPRISINGLY MEANS MORE
GUN VIOLENCE. COUNTRIES WITH
MORE GUNS HAVE MORE GUN
VIOLENCE. STATES WITH MORE GUNS
HAVE MORE GUN VIOLENCE.
HOUSEHOLDS WITH MORE GUNS ARE
MORE LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE GUN
VIOLENCE. NOW SINCE THAT
WEEKEND WHEN WE EXPERIENCE THE-
PASO IN DAYTON SHOOTINGS. THE
WEEKEND WHEN I VOWED AND GUN
SHOWS AT THE COUNTY FAIR
GROUNDS WE HAVE HAD HUNDREDS OF
MASS SHOOTINGS. INCLUDING THE
MASS SHOOTING LAST WEEK IN SAN
JOSE. AND THE SHOOTING ORANGE
IN MY DISTRICT EARLIER THIS
YEAR. OVER FIFTY THOUSAND
AMERICANS AND MANY CALIFORNIANS
HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES. DUE TO
GUN VIOLENCE INCLUDING THE NINE
VICTIMS OF LAST WEEK'S SAN JOSE
SHOOTING. AS WELL AS THIS
COMPUTING WITH SIX YEAR OLD
BOY. APPARENTLY DUE TO ROAD
RAGE AND MY DISTRICT ON THE
FIFTY FIVE JUST A FEW WEEKS
AGO. NO WE DON'T KNOW WHERE
THOSE GUNS WERE WERE PICKED UP.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY'RE
PURCHASED THE GUNS USED TO
COMMIT THOSE MURDERS. BUT IT IS
VERY LIKELY THAT MANY OF THEM
HAVE COME FROM GUN SHOWS. EACH
ONE OF THESE VIOLENT DEATHS.
FOR A MASSIVE HOLE IN THEIR
FAMILIES IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AMONG THEIR LOVED ONES. NEVER
POINTED SO THESE COUNTRIES
ARGUE THAT ENDING GUN SHOWS
WILL DEPRIVE THEM OF REVENUE.
HE'S GONE SHOW CAN BRING IN UP
TO HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS TO THE FAIRGROUNDS. BUT
THIS IS JUST A SMALL FRACTION
OF THE REVENUE GENERATED BY
FAIRGROUNDS. MORE IMPORTANTLY
THOUGH IT IS UNDISPUTABLE THAT
THE COSTS OF GUN VIOLENCE
ECONOMIC MORAL SPIRITUAL. ARE
ASTRONOMICALLY HIGHER. THE
OPPOSITION ALSO CLAIMS THAT
THIS BILL GOES TOO FAR AND EACH
COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS SHOULD BE
ABLE TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS ON WHETHER TO ACCEPT
OR DENY GUN SHOWS AS A MATTER
OF LOCAL CONTROL. AS A MATTER
OF SUBSTANCE THIS IS INCORRECT.
WHEN YOU TALK TO THE BOARD
MEMBERS OF COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS.
THEY WILL TELL YOU THAT THEY-
NO FIDUCIARY DUTIES TO THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY. THEIR SOLE
DUTY. IS TO ENSURE THE SOLVENCY
THEIR PROGRAMS AND THEY TELL
YOU THAT THEY'RE OBLIGATED TO
CONTRACT WITH GUN SHOW
OPERATORS. NO MATTER WHAT THE
PEOPLE IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES MIGHT WANT OR SAY.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO PUSH BACK ON
THE ARGUMENT LOCAL CONTROL AS A
MATTER OF PRINCIPLE. THIS
AUGUST BODY SETS THE STANDARD
FOR THE STATE AND THEIR MANY
INSTANCES IN WHICH WE DECIDE
THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN
STATEWIDE VALUES. THAT WE WANT
TO DICTATE REGARDLESS OF WHAT
LOCALS MIGHT THINK. WE REQUIRE
THAT EVERY CHILD BE VACCINATED
WITH DESPITE WHAT THE
PROTESTERS OUTSIDE MIGHT MIGHT
DEMAND. WE REQUIRE THAT
WORKPLACES BE SAFE FROM
DANGEROUS CONDITIONS OR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OR ASSAULT. WE
REQUIRE THAT CERTAIN HEALTH AND
LABOR STANDARDS BE MET WE DO
THIS DESPITE THE FACT THAT OF
COURSETHERE ARE SOME LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT MIGHT
DISAGREE WITH OUR STATEWIDE
VALUES. AND THAT IS WHAT THIS
IS ABOUT TODAY IT'S ABOUT
VALUES IF THIS BILL PASSES OUT
HIS BODY WE WILL BE SAYING
LOUDLY. THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS NOT GOING TO
CONTINUE SANCTIONING. AND
ENDORSING THE DISTRIBUTION OF
MORE GUNS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
OUT OF STATE PROPERTY. WELL WE
RESPECT THE CONTOURS OF THE
SECOND AMENDMENT. AND THE
RIGHTS OF PRIVATE INDIVIDUALS
TO LEGALLY SELL GUNS ON PRIVATE
PROPERTY. WE DO NOT NEED TO
ALLOW STATE PROPERTY. PROPERTY
THIS TAXPAYER OWNED TO BE USED
TO DISSEMINATE MORE GUNS. AND
HENCE MORE GUN VIOLENCE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. IN TWO THOUSAND
pBEEN OVER TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
MASS SHOOTINGS NATIONWIDE. AND
ALREADY OVER SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
LIVES LOST TO GUN VIOLENCE.
THIS SENSELESS VIOLENCE HAS
RAVAGED COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. WHICH SHOOTINGS IN
SANTA BARBARA SAN FRANCISCO.
OAKLAND SANTA ANA SAN DIEGO
COMPTON YUBA CITY STOCKED.
ORANGE CITRUS HEIGHTS AND OF
COURSE SAN JOSE. THE SECOND
AMENDMENT ALLOWS PRIVATE
PARTIES TO OWN GUNS BUT IT DOES
NOT REQUIRE THAT OUR STATE
PLAYED ACTIVE ROLE IN HELPING
TO SELL MORE FIREARMS. I'M NOT
IS ENOUGH THIS IS OUR CHANCE TO
DRAW A LINE IN THE SAND AND SAY
LOUDLY AND CLEARLY THAT THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA WILL
NOT PROFIT OFF THE SALE OF
GUNS. AND GUNVIOLENCE AND IT
WILL NOT HELP TO DISSEMINATE
MORE GUNS AND THE RESULTING GUN
VIOLENCE IN OUR COMMUNITIES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR NELSON.
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE CENTER I WAS NOT
INTENDING TO GET UP ON THIS
BILL AND DEBATE BUT THE
INTERPRETER MARKS AND I JUST
LISTENED TO DISPOSE ME TO STAND
UP AND SPEAK OUT FOR THE SECOND
AMENDMENT AND AGAINST THOSE WHO
DISDAIN THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
WEST THE SECOND AMENDMENT. DO
YOU EVER THINK OF WHO PULLS THE
TRIGGER NO THIS LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION ARE RELEASING
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF FELONS AND
CRIMINALS INTO OUR COMMUNITIES.
THEY DON'T USE GUNS ALL KNOW
THOSE ARE ALL GOOD
REHABILITATED SOULS. WE SHOULD
LOCK THEM UP WELL WE'RE GOING
TO CLOSE A PRISON. WHO WERE IN
THE PRISONS. PEOPLE WHO HAVE
USED GUNS AND OTHER WEAPONS.
WOW. YOU WANT TESTIMONY TO HOW
SUCCESSFUL THIS GUN CONTROL
STUFF IS TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF
THEIR GROUP. H. AND CITIES. NEW
YORK COMES TO MIND CHICAGO
COMES TO MIND. IT'S GOING TO
CONTROLLER IS. DID SOMEBODY GET
THE GUN YES. I DO NOT AGREE THE
PEOPLE GO TO GUN SHOWS TO GET
THE GUNS. TO COMMIT CRIMES.
THAT'S MUCH TOO VISIBLE. AND
I'VE DEALT WITH A LOT MORE
KILLERS. USERS OF GUNS IN ANY
OF YOU HAVE. AND IN READING THE
RECORDS OF THESE INDIVIDUALS-
CENTRAL FILES EVERYTHING ABOUT
THEIR LIVES. I DON'T REMEMBER
ONE WHO FIRED THE GUN AT A GUN
SHOW. NOT JUST SOMEBODY
PROBABLY STILL BUT THAT
INFLAMED RHETORIC THAT WE'RE
LISTENING TO HERE LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN ENOUGH- URGING NO
VOTE. CENTERING ON THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO SIXTY FOUR
AND THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY FOR BRINGING THIS
MATTER FORWARD I HAVE HEARD
FROM THOUSANDS OF HUNDREDS OF
CONSTITUENTS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN MY DISTRICT WITH
CONCERNS RELATED TO THE SALE OF
FIREARMS ON STATE PROPERTY.
NAMELY FAIRGROUNDS EVERY
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC SAFETY
CONCERNS INCLUDING ILLEGAL
SALES THAT'S THE FIREARMS AND
THE SALES OF PARTS AND
INSTRUCTIONS TO CONVERTS
STANDARD FIREARMS FIREARMS INTO
MORE DANGEROUS WEAPONS. I ALSO
RISE TODAY AS SOMEONE THAT ON
MAY TWENTY THIRD TWENTY
FOURTEEN. HAD TO CALL STUDENTS
OF MINE AT UC SANTA. MY
DISTRICT HAS NOT ONLY FACE TO
THE MASS SHOOTING. PROBLEM IN
CRISIS THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
COUNTRY BUT I ALSO SHARE OF
INTER COUNTY AND THINK OF THE
BORDERLINE SITUATION IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. THIS IS ABOUT FINDING
WAYS TO KEEP GUNS OUT OF FOLKS
HANDS WHO SHOULDN'T HAVE THEM
THIS IS A SAFETY MEASURE. I
SHARE THE BELIEF THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT BE IN
THE BUSINESS OF FACILITATING
GUN SALES. AND THAT THERE ARE
MANY OTHER VENUES FOR
CONSTITUENTS TO LEGALLY
PURCHASE FIREARMS WITHOUT USING
STATE PROPERTY. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR QUESTION THE AUTHOR
PLEASE WE'LL BE OFF TO THE
QUESTION. YES THROUGH THE CHAIR
IN A CHAIR- FUTURITY AUTHOR IS
THERE ANY DATA THAT YOU HAVE
THAT SHOWS THAT ANY- CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY HAS TAKEN PLACE THIS
PLACE WITH FIREARMS PURCHASED
FROM A GUN SHOW AT A STATE
FACILITY I'M SORRY I HEAR THE
QUESTION IS THERE ANY DATA OR
INFORMATION THAT YOU CAN SHARE
THAT SHOWS THAT- SOME CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY OR A CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
HAS TAKEN PLACE. WITH THESE
FROM THE SALE OF OR A PURCHASE
OF A FIREARM FROM AGAIN SHOW OR
ON STATE PROPERTY AS I THINK I
MENTIONED THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION I APPRECIATE THAT AND
I THINK AS I MENTIONED IN MY
OPENING REMARKS. OUR DATA IS
NOT COLLECTED ARE PROVIDED BY
THE OPERATORS OF THE GUN SHOW
AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THE ATF AND FBI DON'T COLLECT
THAT DATA ANECDOTALLY WE KNOW
THAT A LOT OF UNLICENSED AND
ILLEGAL GUNS ARE SOLD I HAVE
MANY REPORTS OF THAT HAPPENING.
AS I MENTIONED MY STAFF WAS-
OFFERED THE PURCHASE OF
PRESUMABLY ILLEGAL WEAPONS WHEN
THEY WERE WAITING IN LINE AND
THAT THAT AN ECHO FROM MY STAFF
WAS CONSONANT WITH WITH OTHER
ACCOUNTS THAT I'VE HEARD BUT
AGAIN THERE'S NO DATA ON THIS
POINT. AND THAT'S UNFORTUNATELY
PART OF THE PROBLEM HERE. I'M
OWN TIME THINKING MADAM CHAIR
ARM MISMATCH PRESIDENT- YOU
KNOW I HAVE TO TELL YOU GUYS
THAT- PEOPLE PURCHASE FIREARMS
FROM THE SCANSHOWS ALL THE
TIME THESE GUN SHOWS ARE A DRAW
TO SEE IN- FIREMAN DIZZY AS
PEOPLE THAT LIKE TO SHOOT FOR
SPORT CHIEF- HUNTING. OR YOU
KNOW SELF PROTECTION WHICH IS
GUARANTEED- TO US UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION. I CAN TELL YOU MY
FAMILY MYSELF WE BOUGHT
FIREARMS FRIEND- GUN SHOWS.
WE'VE NEVER COMMITTED A CRIME
WITH THEM. AND I CAN PROMISE
YOU AND TELL YOU THAT THE
CRIMINAL ELEMENT OUT THERE THE
CRIMINAL ELEMENT. OUT THERE IS
NOT GOING TO A GUN SHOW TO
PURCHASE A FIREARM AND TO
REGISTER TO APPLY FOR AN A AN
APPLICATION THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
PROVIDE THEIR SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS OR DRIVER'S LICENSE
NUMBER. AND ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION THAT'S REQUIRED.
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT WAITING
TEN DAYS OR THIRTY DAYS TO
PURCHASE A FIREARM FOR MAKING
SURE THAT THEY HAVE TO GO BACK
AND PICK UP. THE CRIMINAL
ELEMENT IS GETTING THEIR GUNS
OFF THE STREET. NOT FROM THESE
GUN SHOWS THESE GUN SHOWS ARE A
LEGAL MECHANISM AND A WAY TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE- INDIVIDUALS
WHO WANT TO PURCHASE FIREARMS
FOR THEIR FAMILY- AND MAKE IT
AVAILABLE TO THEM. IN THEIR
AREAS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
WHERE THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
THESE- STATE FAIRGROUNDS. IT IS
A LOCAL CONTROL INTO IT- ISSUE.
AND I AGREE AS WELL IF YOU
DON'T WANT THEM IN ORANGE
COUNTY WE LIKE THEM IN KERN
COUNTY. AND IT DRAWS. A LOT OF
FUNDRAISING MECHANISMS FOR
COMMUNITIES- IN OUR COMMUNITY
NONPROFITS. IT DRAWS- SUPPORT
FOR THE BOYS AND GIRLS TRIBE
CLUB SUPPORT FOR HOUSE BOYS
CAMP IT IT IT. IT'S A WAY TO
RAISE MONEY FOR THE COMMUNITY
AS WELL. IT'S A GOOD USE OF
RESOURCES FOR THE STATE THEY
GET TO. REAP THE BENEFITS OF
LEASING THE FACILITY AND I CAN
GUARANTEE YOU AGAIN IF YOU TALK
TO ANY LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
OR ANY PERSON THAT IS ENGAGED
IN THIS TYPE OF ACTIVITY-
ESPECIALLY ON THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SIDE WHETHER IT'S
THE SHERIFF THE LOCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENT POLICE TV'S. OR ATF.
CRIMINAL ELEMENTS ARE NOT GO WE-
TO THESE. TO PURCHASE A
FIREARM. AND OBVIOUSLY WITH IT
NEW DATA THAT'S UNDER THE GNU
LINKER- THE SOFTWARE THAT'S
AVAILABLE WHEN YOU GO TO
PURCHASE A FIREARM OR
AMMUNITION YOU HAVE TO PUT
STUFF INTO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WEBSITE IF YOU DON'T
HAVE TO DO G. NUMBER THEN YOU
CAN'T PURCHASE IT IT'S DENIED A
PURCHASE. AND THAT'S THE SAME
THING THAT THESE THESE-
FIREARMS DEALERS HAVE TO PASS
OR USE WHEN THEY'RE SELLING
FIREARMS AT A GUN DEALERSHIPS.
IT IS NOT THE CRIMINAL ELEMENT
THAT IS GETTING THESE FIREARMS
AT THIS FACILITY IS A LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS THAT ARE GOING
TO PURCHASE FIREARMS OF THEIR
CHOICE. UNDER THE CONSTITUTION
WITH THEIR WHICH THEY ARE
ALLOWED TO DO. AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
SENATOR MELINDA IS. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- AT THE
SENATORS I RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL TODAY AND I WANT
TO SAY THAT WHILE I SHARE THE
INTENT THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
WHICH IS TO REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE
AND I THINK THAT IS A COMMON
DENOMINATOR AMONG ALL OF THE
SENATORS HERE IN THE CHAMBER.
WORDS LIKE PRESUMABLY
ANECDOTALLY ARE NOT WORDS THAT
BELONG IN THE CONTEXT OF TRYING
TO CONVINCE SOMEONE TO SUPPORT
A PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT IS
GOING TO KEEP PEOPLE FROM BEING
ABLE TO EXERCISE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT THERE IS
NO EVIDENCE THAT IS BEING
OFFERED BY THE AUTHOR NOR
ANYONE ELSE FRANKLY. TO SUGGEST
THAT. MASS SHOOTINGS THAT TAKE
PLACE IN CALIFORNIA ARE BEING
CONDUCTED WITH WEAPONS THAT
WERE PURCHASED AT A GUN SHOW.
THAT EVIDENCE JUST ISN'T THERE
THE AUTHOR CAN'T PRODUCE IT NO
ONE IS PRODUCING IT IT IS
ANECDOTAL IT IS PRESUMED. THAT
IS A FOOL'S ERRAND TO GO DOWN
THAT PATH TO SUGGEST THAT YOU
THINK THIS IS TAKING PLACE IN
BECAUSE YOU DON'T LIKE FIREARMS
THEREFORE. WE SHOULD MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS POLICY. IT IS
A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT FOR
PEOPLE TO BEAR ARMS AND IT'S A
RATE THAT THEY CHOOSE TO
EXERCISE IN PURCHASING A
FIREARM AT A GUN SHOW THAT
HAPPENS TO BE ADDED AT A STATE
FACILITY. MORE IMPORTANTLY
USURPING THE AUTHORITY OF
LOCALS I THOUGHT FOR THOSE WHO
CAME FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS JEALOUSLY
GUARDED I THOUGHT WE LIKE TO
LOCAL CONTROL I GUESS EXCEPT IF
IT'S FOR SOMETHING THAT WE
DON'T LIKE. BECAUSE THEY'RE
SELLING T. SHIRTS. THAT WE
DISAGREE WITH OUR MASKS. THE I
HAVE A MESSAGE ON IT THAT WE
DON'T LIKE. BUT THE LOCALS
DECIDE WHAT THEY WANT IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. THE LOCALS ARE
VERY GOOD AT LETTING THEIR
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS KNOW
WHAT THEY LIKE WHAT THEY DON'T
LIKE AND THEY'RE VERY GOOD AT
EXACTING CHANGE. FROM
ORGANIZING WITHIN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES TO LET THEIR LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS KNOW WHAT
THEY WANT. AND I JUST AS A
FINAL POINT. I DO FIND IT
IRONIC THAT THIS BODY WILL
HAPPILY VOTE FOR BILLS THAT
ALLOW PEOPLE. TO BE LET OUT OF
PRISON OR JAIL EARLY HAVING
COMMITTED A CRIME. WITH A
FIREARM BUT THEN YOU TURN
AROUND AND YOU WANT TO. TARGET
GUN PURCHASES AND IT'S- IT'S A
LITTLE SCHIZOPHRENIC COULD BE
ASKED ME SO I WOULD URGE A NO
VOTE THANK YOU. SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
HIGH RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF.
SP TWO SIXTY FOUR WHICH IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE I AM JUST
KINDA BAFFLED AT THIS TERM
CRIMINAL ELEMENT. YOU'RE A
CRIMINAL IF YOU BUY A GUN
LEGALLY AND YOU GO OUT AND
COMMIT A MASS SHOOTING. EVERY
MASS SHOOTING IN THIS COUNTRY
SO FAR HAS BEEN BY A LEGALLY
PURCHASED GUNS SO WHY NOT EMAIL
HIM A CRIMINAL ELEMENT. THIRD
NOTE DIFFERENT THAN THE SO
CALLED BAD GUYS WHO'VE BEEN
RELEASED OUT OF PRISON EARLY
WHO HAVE NO EVIDENCE OF THE ON
GOING OUT AND COMMITTING MASS
SHOOTINGS AND KILLING PEOPLE
WITH FIREARMS THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE MEASURE AT SOME POINT WE
HAVE TO SAY. ANOTHER WAS ENOUGH
HOW MANY GUNS DO WE NEED ON THE
STREET HOW MANY ASSAULT WEAPONS
DO WE NEED TO OWN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA HOW MANY. MORE
PEOPLE HAVE TO LOSE THEIR LIFE.
HAS A SIX YEAR OLD DRIVING DOWN
THE STREET WITH HIS MOTHER ON
THE WAY TO SCHOOL. SHOP BY
SOMEONE WHO PROBABLY LEGALLY
OWNS A GUN. SO WHAT WOULD THIS
CRIMINAL ELEMENT THE CRIMINAL
ELEMENT IS THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
GOING OUT KILLING INNOCENT
PEOPLE EVERY DAY WHAT DO YOU
HAVE A RICHER GONE OR NOT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. SENATOR
NELSON. MATTER PRESENT LADIES
GEM OF THE SENATE FOR A SECOND
TIME IN MY PREVIOUS DEBATE AT
THE NIGHT NOT MENTIONED
SOMETHING. AND THAT'S- THE
PREVIOUS ATTORNEYS GENERAL OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ONLY A
HANDFUL OF US HAVE WAXED
OUTRAGE THAT THESE ATTORNEYS
GENERAL HAVE MADE NO PROGRESS.
CONFISCATING THE GUNS LAW
REQUIRES THEM TO. WHERE THERE'S
A FELON WHO HAS USED A GUN AND
HAS BEEN RELEASED. UNDER ORDER
OF LAW HAVING SERVED THEIR TIME
THAT THEY ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO
HAVE DONE. BUT A. HUNDRED
THOUSAND. ALTHEA NOW THAT
DOESN'T MEAN ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND GUNS THAT'S ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE. WHO
ARE PROHIBITED ARMED PROHIBITED
PERSONS. AND YOU KNOW DARN WELL
THAT MOST OF THEM HAVE MORE
THAN ONE GUY. BUT THE ATTORNEYS
GENERALIZATIONS HAD THEIR STAFF
COME BEFORE THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. ONE YEAR IT WAS WELL
HOW MUCH WOULD IT TAKE. TO
CLEAN UP. THE WHOLE BACKLOG.
ALL TWENTY MILLION OKAY WE GIVE
TWENTY MILLION ALL YEAR LATER
THAT'S WHY I DIDN'T GO DOWN.
WELL WE COULDN'T HIRE ENOUGH
PEOPLE. BECAUSE WE CAN'T PAY AS
HIGH A SALARY AS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- STILL ANOTHER YEAR
GOES BY IF YOU KNOW THE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS. HI NO PROGRESS
MADE. AND YET NO PROGRESS MADE
STILL. THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO
ORDER KNOWN. CONVICTED HELLO
WELL WE WILL GET AROUND TO IT
SOMEDAY. NOW IF WE CAN'T GET
WITH THOSE INDIVIDUALS WE KNOW
WHERE THEY'RE AT AND- ALL THAT
LEAVES ME TURNING GENERAL JUST
DOES NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES.
WELL I SAY THAT WE TAKE THAT
AWAY FROM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND GIVE IT TO SOMEBODY WHO
COULD DO THE JOB AND GIVE THE
MONEY TO LOCAL POLICE. AND
SHERIFF'S. NOT SOMEONE TO HAVE
A GREAT FIGURE IN THAT. BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO DESTROY LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN AMERICA. OR
DOWNSIZE OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
CAPABILITIES. THIS IS A NEVER
NEVER LAND FOLKS. BUT TAKE A
LOOK. WHO'S CREATED SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS. YOUR ATTORNEYS
GENERAL. ONE OF. IT'S BEEN A
IT'S BEEN REFERENCE THE DATA IS
NOT COLLECTED I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT- WE REMINDED FOLKS
THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY- THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SIXTY ONE WHICH I
AUTHORED THAT WORKED TO COLLECT
DATA- WE DO HAVE EVIDENCE THAT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
HAD FOUND ILLEGAL SALES BUT WE
WANTED TO KNOW HOW MUCH OF A
PROBLEM THIS WAS AND THEREFORE
THIS LEGISLATURE DID PASS-
THIS. THIS BILL IT WAS
SUPPORTED BY OUR ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE AND- THERE WAS
NO OPPOSITION THAT WAS RECEIVED
FOR THAT BILL AS I WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE ALSO EXISTING TOOLS
THAT WOULD COMPLEMENT AT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. SENATOR
BURGESS. WHEN PRESIDENT I
WASN'T. I DON'T THINK WE NEED
TO GET INTO A CAR I NEED TO GET
INTO- THE POINTS THAT WERE MADE
EARLIER BUT MAYBE I COULD POSE
A QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR AND IF
HE'S NOT IN A POSITION TO
ANSWER IT- MAYBE I CAN GET THE
INFORMATION SOMETIME LATER
WOULD IT BE EXPRESSED WRITTEN
OF THE AUTHOR. HE WILL TAKE IT
THERE. SO MY QUESTION TO YOU IS
I'M HEARING TWO DIFFERENT SIDES
OF THIS ARGUMENT EACH SIDE
SEEMS TO BE LOVING- FAX OR
GENERALIZATION OF FACTS I
SHOULD SAY AGAINST ONE ANOTHER.
SO WHERE IS THE DATA ON THIS
AND IF CALIFORNIA HAS NOT
ACCUMULATED MAYBE OTHER STATES
HAVE. WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE
CRIMES- THAT ARE ON THE RECORD
CAN BE TRACED TO A GUN SHOW
PURCHASE. WHAT PERCENTAGE OF%
CRIMES OR INVOLVED LLEGALLY
OBTAINED FIREARMS- I THINK WE
HEARD FROM ONE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES THAT ALL THE MASS
SHOOTINGS WERE FROM- THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED AMERICA ARE FROM
FIREARMS PURCHASED LEGALLY I
DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT.
AND I WOULD LOVE IF SOMEBODY
WOULD PUT SOME SCIENCE AND DATA
INTO THIS DEBATE BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW IT SENDS TENS TO BE
VISCERAL. AND VERY PASSIONATE
BUT I THINK IT'S HELPFUL FOR US
TO FIGURE OUT WHERE WE ARE. ON
THE METRICS. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION. I
WOULD BE EAGER TO WORK WITH YOU
SENATOR ON MEASURES TO FIND
MORE DATA AS YOU KNOW CONGRESS
HAS. FOR A LONG TIME HAD A BAN
ON RESEARCH RELATED TO
FIREARMS- AND FATALITIES- AND
SO THAT IS OBVIOUSLY HAMPERED
SOME OF THIS WAS JUST STARTING
TO COLLECT THE DATA- AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE WE DON'T HAVE
DATA ON WHERE THE GUNS GO. AT
IT IS NOT COLLECTED- WE DO I
WAS TOLD THAT THAT THE IT SORT
OF ROUGH ESTIMATE MANY
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA. IS
THAT ROUGHLY HALF OF GUNS ARE
SOLD AT GUN SHOWS AND AS IN
COMMUNITIES LIKE ORANGE COUNTY.
AND SO IF YOU WERE TO SAY THAT
A GUN THAT WAS LEGALLY
PURCHASED. WAS USED IN A CRIME
AND I WANT TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM MARTINEZ POINTS THAT. YOU
KNOW A LOT OF THE CRIMINAL
ELEMENT TO IT YOU KNOW. THAT
THE PURCHASE OF GUNS LEGALLY
THEY'RE NOT CRIMINALS UNTIL
THEY GO SHOOT SOMEONE- BUT- YOU
KNOW I THINK YOU COULD PROBABLY
HAVE A COIN FLIP I WOULD SAY
IT'S A COIN FLIP. AT THE TWO
RECENT SHOOTINGS IN ORANGE THE
SHOOTING ON THE FIFTY FIVE OF
THE SIX YEAR OLD BOY IN HIS CAR
SEAT. THE MASS SHOOTING WE KNOW
THOSE GUNS WERE WHAT WE KNOW
THAT THE FIRST GUN THE GUNS
USED IN MASS SHOOTINGS LEGALLY
PURCHASED THE GUNS. ARE SO IT'S
A COIN FLIP US ARE SAYING THIS
TO SOME FOLKS- AT THE AG'S
OFFICE. PROBABLY CONFLICT THAT
THAT THOSE GUNS WERE PURCHASED
AT A GUN SHOW GIVEN THAT IT WAS
IN ORANGE COUNTY. BUT WE DON'T
HAVE THE DATA SO I WOULD BE
EAGER TO WORK ITH YOU AND
OTHERS IN THIS BODY. TO TRY TO
FIND THAT DATA WE DO KNOW THIS
HOWEVER THAT. MORE GUNS EQUALS
MORE GUN VIOLENCE AND I THINK
THAT YOU KNOW I JUST WANNA BE
CLEAR THAT THERE'S BEEN SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT MASS
SHOOTINGS. CRIMINAL ELEMENT-
YOU KNOW THEY COULD BE SUICIDE
ACCIDENT IT COULD BE SOMEONE A
DOMESTIC DISPUTE AND BY THE WAY
MOST GUN SHOOTINGS THAT
HAPPENED APPEARS IN IN THE PAST
YEAR A NICKEL BID. FOR
DOMESTICALLY VIOLENT ASSAULTS
AND SUICIDE. AND THOSE ARE THE
TYPES OF SHOOTINGS THAT WE SAW
HAPPEN QUITE FREQUENTLY. AND AS
YOU KNOW IF YOU FOLLOW SUICIDE
STATISTICS- TYPICALLY IF YOU'RE
NOT USING A GUN THE FIRST
ATTEMPT AT SUICIDE DOESN'T
SUCCEED. AND THEN TYPICALLY
THEY GET HELP AND SO THERE'S
SOME ABILITY TO REHABILITATE
THEMSELVES. OUT WITH A GUN IF
YOU OWN A GUN THE LIKELIHOOD OF
COURSE THAT YOU COULD PUT
YOURSELF IN A SUCCESSFUL THAT
SUICIDE IS CLOSE TO A HUNDRED
PERCENT- SO. YOU KNOW THESE ARE
THE TYPES OF THINGS WERE SAYING
BUT THERE IS A VERY VERY CLEAR
INDICATION THAT JUST TAKE MY
WORD FOR THE HARVARD INJURY
CONTROL SPENT- IN RESEARCH
CENTER. IN MANY MANY OTHER
SCHOLARS HAVE REPEATEDLY FOUND
THIS STUDY AFTER STUDY AFTER
STUDY. SHOWS A VERY STRONG
CORRELATION BETWEEN. THE AMOUNT
OF GUNS THE AVAILABILITY OF
GUNS IN THE COMMUNITY OR
HOUSEHOLD. AND THE LIKELIHOOD
OF GUN VIOLENCE. HANK YOU AND
I AND I WOULD LIKE. IF I CAN
GET SOME. GET SOMEBODY FOR. OF
THE FACT THAT WE- DON'T HAVE
IT. ACCUMULATED I THINK IT'S A
LITTLE SHOCKING ESPECIALLY AS-
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD ON PUBLIC
POLICY. THAT DEALS WITH A
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
RIGHT. THAT IF WE ARE FLYING
BLIND BLIND OR ANECDOTALLY.
THAT WE PAUSE. AND IN THE
INTEREST OF GOOD PUBLIC POLICY
ACCUMULATE SS. AND DISCUSS
THESE ISSUES. ON THE MERITS
BASED ON THE METRICS- I THINK
THAT WOULD BE FOR. A MUCH
STRONGER. NON REFLEXIVE TYPE OF
PUBLIC POLICY. AND I KNOW THAT
YOU WERE A CAR LOT PROFESSOR
FELLOW PROFESSOR SO I WOULD
JUST POINT OUT TO YOU. THAT THE
SECOND AMENDMENT PROTECTS AN
INDIVIDUAL RIGHT TO BEAR ARMS
AND THAT WITH THE DECISION WAS
DECIDED IN HELLER RECENTLY- BYE
THAT DOES NOT GO TO THE STATES
AND COURTS THE TENTH AMENDMENT
RESERVES A SIGNIFICANT POWERS
TO THE STATES. I BELIEVE THIS
BILL IS A 100% CONSISTENT AND
CONSTANT WITH THE SECOND
AMENDMENT I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S
IN TEMPERATE TO CALL THIS.
CONSISTENT WITH THE SEGMENT
RIGHTS I HAVE NOT HEARD ANY
ARGUMENT AS TO WHY THIS WOULD
BE AN INFRINGEMENT ON THE
SECOND AMENDMENT BECAUSE IT IS
SIMPLY SAYING THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. CAN DO WHATEVER IT
WANTS WITH ITS OWN PROPERTY AND
AGAIN GIVEN THE HIGH
CORRELATION BETWEEN GUNS AND
GUN VIOLENCE. I THINK IT'S VERY
CLEAR THAT THIS IS GOOD PUBLIC
POLICY BECAUSE THE STATE SHOULD
NOT BE PROFITING FOR EVERY
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR GUN
SHOW. WE'RE PROBABLY INCREASING
SIGNIFICANTLY THE LIKELIHOOD OF
SIGNIFICANT COSTNER'S CASA
GRANDE BY ONCE IN THE STATE ARE
MUCH HIGHER. THAN A TINY. BIT
OF REVENUE THAT WE'RE RECEIVING
FROM GUNSHIPS. SENATOR COULD.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- ARISING
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO SIXTY FOUR
BUT I DO WANT TO CLARIFY THE
REASON FOR MY SUPPORT- IN THE I
WANTED TO- GO OUT OF MY WAY TO
DISASSOCIATE MYSELF IN THIS
BOAT- WITH ANY INDICTMENT ON
FREE SPEECH ACTIVITIES THAT
WOULD OCCUR IN FAIRGROUNDS OR
OTHER STATE- PROPERTIES- I WANT
TO DISASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH ANY
VILIFICATION OF LEGAL VENDORS
WHO DEAL IN THE SALE OF
FIREARMS OR HAVE THROUGH AT
FAIR GROUNDS OR THERE'S THE
PROPERTIES- AND I THINK- TO
SOME EXTENT THE OPPOSITION. IN
THE ANALYSIS IS POINTED OUT IN
RIGHTFULLY SO THAT YOU CAN
ASSOCIATE CALIFORNIA REGULATION
OF THESE GUN SHOWS WITH A
NATIONAL STATISTICS BECAUSE
HERE THE LEGISLATURE HAS DONE A
TREMENDOUS JOB OF MAKING SURE
THAT BACKGROUND CHECKS ARE IN
PLACE THE REQUIREMENTS FOR GUN
LOCKS AND SAFES AND ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT ARE REQUIRED BY
RETAIL DEALERS ARE PRESENT IN
THESE GUN SHOWS- SO WHY AM I
SUPPORTING THE BILL I'M
SUPPORTING THE BILL BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK. THAT IT'S
NECESSARY OR PROPER FIRST AID
TO CALIFORNIA PROPERTY TO BE
USED- IN THIS MANNER IN HIM I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT I
CLARIFY FOR MYSELF AND FOR THE
RECORD- A LITTLE BIT OF A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN- MY SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL AND SOME OF THE
ARGUMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN-
TOSSED AROUND. ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER TODAY I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SINGER
CENTER MANY MAY CONCLUDE
NUMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT KINS BY
BASE NO BECKER I PORCHES NO
BRADFORD. I CAN BUY A I CORTESE
I DALLY. NO DODD HI THE RUSSELL
HI AIKMAN I GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG I WISH SO HI HER TADO.
JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LLEVA. I LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. NO A CHOKE NO PAM HI
FORTUNE TINO. HI ROTH. RUBIO HI
SKINNER I STERN HI NUMBER I BY
CAL SKI FIVE WINNER I WILL. NOW
PLEASE CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS.
HER TADO. RALPH. PRICE TWENTY
NINE KNOWS NINE THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING BACK TO ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT SENATOR PAN
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL TWO
FIFTY BY SENATOR PAN AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE SENATOR PENN THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU M. PRESIDENT
SENATORS A- S. B. TWO FIFTY
WILL EASE THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS FOR HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS AND PATIENTS BY
FREEING UP TIME EXPENSE FROM
ADMINISTRATIVE TASKS WHICH
ULTIMATELY IMPROVES CARE FOR
PATIENTS. ABOUT THAT ACTUALLY
OF STUDY THAT WAS PUBLISHED-
SHOULD THAT PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS ACTUALLY SPENT LESS
THAN A THIRD OF THE TIME
ACTUALLY DOING CLINICAL WORK.
S. B. TWO FIFTY WOULD CREATE A
GOLD CARD PROCESS FOR HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS WHO HAVE A
RECORD OF GAINING APPROVALS OF
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION REQUESTS
FROM HEALTH PLANS AND HEALTH
INSURERS.THE BILL REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT MANAGED HEALTHCARE
DEPARTMENT SURE SADDAM A
METHODOLOGY BASED ON
CALCULATIONS IN THE BILL HOW
QUALIFIED PROVIDER FOR TWO
YEARS AND DEEMED APPROVAL
STATUS OF THE PROVIDER WILL NOT
HAVE TO SUBMIT. PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION REQUESTS FOR HIS
OR HER PATIENTS IN ORDER TO GET
PAID. THERE'S AN AUDIT PROCESS
PERMIT IN THE BILLTO ALLOW
HEALTH PLANS INSURERS TO CHECK
TO SEE IF THE PROVIDERS THAT
SHOULD REMAIN. THE C. TWO FIFTY
ALSO SET UP A PROCESS BY WHICH
CERTAIN FACILITY BASED
PROVIDERS CAN GET PAID THE FULL
CONTRACTED RATE BY HEALTH PLANS
INSURERS FOR SERVICES PROVIDED
IN THE CONTRACTED FACILITY. BUT
HAVING TO BILL AND COLLECT COST
SHARING FROM PATIENTS. BOTH OF
THESE PRACTICES TOGETHER WILL
GO A LONG WAY TOWARD EASING THE
MINISTRY OF BURDENS ON
PROVIDERS AND PATIENTS AVOID
DELAYS IN CARE AS P. AS
PHYSICIANS AND PATIENTS ARE
WAITING TO HEAR FROM INSURANCE
COMPANIES. AND DIRECTING
RESOURCES TO PRACTICES. TO
IMPROVE PATIENT OUTCOMES AND
ACTUALLY FOCUS ON PROVIDING
CLINICAL CARE INSTEAD OF DOING
ADMINISTRATIVE WORK
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SAYING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS
I BASE. BECKER I FORGES NO
BRADFORD I COULD BUY A FIVE
CORTEZ HE- HI DALLY NO DODD
FIVE TORONTO I EGGMAN I GLAZER.
I CONSOLIDATES I GROSS.
HERTZBERG FIVE WAYS SO. HI HER
TADO. I JONES. NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA I THE MON I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN. FIVE NIELSEN. A SHOW
BOTH NO PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO
I. ROSS I RUBIO I SKINNER. FIVE
STERN HI AMBER ALL RIGHT I LIKE
HOW SKI I WINNER I WOKE. NOW.
NIELSEN NOW PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN. ALAN I
BATES NO. GROVE. HIGHS THIRTY
ONE KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING BACK TO ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY ONE SENATOR
MCGUIRE IS READY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWELVE BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE AN ACT RELATING TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CENTER MCGUIRE
THE FLOORS YOURS. IF YOU HAVE A
WONDERFUL WEEKEND IF YOU COULD
JUST WAIT WE'LL GET THE MICRON.
TRY IT AGAIN OUR. IN ORDER. ALL
RIGHT HERE WE GO GUESS WE'LL
TRY ANOTHER MIKE SENATOR
MCGUIRE HERE'S WHERE YOU'RE
BURNING YOURS OUT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH BETTER PRESIDENTS COULD
SEE HOPE YOU HAD A WONDERFUL
WEEKEND I DON'T NEED TO TELL
YOU THAT WE'RE LIVING. IN ON
PRESIDENT TIMES OF QUALIFIERS
HERE IN THE GOLDEN STATE THE
SIZE AND SCOPE OF WILDFIRES IN
THE STATE WELL THEY'VE CHANGED
THEIR LARGER MORE DESTRUCTIVE
AND DEADLY- THAN EVER BEFORE.
THE ERA OF MEGA FIRES HERE AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE BRINGING
FORWARD SENATE BILL TWELVE WITH
SENATOR STERN. S. T. TWELVE
CENTS A MINIMUM FLOOR FOR
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE SP TWELVE SETS
UP A TRANSFORMATIONAL PROCESS
FOR THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO
ESTABLISH BOLD NEW STANDARDS
THAT. ENSURE DEVELOPMENTS AS A
WHOLE ARE DESIGNED TO WITHSTAND
FIRE NOT JUST THE BUILDINGS
WITHIN THOSE DEVELOPMENTS.
CRUCIALLY THE STANDARDS ARE
TIERED SO THAT THE STANDARDS
GETTING INCREASINGLY MORE
ROBUST AS DEVELOPMENTS GROW
LARGER. AND IT IS NOT SO COSTLY
THOUGH AS A TOTALLY PREVENT
DEVELOPMENT. THIS IS THE ONLY
pBILL IN THE LEGISLATURE THIS
YEAR THAT BALANCES THE NEED FOR
NEW HOUSING EVEN IN FIRE PRONE
AREAS WITH WILDFIRES SAFETY.
AND SAFETY OF THOSE WHO LIVE IN
THOSE HOMES THE LEGISLATURE CAN
AFFORD TO LET ANOTHER RECORD
YEAR OF FIRES GO BY WITHOUT
ACTION. THE BILL IS PROBABLY
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE CHIEFS AND FIRE DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION AND OF COURSE THE
NATIONAL FIRE PROTECTION
ASSOCIATION WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I VOTE. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON.
THIS ITEM. SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU MAY PRESIDENT. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE THANK YOU
TO MY- MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
NORTH COAST FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS. OKAY I INTRODUCE MY
OWN LEGISLATION EARLIER THIS
SESSION IS P. FIFTY FIVE IT
WOULD HAVE TAKEN A MUCH MORE%
AGGRESSIVE APPROACH. TO
LIMITING DEVELOPMENT IN THE
VERY HIGH FIRE SEVERITY ZONES.
I FRANKLY DON'T THINK WE SHOULD
BE BUILDING. DEEPER AND DEEPER
INTO THE WILLIAM EXACERBATING
RISKS FORCING OTHER TAXPAYERS
TO COVER THAT COST. HOWEVER I
MADE THAT BILL TO YOUR BILL I
AGREED TO JOIN AUTHOR- S. B.
TWELVE YOUR- WHICH IS. NOT A
STOP TO DEVELOPMENT BUT IT
ACTUALLY IS A PERMISSIVE
PROCESS TO ALLOW DEVELOPMENT OF
CERTAIN AND IF AND WHEN CERTAIN
CONDITIONS ARE MET. I THINK
THAT WE CAN MEET RE NOT.
OUTSIDE OF THE FIRE ZONE. I
THINK WE CAN DO THIS WITHOUT
HURTING OUR INSURANCE COVERAGE-
BUT I THINK S. B. TWELVE IS A
MODEST STEP FORWARD IT IS THE
ONLY BILL THE LEGISLATURE THIS
YEAR AND- AS WE MOVE THIS
AGGRESSIVE HOUSING PACKAGE I
HOPE YOU'LL JUST KEEP IN MIND-
THAT THESE MEASURES ARE. ARE
CRITICAL COMPONENTS. AS WELL.
THANKS FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SUN AND I ALSO STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE-
FOR SMILES WHEN ITHINK THE
GREAT SENATOR FOR MALIBU LOS
ANGELES FOR HIS WORK AS HE
STATED IT WAS A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT IN WHICH- THE WILDFIRE
WORKING GROUP WAS ABLE TO COME
TOGETHER AND A DESIGNATE THIS
AS A SENATE PARTY SO I WOULD
ALSO URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO VOTE
I THINK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SINGMAN
SENATOR MCGUIRE YOU MAY
CONCLUDE THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT
A PRESIDENT I DO WANNA TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU TO MY
CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES FOR
HIS TENACIOUS LEADERSHIP IS
HARD WORK THAT WE COULD NOT BE
DOING THIS WITHOUT HIM AND IT'S
A 100% PARTNERSHIP THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND MISTER SENATOR AND
ALSO FROM THE SENATOR FROM SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY. FOR ALL OF HER
WORK ON THE BONFIRE WORKING
GROUP AS WELL AS ALL THE
MEMBERS OF OUR WORKING GROUP
WE'RE GRATEFUL THANK YOU
TONIGHT AND SENATOR FOR HER
LEADERSHIP IS WHAT WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ITEM.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS HI BABES.
BACKER HI FORGES NO BRADFORD I
COULD A HI CORTESE FIVE DALLY.
NO DODD I TORONTO HI ADNAN I
GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HURTS BERG FIVE WITH SO. HI
FURTADO I JONES NO CAN LONGER.
LAYERED HI LLEVA I LIVE ALONE I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON. NO A CHOKE NO
PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO HI ROTH
FIVE RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN I
NUMBER FIVE BY CAL SKI FIVE
WINNER I WILL. NO PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBERS. BASE NO.
GROVE CAN LONGER HI. FIVE
THIRTY ONE KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER FORTY CENTER DRIVE
SO. SHE IS PREPARED PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY BY
SENATOR TORONTO AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT SENATOR
DRAWS ON THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. AS B.
TWO SEVENTY WILL ENSURE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS RECEIVE
ACCURATE AND TIMELY BARGAINING
UNIT INFORMATION WHICH THEY ARE
ALREADY ENTITLED TO BY LAW SO
THEY MAY FULFILL THEIR LEGAL
REPRESENTATIONAL DUTIES AND
MEET THE NEEDS OF BARGAINING
UNIT AS A WHOLE. EVEN THOUGH
MANY PUBLIC EMPLOYERS FOLLOW
THE LAW UNFORTUNATELY MANY
OTHERS FAILED TO MEET THOSE
OBLIGATIONS. OUT OF SEVEN IN
THE EDUCATION SECTOR OUT OF
SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY SIX LOCAL
AGE EDUCATION AGENCIES. TWO
HUNDRED FORTY TWO HAD NOT
SUBMITTED THE MONTHLY NEW HIRE
LIST AS REQUIRED BY LAW. WITH
NO CONSEQUENCES AS B. TWO
SEVENTY ESTABLISHES AN
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURE WITHPLENTY OF OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
EMPLOYER TO CURE THE PROBLEM-
BEFORE ANY. INVOLVEMENT WITH
HER THESE ARE NOT NEW
REQUIREMENTS FOR EMPLOYERS IT
SIMPLY INCENTIVIZES COMPLIANCE
DURING EMERGENCIES HAVING
ACCURATE AND TIMELY INFORMATION
IS ESSENTIAL WHAT THE STATE IS
FACING A WILDFIRE. A SHOOTING
OR PANDEMIC VIRUS WE AND THE
PUBLIC ALL OVER CALIFORNIA
EXPECT OUR PUBLIC SERVANTS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE AGAIN THIS IS
ABOUT BOTH THE MORAL AND LEGAL
DUTY OF A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
REPRESENTATIVE. THIS BILL
PASSED BOTH HOUSES LAST YEAR
WAS UNABLE TO GET TO ITS FINAL
CONCURRENCE VOTE- FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK US
FOR AN IPHONE THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I PAY NO
BECKER. HI FORTUS NO BRADFORD I
HAVE A. CORTESE HI DALLY NO
DODD I TORONTO HI EGGMAN I
GLAZER. NO CONSOLIDATES HIGH
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI WITH SO.
HI HER TADO HI JONES. JONES NO
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA I
LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MEN I NEWMAN I
NELSON. NO A SHOW OF BOTH NO
PAN. FORTINO FIVE ROCK HI RUBIO.
SKINNER. FIVE STERN I REMEMBER
I WAS CASTING HI WINNER I WILL.
NOW. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. CABRERO I. GROVE NO.
PAN I. RUBIO I. PRICE THIRTY
KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER FORTY
ONE SENATOR LEYVA. PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR LEYVA AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT. UNDER LABOUR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
OR AFTERNOON THAT'S B. TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT PROTECTS THE
PROMISED AND PAID FOR
RETIREMENT BENEFITS OF CALPERS
MEMBERS BY MAKING SURE THAT NO
HARM COMES TO RETIREE FOR ANY
COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN
PENSIONABLE COMPENSATION. THAT
WAS REPORTED TO THE SYSTEM THIS
MAJOR RESPONSE IN CASES IN
WHICH PENSION OR COMPENSATION A
RETIRED EMPLOYEES IS
RETROACTIVELY DEEMED DISALLOWED
BY CALPERS. AND THESE
INCIDENCES THE RETIRED
EMPLOYEES ARE FORCED TO PAY
BACK THE TOTAL OVERPAYMENT
AMOUNT AS WILL SUFFER PERMANENT
REDUCTIONS TO THEIR PENSIONS.
MANY RETIREES LIVED ON FIXED
INCOMES AND SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
EXPERIENCE UNEXPECTED CUTS TO
THEIR BENEFITS AT NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN LONG AFTER THEY HAVE
RETIRED. AS P. TWO SEVENTY
EIGHT GIVES RETIREES IMPORTANT
PEACE OF MIND WITH RETIREMENT
THEY EARNED AND PAID FOR OVER A
LIFE OF PUBLIC SERVICE WILL
CONSISTENTLY BE THERE
THROUGHOUT THEIR RETIREMENT
YEARS. SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A PROCESS FOR
CALPERS AND EMPLOYERS TO WORK
TOGETHER TO PROTECT RETIREE
BENEFITS AND PREVENT THESE
INSTANCES FROM EVER HAPPENING
IN THE FIRST PLACE SP TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT ALSO COMPELS
EMPLOYERS TO KEEP THEIR PROMISE
TO RETIREES AND HOLD THEM
HARMLESS FROM ANY REDUCTIONS TO
THEIR RETIREMENT AS A RESULT OF
A DISALLOWED COMPENSATION.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I THOUGHT IS. THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SINGMAN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT
KENS FIVE BATES. BACKER I FOR
JUST. BRADFORD I COME BY OTHER
HI PROTESTING HI DALLY HI TODD
HI TORONTO HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER
I CONSOLIDATE I GROW. HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO. I HER TADO HI JONES
I CAN LONGER I LAYERED. I LLEVA.
FIVE WOMEN I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON. BUT SHOW BOTH. HI CAN I
FORTUNE TINO. I BROUGHT FIVE
RUBIO. SKINNER HI STERN HI
NUMBER I BREAK OWSKI FIVE
WINNER I WILL HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES
GORGEOUS. GROVE MELINDA'S.
NIELSEN. RUBIO HI. FIVE THIRTY
FIVE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER FORTY
THREE SENATOR DRIVE SO SHE IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE TWENTY ONE BY
SENATOR TO RASO AND ACTUALLY DO
EMPLOYMENT. CENTER DRIVE SO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THERE ARE MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOMESTIC
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA THAT TWO
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS DEPEND ON
THE DEPEND ON THEM TO CARE FOR
THEIR THERE ARE AND THEIR
FAMILIES. DOMESTIC WORKERS WERE
PRIMARILY IMMIGRANT WOMEN ARE
ESSENTIAL TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY THEY DESERVE
CONSIDERATION FOR HEALTH AND
SAFETY ISSUES JUST LIKE ANYONE
ELSE WE SHOULD NOT CONTINUE TO
EXCLUDE THIS WORK GROUP OF
WORKERS FROM BASIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROTECTIONS NOT DURING
THE HEALTH PANDEMIC NOT DURING
WILDFIRES. NOT IN THE EVERYDAY
WORK THAT PUTS THEIR HEALTH AND
WELL BEING AND THAT OF THEIR
FAMILIES ON THE LINE IN THE END
MANY OF US HAVE OR WILL DEPEND
ON SOMEONE TO CLEAN OUR HOMES
WATCH OUR KIDS COOK OUR MEALS
OR TAKE CARE OF OUR ELDERLY OR
DISABLED THEY ARE PROFESSIONALS
WITH SKILLS. DURING THE
WILDFIRES THAT DEVASTATED
CALIFORNIA SOME HOUSEHOLD
DOMESTIC SERVICE M- EMPLOYEES
WERE ASKED TO STAY BEHIND HELP
WITH THE HOMES WITH THE PETS
WORKING SMOKY CONDITIONS AND
CLEAN UP TOXIC ASH. SOMEWHERE
NOT EVEN TOLD THEY WERE UNDER
MANDATORY EVACUATION ORDERS THE
CURRENT OF COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC ONLY MATTER FURTHER
MAGNIFIED THEIR VULNERABILITIES
AND THE DANGERS THEY FACE THEY
SHOULD BE COVERED UNDER CAL
OSHA'S RULES I'M GRATEFUL TO
THE BROAD COALITION INCLUDING
HELPING HANDS HELPING HANDS. A
HOUSEHOLD EMPLOYERS GROUP THAT
HAS BEEN WORKING HARD TO
SUPPORT THEIR DOMESTIC WORKERS
THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE EMPLOYERS
AND COMMITTED TO THE WELL BEING
OF THE DOMESTIC WORKERS. OUR
COLLEAGUES I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. IS THERE. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION- DEBATE. SINGMAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I AT. I FACE NO
BACKER I PORGES NO BRADFORD.
CABRERA FIVE COURTESY I DALLY
NO DODD. THEY'RE ALSO HI AIKMAN
FIVE GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES
FIVE GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG HI
WITH SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES
NO KIM AUGER I LAYERED I LABOR
HI THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S. NO MAN. NEWMAN
NIELSEN NO BUT SHOW UP BOTH. NO
TEN FIVE FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH
FIVE RUBIO. HI SKINNER. FIVE
STERN HI AMBERG I LIKE ASKING.
FIVE WINNER I WILL. PLEASE NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD I. DOT I. MAN NO.
NEWMAN I. HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS
TEN THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO ASK IF YOU DO WANT
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION THAT YOU
TAKE IT OFF THE FLOOR- IT'S
KIND OF HARD TO HEAR SOMETIMES
WITH THE CONVERSATION IN THE
BACK MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER FORTY FOUR
SENATOR CORTESE HE IS PREPARED.
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL THREE
THIRTY FIVE BY SENATOR CORTEZ
HE AN ACTOR RELATED TO WORKERS
COMPENSATION. CENTER CORTESE
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SP THREE THIRTY FIVE. A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE THAT WOULD
SEEK TO REDUCE UNREASONABLE
DELAYS ON WORKER COMPENSATION
CLAIMS. THAT'S B. THREE THIRTY
FIVE WOULD REDUCE THE TIME THAT
AN EMPLOYER HAS TO DENY. OR
ACCEPT LIABILITY FOR WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS FROM NINETY
DAYS TO FORTY FIVE DAYS. FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY EMPLOYEES IS TO
BE REDUCED TO THIRTY DAYS.
ADDITIONAL SP THREE THIRTY FIVE
WOULD IMPOSE A 10% INCREASE ON
THE AMOUNT DUE FOR ANY PAYMENT
OF COMPENSATION IS FOUND TO BE
UNREASONABLY DELAYED OR REFUSED.
FINALLY SP THREE THIRTY FIVE AN
INCREASING AMOUNT OF MEDICAL
TREATMENT EMPLOYER MUST.
IMMEDIATELY COVER FROM TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR CALLING
SOME PROVISIONS IN SB THREE
THIRTY FIVE WILL TAKEN TOGETHER
RESPOND DIRECTLY TO THE
WIDESPREAD AND TOTALLY
UNREASONABLE DELAYS AND DENIALS
USED. BY MANY EMPLOYERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THE RESULT OF THESE
TACTICS HAS BEEN WORKERS
SUFFERING WITHOUT CARE. AND
EVEN LOSING THEIR LIVES
INCLUDING THE VERY WORKERS WHO
SEEK TO MAINTAIN A PUBLIC
SAFETY. QUITE FRANKLY THIS BILL
WILL LINE THE CURRENT
PRESUMPTION MODEL WITH ITS
ORIGINAL INTENT HE CONTINUED TO
ME MAINTAIN CALIFORNIA STRONG
DISTANCE OF WORKER PROTECTIONS
I RESPECTFULLY URGE I VOTE.
THANK YOU. FOR ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SAY NONE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I AT KENS FIVE
EIGHTHS NO BACKER FIVE FOUR
JUST KNOW BRADFORD I HAVE A
AUTO. CORTESE HI DALLY. NO DODD
NO TORONTO HI ADNAN FIVE GLAZER.
GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE NO
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HER TADO.
JONES NO KAMMERER I LAYERED HI
LLEVA.I THE MON I REQUIRE. I
MELINDA'S. NO MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH. NO
PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS.
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. HI STERN HI
NUMBER I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER.
I WILL NOW. PLEASE CALL THE OB
TO MEMBERS. BY ADAM. GLAZER I.
WITH SO I. HER TADO. RALPH ROTH
I AND THEN. PLEASE CALL ME UP
TO MEMBERS. CONFIRA HI I. HER
TADO. I TWENTY NINE KNOWS TEN
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FORTY FIVE SENATOR GONZALES.
SHE IS PREPARED PLEASE READ AT
ABOUT THREE THIRTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ AND ACTUALLY
THE PRIVATE EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR
GONZALES THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SP THREE THREE EIGHT WHICH WILL
HELP PROTECT THE CENTRAL FRONT
LINE TRUCK DRIVERS AT
CALIFORNIA'S PORTS PORT TRUCK
DRIVERS HAVE BEEN THE TRIES
THEY EXPLOITED. BY BAD ACTORS
IN THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY THESE
BAD ACTORS ROUTINELY MOVE
MISCLASSIFIED WORKERS TO CUT
COSTS WRONGFULLY EXCLUDE
WORKERS FOR MINIMUM WAGE
WORKERS COMPENSATION AND THE
RIGHT TO JOIN A UNION IF THEY
SO CHOOSE AS B. THREE THREE
ADDRESSES ONGOING PROBLEM BY
ADDING TRUCKING COMPANIES AN
EXISTING JOINT LIABILITY BAD
ACTOR LIZ. IF THOSE COMPANIES
ROUTINELY MISCLASSIFIED WORKERS
ARE FAILED TO ADDRESS SERIOUS
CAL OSHA VIOLATIONS- SP THREE
THREE WILL ALSO REQUIRE SOME
COMPANIES UNDERGO AN AUDIT TO
GET OFF THE BAD ACTOR LIST.
I'VE ACTUALLY WORKED VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION TO NARROW
THE FOCUS OF THE BILL TO
INCLUDE ONLY THE MOST EGREGIOUS
BAD ACTORS AND PLAN TO AMEND
THE BILL FURTHER IN THE NEXT
HOUSE TO GIVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR AUTHORITY TO DETERMINE
WHICH COMPANIES MUST GO UNDERGO
AN AUDIT. AND I THINK THEM FOR
WORKING WITH US TRUCK DRIVERS
ARE SOCIAL WORKERS ARE CRITICAL
TO MAINTAINING THE SUPPLY CHAIN
SUPPLY CHAIN AND THEY DESERVE
STRONGER PROTECTIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER I VOTE ON
SB THREE THREE THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. GROSS. CENTER GROVE I'M
SORRY MY APOLOGIES NO THAT'S
OKAY MADAM PRESIDENT I KNOW
THAT THERE'S A CLEAR ON THAT
THE PLEXIGLASS I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AND-
BEFORE A. B. FIVE A LOT OF
TRUCK DRIVERS WERE INDEPENDENT
OWNER OPERATORS AND THEY COULD-
DRIVE WHEN THEY WANTED THEY HAD
THEIR OWN TRUCK PAYMENT THROUGH
AN INSURANCE AND- SOMETIMES OUR
KIDS ARE THEY HAD A COUPLE OF
EMPLOYEES THAT WORK FOR THEM
THAT THEY CARRIED INSURANCE ON
A SINCE EIGHTY FIVE THERE'S
BEEN A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
DISRUPTION IN THE TRUCKING AND
TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY. AND I
DO AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE ON
ONE STATEMENT THAT SHE SAID
ABOUT THE OR THE SUPPLY CHAIN-
THE KEY TO THE SUPPLY CHAIN TO
MAKING SURE THE GOODS AND
SERVICES GET KIDS GET TO THE
MARKET AND- SO THAT
CONSTITUENTS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO M. GO TO STORE
IN THE STORE SHELVES ARE NOT
BEER SO TRUCKING INDUSTRY IS
VITAL IN THAT AREA EIGHTY FIVE
DISRUPTED THAT AND ESPECIALLY
WITH OUR TRUCK DRIVERS IN THE
TRANSPORTATIO INDUSTRY THIS
BILL FURTHER AND DISRUPTS THAT
AND I WOULD ASK SPECIFICALLY
FOR. A NO VOTE ON THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. ANY FURTHER JUST.
OR DEBATE. FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE CENTER GIVES US YOU
MAY CONCLUDE THANK YOU I. MADAM
PRESIDENT- AND I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD FOR
HER COMMENTS ALTHOUGH I WOULD
SAY THIS BILL HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH EIGHTY FIVE BUT MOSTLY
JUST ABOUT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY VIOLATIONS THAT CAL OSHA
NEEDS TO BE FOCUSING ON TO
ENSURE THAT THESE EGREGIOUS
EMPLOYERS ARE ON THAT THE BAD
ACTOR LIST. IN CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION WILL AGREE
WITH US SO WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO VOTE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. HI
ARCHULETA I ADKINS FIVE BASE NO
BACKER. FIVE FORGES NO BRADFORD
I COME BY IT- I CORTESE HI
DALLY. NO DODD FIVE TORONTO HI
ADNAN I GLAZER. GONZALEZ I GROW.
NO HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO. JONES NO KAMMERER I
LAYERED I LLEVA. I LIVE ALONE I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S. NO MAN
FIVE NEWMAN I NELSON NO A SHOW
OF BOTH. NO PAN HI FORTUNE TINO.
FIVE ROTH FIVE RUBIO. HI
SKINNER. STERN FIVE AMBERG HI
WHAT KIND OF FIVE WINNER I WILL.
NOW. SENATOR GONZALEZ MOVES THE
CALL. MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER FORTY SIX
SENATOR WIENER HE IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL THREE
FIFTY SEVEN BY SENATOR WIENER
AN ACTOR LIVING TO CRIMES. THEN
WINNER THE FORGERS FIVE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH PROUD OF
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL THREE FIVE
SEVEN- WHICH REPEALS THE CRIME.
THAT IS CALLED LOITERING WITH
INTENT TO ENGAGE IN
PROSTITUTION. QUOTE UNQUOTE
THIS LEGISLATION- ALSO PERMITS
FOR THE SEALING OF RECORDS FOR
ANYONE PREVIOUSLY CONVICTED OF
THIS LOITERING OFFENSE NUMBER
FIVE THREE SEVEN SAYING FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED. FOR THIS OFFENSE
HI SINCE ITS ENACTMENT IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE- THIS
MISDEMEANOR OFFENSE ON HAS
FAILED TO PROTECT PUBLIC
SAFETY- WALL HARMING- AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY BEING
ENFORCED. AGAINST TRANSGENDER
WOMEN AND WOMEN OF COLOR. THIS
IS TRULY A PROFILING CRIME A
STATUS CRIME. A CRIME WHERE YOU
CAN BE ARRESTED NOT BASED ON
WHAT YOU'RE DOING. BUT HOW YOU
LOOK. YEAH AN OFFICER SEESYOU
STANDING ON THE SIDEWALK.
DRESSED IN A CERTAIN WAY
PERHAPS WITH TIGHT CLOTHING-
WEARING HIGH HEELS WEARING
CERTAIN KIND OF MAKE UP.
HOLDING HOLDING A PERSON A
CERTAIN WAY. HE GOT OFFICER CAN
ARREST YOU. BECAUSE THE NOT
OFFICERS SUBJECTIVISM YOU ARE
QUOTE UNQUOTE LOITERING WITH
THE INTENT TO ENGAGE IN SEX
WORK EVEN THOUGH YOU HAVEN'T
DONE ANYTHING. THIS IS NOT A
CRIME THAT SHOULD HAVE EVER
BEEN CREATED IN CALIFORNIA IT'S
NOT A CRIME THAT SHOULD EXIST
IT IS INHERENTLY A
DISCRIMINATORY PROFILING CRIME.
AT ALL IT DOES IS IT REDUCES
TRUSTS. IN LAW ENFORCEMENT BY
SOME OF THE MOST MARGINALIZED
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY WITHIN
SCARED TO GO TO THE POLICE TO
EVEN REPORT A CRIME- THIS CRIME
NEEDS TO BE REPEALED. NEW YORK
STATE JUST REPEALED ITS VERSION
OF THIS CRIME EARLIER THIS YEAR
AND CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO DO THE
SAME I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AUTO. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
I ARCHULETA HI AT KENS FIVE
BASE NO BECKER. I FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD I KERR BIO HI COURTESY
HI DELHI NO DODD HI TORONTO HI
EGGMAN I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
HIGH GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG. WAIT
SO. HI HER TADO. I JONES NO
KAMMERER I LAYERED I LABOR. I
LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MAN BY NEWMAN I
NELSON NO A SHOW OF BOTH. NO
PAN BY FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS I
RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER. STERN HI
NUMBER. WHITE HOUSE SKI FIVE
WINNER I WILL. NOW SENATOR WILL
MEET THE WINNER MOVE THE CALL.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER FORTY
SEVEN SENATOR LEE MON. SHE IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE SIXTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR EARLY MON AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE SENATOR LIEBERMAN FOR
JURORS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES TODAY
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE
HEALTH INSURANCE WITH
DEDUCTIBLES AND MAXIMUM OUT OF
POCKET COST RANGING ANYWHERE
FROM A THOUSAND TO EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS ENROLLEES
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT HEALTH NEEDS SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO TRACTOR COST
SHARING TO DETERMINE IF THEY
HAVE REACHED THEIR DEDUCTIBLE
OR MAXIMUM OUT OF POCKET COST.
ADDITIONALLY LANGUAGE BARRIERS
FINANCIAL AND HEALTH LITERACY
AND ACCESS TO BROADBAND
INTERNET ME KEEPING TRACK OF
THESE PAYMENTS EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT THE RECENT FEDERAL
RULES DO NOT GO FAR ENOUGH TO
INFORM CONSUMERS THE BURDEN OF
NAVIGATING AND TRACKING STILL
FALLS LARGELY ON THE CONSUMERS.
SB THREE SIXTY ONE MANDATE
HEALTH PLANS COMMUNICATE DURING
ANY MONTH BENNETT DURING ANY
MONTH BENEFITS WERE USED TO
ENROLL TO ENROLL. TO AN
ENROLLEE. ON THERE A CURE ALL
TOWARDS DEDUCTIBLE OR MAXIMUM.
OPT OUT FROM NOTICES SENT BY
MAIL AND HAVE THE OPTION TO OPT
BACK IN AT ANY TIME. SB THREE
SIXTY ANSWERS THAT PEOPLE HAVE
THE MOST CURRENT INFORMATION ON
THEIR CURLS AND ALL ALLOWS FOR
MORE TRANSPARENCY FROM HEALTH
PLANS AND INSURERS. THANK YOU
KNOW STRICTLY ASKED FOR AND I
BOTH. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION DEBATE SAYING MAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WITH
FALLON I ARCHULETA HI AT KINS
FIVE BASE NO BECKER HI FORGES
NO BRADFORD. CABRERA I CORTESE.
DALLY NO DODD HI TORONTO HI
ADNAN HI GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES
MY GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI WITH SO.
HI HER TADO HI JONES NO
CAMCORDER. I LAYERED I LABOR. I
LIVE MY OWN LIFE FIVE WIRE. I
MELINDA'S. NO MAN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. A SHOW OF BOTH. PAN
FIVE FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH HI
RUBIO I SKINNER. STERN I AM
BERG ALL RIGHT HI MIKE HOW SKI
FIVE WINNER I WILL NOW. A
TROUBLED NOW. SENATOR IMAN
MOVES A CALL MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FORTY NINE SENATOR PAN
IS READY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FOR TWENTY TWO BY SENATOR
PAN AN ACT RELATING TO EACH
STATE EMPLOYMENT YOU MAY
PROCEED CENTER PENN THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENTS SENATOR SAID
TODAY PERCENT SP FOUR TWENTY
TWO A BILL THAT WILL PROVE
PATIENT. CARE AND HEALTH
OUTCOMES BY EXTENDING WORKFORCE
FLEXIBILITY TO CIVIL SERVICE
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS CURRENT
LABOR LAWS CURRENTLY LIMIT THE
AMOUNT OF HOURS THAT CIVIL
SERVICE MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL
CAN PERFORM BEFORE THE STATE IS
REQUIRED TO UTILIZE A PRIVATE
CONTRACTOR FOR ADDITIONAL
SERVICES. UNDER THE CURRENT
MODEL PRIVATE CONTRACTORS AND
COST THE STATE SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE THAN. CIVIL OTHER CIVIL
SERVICE MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
AND PATIENTS ULTIMATELY SUFFER
WHEN THERE ARE GAPS IN
AVAILABILITY FROM THEIR TRUST A
MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL THE STATE
HAS A RESPONSIBILITY TO
MAINTAIN A CONTINUITY OF CARE
FOR TWO PATIENTS INSIDE
HOSPITALS CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES. THESE INSTITUTIONS
CURRENTLY SUFFER FROM HIGH
VACANCY RATES AMONGST
PHYSICIANS AND OTHER MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS DOESN'T JULY
TWENTY TWENTY LATER REVEALED A
VACANCY RATE OF 29% AMONG ALL
STATE MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
MORE SPECIFICALLY THE CURRENT
VACANCY RATE FOR PHYSICIANS CAN
RANGE ANYWHERE BETWEEN FORTY
SEVEN AND 87% ACROSS VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS. SB FOUR TWENTY TWO
IS MODELED AFTER SUCCESSFUL
PILOT PROGRAM LAUNCHED IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN BY THE COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES THAT RESULTED IN
SIGNIFICANT COST SAVINGS AND
IMPROVED PATIENT OUTCOMES FIFTY
FOUR TWENTY TWO SEATS TO CREATE
A PHYSICIAN OR MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL REGISTRY DON'T
COURAGE BUXTON SCHEDULING
FLEXIBILITY AND GREATER PATIENT
COVERAGE ALLOWING MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS TO MEET REMAIN AT
THE PLACE OF EMPLOYMENT. THAT'S
BEFORE TWENTY TWO IT GIVES
CIVIL SERVICE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS ABILITY PERFORM
TEMPORARY WORK THAT THE STATE
WOULD OTHERWISE CONTRACT OUT TO
MORE COSTLY PRIVATE COMPANIES
IN ADDITION EACH STATE AGENCY
EMPLOYING MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
FROM THE REGISTRY MUST CONDUCT
A REPORT TO STUDY THE
EFFECTIVENESS AND COST SAVINGS
OF THE REGISTRY BY JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. THE
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL DO
SUNSET ON JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN BUT THAT ARE STRICTLY
ASPIRIN IPHONE THANK YOU. IS.
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SAYING MAN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN. ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I BAIT NO BACKER. HI FOR
JUST NO BRADFORD I HAVE A HI
FOR TESTING HI DALLY. NO DODD
HI TORONTO HI ADNAN I LASER EYE
CONSULTANTS I GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO I- TIDO HI
JONES NOPE KAMMERER I LAYERED
HI LLEVA. I LIVE ALONE I MEAN
WHY- I MELINDA'S. MAN. FIVE
NEWMAN I NELSON NO THE TRAILER
BOTH. NO PAN HI FORTINO FIVE
ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER STERN.
HI NUMBER I Y. CASKEY I WINNER
I WILL NOW. CENTER PENN MOVED
TO CALL MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY SENATOR ALAN. ARE
YOU PREPARED. SEARCHING
SEARCHING HE IS PREPARED PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL FOUR FIFTY
NINE BY SENATOR ALAN AN ACT
RELATING TO THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF. NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR. SENATOR ALAN THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS ON THIS BILL
AS BEFORE FIFTY NINE GIVES THE
PUBLIC ARE PRESSING LAWMAKERS
MORE TIMELY AND USEFUL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE MILLIONS
pTHE FATE OF LEGISLATION IN
CALIFORNIA. SO IN OUR STATE.
OUR LOBBYING FIRMS AND INTEREST
GROUPS THAT THOSE THOSE
INTEREST GROUPS THAT HIRE THE
FIRM IS THEY HAVE TO FILE
QUARTERLY REPORTS ON THEIR
LOBBYING ACTIVITY ONCE ONE
MONTH. AFTER THE CLOSING EACH
QUARTER THE THIRD QUARTER
REPORT COVERS THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT LESS THAN A QUARTER
OF THE YEAR JULY. THROUGH
SEPTEMBER NOW I DON'T THINK I
HAVE TO EXPLAIN ANYONE HERE
EXCEPT FOR PERHAPS OUR NEWEST
MEMBERS. THAT DURING THAT THIRD
QUARTER LITERALLY MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. ARE SPENT TO INFLUENCE
LEGISLATION- AND YET THE
DISCLOSURE DOES NOT OCCUR.
UNTIL AFTER THE LEGISLATURE HAS
ALREADY DECIDED WHICH BILLS. TO
PASTOR DEFEAT AND AFTER THE
GOVERNOR HAS DECIDED WHICH
SPILLS TO SIGN OR VETO. AND
THIS- FAILS THEN TO PROVIDE ANY
USEFUL DISCLOSURES ARE
TRANSPARENCY WHEN THE FATE OF
LEGISLATION IS DECIDED. SO
SOMETHING THAT NEARLY HALF OF
THE STATE OF THE UNION ROOFTOP
PROVIDE. FOR THE MONTHLY
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS MORE IN
SOME INSTANCES EVEN MORE
FREQUENT REPORTING. AND IT'S
REALLY GOT BECOME MIGHT BELIEVE
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS TO DO MORE
NOW TO ENSURE. THAT POLICY
MAKERS THE PRESS THE PUBLIC
HAVE MORE TIMELY AND USEFUL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE LOBBYING
IMPACTING PUBLIC POLICY. SO
THIS BILL EXPEDITES THE
ADVOCACY ACTIVITY REPORTING
FROM QUARTERLY TO MONTHLY FOR
THE HIGH SPENDING LOBBYING
FIRMS AND INTEREST GROUPS AND
REQUIRES THEM TO INDICATE THE
SUPPORT. OR OPPOSE POSITIONS
THAT THEY TAKE DURING THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. RATHER
THAN SIMPLY LISTING THE BILL
NUMBERS AND THAT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE- IT GIVES THEM SOME
INSIDE SOME WINDOW INTO INTO
WHAT- WHAT IT WHAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY DOING. THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRES REPORTS OF SPENDING ON
ISSUE DS. WITHIN SEVENTY TWO
HOURS AND REQUIRES INTEREST
GROUPS TO PUT THEIR NAMES ON
THEIR HEADS. MEMBERS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S HAPPENING MORE
AND MORE. HI WE ARE A WE AND
OUR STAFF ARE BEING TARGETED.
ONLINE WITH ISSUE ADS THAT ARE
JUST GOING DIRECTLY TO OUR-
FACEBOOK AND- INSTAGRAM
ACCOUNTS. NOT GOING TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC IN THE COURSE
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'RE THEY'RE BASICALLY BEING
BOUGHT TO INFLUENCE OUR VOTES.
AND THOSE ADS ARE SUBJECT TO
NONE OF THE- DISCLOSURE AND
TRANSPARENCY RULES THAT GOVERN-
SO MUCH OF ADVOCACY. ELSEWHERE
THE BILL ALSO PROVIDE SOME
COMMON SENSE SOLUTIONS FOR
ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY. IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THE PUBLIC
IN THE PRESS. AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS DESERVED. AND WITHOUT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
WAS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
I ARCHULETA I AT KINS I FACE.
BACKER HI FOR JUST. BRADFORD.
BY ADAM FIVE COURTESY FIVE
DALLY. DODD FIVE THERE ARE SO.
EGGMAN FIVE GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROWTH.
HERTZBERG WEST SO HI HER TADO
HI JONES NO KAMMERER. LAYERED I
LLEVA. FIVE THE MON HI WIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MAN HI NEWMAN. I
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH. PAN
FIVE FOUR TWENTY NOW. HI RALPH
FIVE RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER. STERN
HI NUMBER I LIKE HOW SKI. FIVE
WINNER I WILL. SENATOR ALLEN
MOVES A CALL MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY ONE SENATOR
CORTESE HE HAS PREPARED PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL FOUR SIXTY
ONE BY SENATOR CORTEZ HE CAN
ACTUALLY DO TO BUSINESS.
SENATOR KERR CASEY THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THE SENATE BILL FOUR
SIXTY ONE ONE HAND CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND FAIR COMPETITION
ENFORCEMENT BY ALLOWING THE
ALLOWING. THE IF THE AUTHORITY
OF A LARGE COUNTY COUNCIL
OFFICES WITH A PRE EXISTING
AUTHORITY OF THEIR CITY
ATTORNEY COUNTERPARTS.
CALIFORNIA'S UNFAIR COMPETITION
LAW. ALLOWS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND
CITY ATTORNEYS OF CITIES WITH A
POPULATION OF OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND THE
AUTHORITY TO BRING CIVIL ACTION
AGAINST DUBIOUS BUSINESS
PRACTICES. HOWEVER COUNTY
COUNCILS DO NOT HAVE THAT SAME
AUTHORITY. BY GIVING THE
STATE'S THREE LARGEST COUNTY
COUNCIL OFFICES LOS ANGELES SAN
DIEGO AND SANTA CLARA THE
AUTHORITY TO BRING. THESE SO
CALLED UCL ACTIONS SP FOUR
SIXTY ONE. WILL CLOSE AN
EXISTING ENFORCEMENT GAP AND
ENABLE THESE COUNTY COUNCILS TO
BETTER PROTECT CONSUMERS IN THE
PUBLIC AND PROMOTE FAIR
COMPETITION. AS BEFORE SIXTY
ONE IS CO SPONSORED. BY SEN
OCCUR IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY'S I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU. THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. I NEED OR DEBATE SAYING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I BASE
NO BECKER. HI FORGES NO
BRADFORD I KERR BY FIVE FOR
TESTING. HI DALLY NO DODD HI
THERE ARE SO. EGGMAN HI GLAZER
FIVE TEN DOLLARS BY GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG HI WAY SO. HER TADO I
JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED
HI LLEVA I LIVE ALONE HI
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN. I NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF
VOGUE. NO PAN I FORTUNE TINO HI
RALPH FIVE RUBIO HI SKINNER.
STERN HI I'M BURKE RIGHT HI BY
CASTING FIVE WINNER. FIVE WELL
NOW PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. TORONTO I. WITH SO I
SKINNER THE- CENTER COULD
CORTESE MOVE THE CALL MOVING
OUT I REMEMBER FIFTY FOUR
SENATOR LEYVA SHE IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FIVE
TWENTY THREE BY SENATOR LEYVA
AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE CENTER LABOR YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE B. BILL
FIVE TWENTY THREE EXPANDS AND
MODERNIZES BIRTH CONTROL ACCESS
ENSURES GREATER CONTRACEPTIVE
EQUITY STATEWIDE REGARDLESS OF
AN INDIVIDUAL'S GENDER.
INSURANCE COVERAGE STATUS WHERE
THEY WORK OR WHERE THEY GO TO
SCHOOL IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
CALIFORNIA ENACTED SB TEN FIFTY
THREE THE CONTRACEPTIVE
COVERAGE EQUITY ACT TO BUILD ON
EXISTING POLICY AND CODIFY THE%
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT'S
CONTRACEPTIVE COVERAGE MANDATE
INTO STATE LAW. THE MEASURE
REQUIRED BOTH COMMERCIAL HEALTH
PLANS TO COVER ALL FDA APPROVED
CONTRACEPTIVE METHODS WITHOUT
CO PAYS COST SHARING OR
RESTRICTIONS LIKE STEP THERAPY
OR PRIOR AUTHORIZATION. CAN YOU
PLEASE GO OVER THERE. THANK YOU
SORRY THE MAJOR ECORD POST-
ADICIONAL IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN JUST AFTER SP TEN FIFTY
THREE WAS ENACTED SB NINE
NINETY NINE WAS IMPLEMENTED TO
REQUIRE MOST HEALTH INSURANCE
PLANS IN CALIFORNIA TO COVER A
YEAR'S SUPPLY OF BIRTH CONTROL
DISPENSED AT ONE TIME. DESPITE
THE PROGRESS MADE IN CALIFORNIA
HEALTH DISPARITIES REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES PERSIST AMONG
BLACK INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR INCLUDING
DISPROPORTIONATE UNINTENDED
PREGNANCY INFANT AND MATERNAL
MORTALITY AND STD RATES IT IS
TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO
MODERNIZE AND EXPAND ITS
CONTRACEPTIVE EQUITY LAWS TO
REDUCE BARRIERS TO
CONTRACEPTIVE CARE IMPROVES
SEXUAL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND CREATE GREATER
HEALTH EQUITY. TO THAT END SP
FIVE TWENTY THREE ACCOMPLISHES
THE FOLLOWING MAKES
CALIFORNIA'S COMP PERCEPTRON
PERCEPTRON RECEPTIVE EQUITY
LAWS GENDER INCLUSIVE REQUIRES
COVERAGE OF OVER THE COUNTER
BIRTH CONTROL OPTIONS TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO TIME
SENSITIVE CARE. EXPANDS
CONTRACEPTIVE COVERAGE TO
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS BY
EXPANDING BENEFITS TO STATE
EMPLOYEES AND INDIVIDUALS
ENROLLED IN HEALTH PLANS
OPERATED BY UNIVERSITIES AND
COLLEGES PROHIBITS EMPLOYER
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON AN
EMPLOYEE'S CONTRACEPTIVE
CHOICES MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
UNDERDOG. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF FIVE TO
THREE I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR
FOR MY CONSTITUENTS ON WHY I'M
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY. I'M
PROUDLY PRO LIFE IN BELIEVE IN
FAMILY I ALSO BELIEVE IN
HELPING PEOPLE MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISIONS FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES. I'D LIKE TO
SHARE SOME STATISTICS WITH YOU
FROM THE P. P. I. C. AND THE
LATINA COMMISSION. TWO OUT OF
EVERY THREE BABIES BORN TO
TEENS IN CALIFORNIA ARE BELONG
TO THE GENUS. 70% OF MOTHERS
DROP OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL. ONLY
ONE OUT OF FIVE. TEEN MOTHERS
RECEIVE ANY FINANCIAL SUPPORT
FROM THERE FOR CHARLOTTE FROM
THEIR CHILD'S FATHER. 80% OF
TEENS FATHERS DO NOT MARRY THE
TEEN GIRLS WHO BORE THEIR CHILD.
FATHERS OF CHILDREN BORN TO
TEENS ARE ON THE AVERAGE ALMOST
FOUR YEARS OLDER THAN THE
MOTHERS. CAN A MAJORITY IS OVER
THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE. FOR LOW
INCOME TEAM TO MAKE UP
APPROXIMATELY 40% OF THE
ADOLESCENT POPULATION AND
ACCOUNT FOR EIGHTY THREE.
PERCENT OF TEENS WHO GIVE BIRTH.
AN ESTIMATED 5260% OF PARENTING
TEENS HAVE BEEN SEXUALLY ABUSED
TWICE THE NATIONAL RATE FOR
NEVER PREGNANT TEENS. THIS BILL
REMOVES THE BARRIERS TO HELP
THOSE WHO CANNOT AFFORD
CONTRACEPTION. BE ABLE TO TAKE
CARE OF THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES HAVING THE PRO LIFE OR
PRO CHOICE DEBATE SHOULD NOT
START WITH THE PREVENTION OF
UNPLANNED PREGNANCIES. EVERYONE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO MAKE SAFE
CHOICES WHEN PLANNING A FAMILY
AND I THINK THIS IS A GOOD
START I SUPPORT THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT YOU
KNOW- I JUST WANT TO APPLAUD
THE AUTHOR IN TAKING THIS TO
THE NEXT STEP THIS IS WE OFTEN
FORGET THESE FIGHTS- STARTED A
TIME WHEN THE- IT ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO WIN I THINK IT
WAS NINETY SIX NINETY SEVEN
NINETY EIGHT NINETY NINE AND
TWO THOUSAND. FOR THE FIRST
CONTRACEPTIVE EQUITY ACTED
TOGETHER WITH THEN STATE
SENATOR- JACKIE SPEAR THAT WE
FOUGHT AND GOT VETOED AND
VETOED AND VETOED AND VETOED.
AND THIS- ELEGANTLY TAKES THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE TO THE
NEXT STEP. AND AS FOR NIGEL.
THE WHOLE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SINGMAN
CENTER LABOR YOU MAY CONCLUDE
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I'D
LIKE TO THANK BOTH OF MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR SUPPORT ON
THIS BILL AFTER FOUR YEARS OF
ATTACKS ON REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
FREEDOM AND JUSTICE UNDER THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
WASHINGTON CALIFORNIA NOW HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY AND THE
OBLIGATION TO EXPAND BIRTH
CONTROL ACCESS CREATE GREATER
HEALTH EQUITY AND IMPROVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES STATEWIDE OUR
SUCCESS FOR NOVEL. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA I AT KINS I
BASE. BECKER FIVE FORGES NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A BETTER LIFE
FOR TESTING. HI DALLY I DONT
FIVE TORONTO I A GIVEN HI
PLEASE- HI GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO BY JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. FIVE LAVER I LIVE
ALONE I REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NELSON NO A SHOW
OF VOGUE. NO PAN FIVE FORTUNE
TINO HI RALPH I RUBIO FIVE
SKINNER. STERN HI NUMBER NINE
FIVE WHAT KIND OF SKI. FIVE
WINNER I WILL NOW SENATOR LABOR
MOVES A CALL. BEYOND THE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY FIVE SENATOR PAN
IS READY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FIVE SIXTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR PAN AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE CENTER
PANNED THE FLOOR'S YOURS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS
SAID SP FIVE SIXTY EIGHT IS
ABOUT PATIET ADHERENCE TO
PRESCRIBED COVERED MEDICATIONS.
IT'S BOUT PEOPLE WITH CHRONIC
CONDITIONS LIKE ASTHMA HIGH
BLOOD PRESSURE DIABETES HIGH
CHOLESTEROL ARTHRITIS OTHER
DISEASES THAT REQUIRE ONGOING
MEDICATION AND FOR SOME
SUPPLIES IN ORDER TO KEEP THE
CRISIS CONDITION UNDER CONTROL.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WITH
CHRONIC DISEASE AFFECTS ABOUT
40% OF CALIFORNIANS OF AT LEAST
ONE CHRONIC CONDITION. AND MANY
ARE IN HIGH DEDUCTIBLE HEALTH
PLANS THEIR PLANS OF MEDICAL
DEDUCTIBLES OVER A THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS THE
PHARMACY DEDUCTIBLES OVER FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS WHICH MEANS
DEPENDING ON THE BENEFIT
DESIGN. PATIENTS MUST PAY EVERY
YEAR ALL OF THE MEDICAL AND
PHARMACY FOR EXPENSES UP TO THE
DOCTOR BULL BEFORE THEY- GET
ANY COVERAGE WHERE THEY'RE ALSO
PAYING COPAYS FOR COVERED
SERVICES. MANY STUDIES SHOW
THAT PATIENT NON ADHERENCE TO
PRESCRIBED MEDICATIONS LEADS TO
POOR. OUTCOMES AND PROGRESSION
OF THE DISEASE THAT'S ESTIMATED
TO BE IN BILLIONS OF AVOIDABLE
DIRECT HEALTH CARE COSTS. OF
COURSE ALSO ADDITIONAL SIDE-
COST AS WELL. THIS BILL DOESN'T
ELIMINATE COPAYS OR PATIENT
COST SHARES. ELIMINATES THE
DEDUCTIBLE FOR CHRONIC DISEASE
MEDICATION THAT PERFECT THAT
PREVENTS THEM FROM BEING ABLE
TO AFFORD THE MEDICATION IN THE
FIRST PLACE BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TO. SAVE UP THE OF MAY PERHAPS
OVER A THOUSAND. PATIENTS STILL
HAVE TO PAY THE COPAY SO
THERE'S STILL SOME. LIMITATION
THERE WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN IPHONE. WAS THERE
ANY DOES IT- DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR
BATES. I DON'T THINK IN MY OWN
NOW I THINK YOU- HIGH RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT
TODAY BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING TO HELP
PATIENTS WITH THESE CHRONIC
CONDITIONS OF FOR THEIR
PRESCRIPTIONS THE BILL WILL
ELIMINATE ANY PHARMACEUTICAL
DEDUCTIBLE FOR PATIENTS
DIAGNOSED WITH A CHRONIC
CONDITION CALIFORNIANS LIVING
WITH CHRONIC DISEASE TYPICALLY
RELY. ON PRESCRIPTION MEDICINE
TO KEEP THEIR CONDITION STABLE
CURRENTLY THE SAME PATIENTS ARE
FACED WITH PAYING HUNDREDS AND
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE CALENDAR YEAR
TO SATISFY THE WHOLE PLANTS
DEDUCTIBLE AMOUNT BEFORE THE
FIRST PAYMENT FROM THEIR
INSURANCE COVERAGE KICKS IN
REMOVING THE DEDUCTIBLE WILL
ENHANCE ACCESS TO CRITICAL
MEDICINES AND HEALTH PLANS WILL
STILL HAVE THE ABILITY TO
REQUIRE COPAYMENTS AND PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION AND COINSURANCE
HAIDIAN INTRODUCED SENATE BILL
FOUR SEVENTY THREE EARLIER THIS
YEAR TO FOCUS ON. THE OUT OF
POCKET COSTS FOR DIABETIC
PATIENTS MANY IN MY DISTRICT
WHO NEED INSULIN AND I
SUPPORTED SB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT
LAST WEEK IN THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS WHEN IT CAME OFF
THE SUSPENSE CALENDAR AGAIN TO
EMPHASIZE THE NEED FOR THIS
BILL THE AUTHOR HAS STRUCK A
LAUDABLE BALANCED ALLOWING
IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO MEDICATIONS
FOR PATIENTS WITH THESE
DISEASES AND LEAVING THIRD
PARTY PAYERS WITH THE EXISTING
MEANS TO CONTROL SPENDING ON
DRUGS I THANK THE AUTHOR AND I
URGE AND I. VOTE ON SB FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT. FURTHER DO OR
DEBATE. SINGMAN CENTER PENN YOU
MAY CONCLUDE THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT AND WISE
WORDS AND MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
LAGUNA GAL EXPECT LAST NIGHT
BUT THANK YOU. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BAIT. HI BECKER. FIVE
FORGES BY BRADFORD HI BY ADAM
HI COURTESY I DALLY. DON HI
THERE ARE SO. HI EGGMAN MARK
FIVE GLAZER. GONZALEZ BY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO.
JONES NOPE CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED I LLEVA I LIVE ALONE I
REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF
BOTH. TEN FIVE FOURTEEN TINO.
HI RALPH HI PREVIA FIVE SKINNER.
STERN. HI I AM BERG I WAIT
CASKEY I WINNER I WILL HI
CENTER PENN MOVES A CALL MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIFTY SIX
SENATOR PAN HE IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FIVE
NINETY EIGHT BY SENATOR PAN AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT.
CENTER PENNED THE FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU MATT PRESENCE ENTERS
SP FIVE NINETY EIGHT AS A
DISTRICT BILL WHICH WOULD ALLOW
EMPLOYER ORGANIZATIONS AT THE
SECOND A REGIONAL TRANSIT
DISTRICT TO MOVE UNFAIR LABOR
PRACTICE CHARGES TO THE
JURISDICTION OF THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD A
PERVERT. CURRENTLY THE DISTRICT
AND ITS EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS
MUST GO THROUGH THE OVER
BURDENED AND UNDER RESOURCE
SUPERIOR COURT FOR CONFLICT
RESOLUTION THIS PROCESS IS TIME
CONSUMING EXPENSIVE AND MAYBE
PLACE AN UNFAIR PRACTICE CHARGE
WITH THE JUDGE HAS LITTLE
EXPERIENCE WITH PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
YOUR EMPLOYEE RELATIONS. THE
PERSON THE PROPUBLICA'S
ALLUSION TO STREAMLINE THE LESS
EXPENSIVE THIS IS SUPPORTED BY
BOTH THE EMPLOYEES AT LABOR
PARTNERS AND TO THE EMPLOYER
AND SO THIS AND WILL HOPEFULLY
SAVE ALSO SAVE MONEY FOR
TAXPAYERS HERE IN THE
SACRAMENTO REGION RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I THOUGHT. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA. HI
AT KINS FIVE BASE NO BECKER. HI
PORCHES NO BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM HI CORTESE HI DALLY. NO
DOT. FIVE TORONTO HI EGGMAN HI
GLAZER NO GUNS ALLAH'S HIGH
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO
HI HER TADO HI JONES NO
KAMMERER. I LAYERED I LLEVA
FIVE THE MON HI MCGUIRE. HI
MELINDA'S NO MAN. I NEWMAN I
NELSON NO A TOWBOAT HI PAM MY
FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH HI RUBIO
I SKINNER STERN HI AMBER I LIKE
HOW SKI FIVE WINNER. I WILL NO
CENTER PENN MOVES A CALL MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN
SENATOR ALAN PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX ELEVEN BY
SENATOR ALAN AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION CHECK AFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY. SENATOR
ALLEN YOU MAY PROCEED. BENJAMIN
PRESENT MEMBERS THIS BUILDS
UPON THE FILM INDUSTRY'S
COMMITMENT TO TRAIN AND EMPLOY
MORE CALIFORNIANS FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES.
FOR THE SKILLED WORKER
COMPRISES MOTION PICTURE AND
TELEVISION PRODUCTION. IT WORKS
WITHIN THE EXISTING FAMEWORK
OF THE STATE'S FILM TELEVISION
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM SO DOESN'T
EXPAND IT AND IT JUST WORKS
WITHIN THE FRAMEWORK AND THE
SIZE OF IT- AND BUT WITH THAT
THE LEGISLATION CATALYZES
MOTION PICTURE PRODUCTION. I
HAD TO HIRE GRADUATES FROM
SUCCESSFUL INDUSTRY TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE A PROVEN
TRACK RECORD OF WORKING WITH
HISTORICALLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. TO PROVIDE MORE
MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITIES TO
BUILD LASTING CAREERS IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY IT'S
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD ARRAY OF
FILM. AND TELEVISION INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDERS IT HAS NO NOWN
OPPOSITION AND IT'S RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
THUS FAR AND I. HOPE TO EARN
YOUR RIVAL TODAY. SENATOR PENN
IF YOU ARE A MATTER PRESIDENT
CENTERS I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX ONE ONE I APPRECIATE
THAT MY GOOD FRIEND- WHO'S
RECOGNIZES THAT WE NEED TO
INCREASE DIVERSITY BOTH IN
FRONT THE CAMERA BEHIND THE
CAMERA WHEN IT COMES TO THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY THAT'S
WHY THE A. T. A LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS HAS BEEN WORKING HARD TO
EXPAND THE AVAILABILITY OF-
POSITIONS IN ENTERTAINMENT- FOR
BOTH THE API COMMUNITY MORE
BROADLY AND SO CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE- GOOD CENTERS- FIRST
INTO AGAIN INCREASED DIVERSITY
IN OUR ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SINGMAN
CENTER ALLEN YOU MAY CONCLUDE.
RESPECT RESTAURANT THANK YOU
PAY THANK YOU SENATOR. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. FIVE
ARCHULETA I AT KINS I BASE I
BECKER. I PORCHES HI BRADFORD I
HAVE A HI COURTESY HI DALLY. HI
DON HI THERE ASA HI EGGMAN FIVE
GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ I GROSS. HI
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA I LIVE ALONE I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON HI A SHOW OF
BOTH. I PAN HI FOUR TWENTY NOW
I BROUGHT HI RUBIO. I SKINNER
STERN HI NUMBER NINE I PLAY
CASKEY. I WINNER I WILL. HI
SENATOR ALAN MOVES A CALL
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
EIGHT CENTER NEWMAN IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SIX
THIRTY SEVEN BY SENATOR NEWMAN
AND ACTUALLY NEED TO HEALTH
FACILITIES SENATOR NEWMAN THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TO ASK
YOUR SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL SIX
THREE SEVEN. SP SIX THIRTY
SEVEN DOES TWO THINGS IT
REQUIRES HOSPITALS TO REPORT
NURSE STAFFING SHORTAGE DATA
AND STUFF CODE TESTING DATA TO
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ON A WEEKLY BASIS DURING
HEALTH RELATED STATE OF
EMERGENCY AND ON A MONTHLY
BASIS AT ALL OTHER TIMES. IT
DIRECTS HOSPITALS TO PUBLICLY
POST NOTICES OF MERCY HEALTH
AND SAFETY WAIVERS INCLUDING
THOSE RELATING TO NURSE TO
PATIENT RATIOS DIRECTLY
ADJACENT TO THEIR LICENSE.
STAFFING IS AMONG THE MOST
CRUCIAL PARTS OF A HOSTILE
OPERATION AS WE HAVE WE HAVE
ALL SEEN DURING THIS PANDEMIC
STABBING DETERMINES IF AN ER OR
AN ICY YOU CAN KEEP ACCEPTING
PATIENTS HOW MANY SURGERIES CAN
BE PERFORMED AT ONCE. AND THE
QUALITY OF CARE PATIENTS ARE
LIKELY TO RECEIVE. SP SIX
THIRTY SEVEN WILL ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS ARE
TRANSPARENT ABOUT THEIR
STAFFING RESOURCES AND WILL
ENABLE NURSES ON THE FRONT
LINES TO PROPERLY PREPARE AND
PROTECT THEMSELVES FROM
UNNECESSARY RISK OF ILLNESS
WHILE PROVIDING LIFESAVING
CARE. IN A SAFE ENVIRONMENT TO
THE PATIENTS IN THEIR CARE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HERE I GO
TODAY. AND IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT
KENS FIVE BATES NO BECKER HI
FOR JUST. BRADFORD I HAVE A
FIVE COURTESY HI SALLY NO DOT
HI TORONTO I HAD BEEN HI GLAZER
FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI WAY SO HI HER TADO
HI JONES NO CAMEL OWNER I
LAYERED HI LABOUR. I LIVE ALONE
FIVE WIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON. A SHOW ABOUT.
I PAN FIVE PORTS IN CHINO. HI
RALPH HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER
STERN HI I AM BERG I WAKE
COUNTY I WINNER. I WILL NOW.
SENATOR EXAM A SINNER NEWMAN
MOVES THE CALL MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SIXTY ONE SENATOR
ADMIN IS PREPARED PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX NINETY NINE BY
SENATOR EDMUND AN ACT RELATED
TO SCHOOL CLIMATE. SENATOR
EDMUND YOU MAY PROCEED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
AND SENATORS TO I'M PRESENTING
TODAY S. BE SIX NINETY NINE.
WHICH ASKS SCHOOLS TO PORT THE
SCHOOL BOARD TO PUT THE SCHOOL
CLIMATE SURVEY ON TO THE
CALIFORNIA. DASHBOARD OF
CURRENTLY SCHOOLS AND WHERE WE
KNOW COMING OUT OF KOBE COMING
OF THE PANDEMIC THE CLIMATE ON
A SCHOOL GROUND CAN REALLY
IMPACT A STUDENT'S. EMOTIONAL
HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH AND
CERTAINLY THEIR ABILITY TO
LEARN AND SO BY THAT BY TAKING
A SURVEY TO SEE BEING ABLE TO
ASSIST WITH THAT THE SCHOOL
CLIMATE IS AT THAT WILL HELP
YOU THINK SCHOOLS DO A BETTER
JOB OF BEING ABLE TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ISSUES- AND PARENTS
AND FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES TO
BE ABLE TO SEE HOW KIDS ARE.
ARE FEELING IN THE SCHOOL
SETTINGS THIS CALL THIS
INFORMATION IS CURRENTLY
COLLECTED BUT IT'S A DIFFERENT
A DIFFERENT PLACES AND IT'S NOT
PUT INTO THE DASHBOARD SO WE'RE
ASKING- TO USE A COUPLE PRE
APPROVED- S. SURVEY INSTRUMENTS
THAT PEOPLE'S SCHOOLS ARE
ALREADY USING. AND JUST FOR
THE- CALIFORNIA PART OF
EDUCATION TO THAT PUT THAT AS
AN INDICATOR ON OUR CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS DASHBOARD AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
IS THERE ANY DISK OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BASE. BACKER. FIVE
PORGES HI BRADFORD. I HAVE A
FINE CORTESE I DALLY. DODD HI
TORONTO I HAD BEEN I GLAZER
FIVE GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG
HI WITHOUT HI HER TADO HI JONES
NO KAMMERER FIVE LAYERED I
LABOR HI THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON. NO HOTEL ABODE. I PAN
FIVE FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH I
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER STERN I
NUMBER NINE I PLAY CASTING FIVE
WINNER I WILL. NOW SENATOR
EDMUND MOVES THE CALL BUTTON ON
THE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY SIX
SENATOR GONZALEZ HE'S READY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
SEVENTY SIX BY SENATOR GONZALEZ
AN ACT RELATING TO WATER
SENATOR GONZALEZ YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL SEVEN
SEVEN SIX WHICH WILL MAKE
VARIOUS STATUTORY CHANGES TO
ENHANCE THE STATE WATER BOARDS
ABILITY TO DRINK TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY
IMPLEMENT THE SAFE. AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER ACT
THE STATE WATER BOARD IS
WORKING HARD TO IMPLEMENT THE
LEGISLATURE'S VISION FOR THE
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER PROGRAM BUT HAS
IDENTIFIED A NUMBER OF
CLARIFYING STATUTORY CHANGES
THAT ARE NEEDED TO ALLOW THEM
TO MOVE FASTER AND MORE
EFFICIENTLY AND PROVIDING
FUNDING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. THESE EFFICIENCY-CHANGES ARE BALANCED BY THE
BILL'S PROVISIONS TO RECASTING
CONSOLIDATE THE BOARD'S
ADMINISTRATIVE ENFORCEMENT IN
FINDING A SORTIE TO ENSURE THAT
THE STATE'S FUNDS DO NOT FALL
VICTIM TO FRAUD OR ABUSE THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE ON SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE. THE ROLE PLEASE. FOR HER
WITH ALAN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
I BASE. I BACKER. HI FOR JUST
NO BRADFORD I HAVE A ITEM BY
PROTECTING. I DALLY NO DOT HI
TORONTO I THANK HEAVEN I LASER
HI I CONDOLENCES HI HI GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG. HI WITH SO. HI
HER TADO. JONES NO CAMCORDER I
LAYERED ON HI LLEVA HI THE MON
I REQUIRE HEY HEY HI MELINDA'S
HOME NO MAN. HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN NO A TRIO OF BOTH.
POSTED BY HAND HI FORTUNE TINO
HI RALPH HI RUBIO. SKINNER I
STERN HI I'M BURKE HI WHAT KIND
OF SKI I WINNER I WILL. NOW
CENTER CONSOLIDATION WAS A CALL.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTY TWO. SENATOR UMBERG HE
IS PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY NINE BY
SENATOR ON BERG AN ACT RELATING
TO LICENSE PLATES SENATOR
UMBERG THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS- THIS IS A BILL THAT-
SIMPLY ALLOWS PROFESSIONAL
SPORTS TEAMS TO HAVE THEIR LOGO
ON LICENSE PLATES IT DOESN'T
COST THE STATE ANY MONEY- AND
TO THE EXTENT THAT THEY'RE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS GENERATED THEY
WILL BE USED- ALLOCATED
PROJECTS AND PROGRAMS SUPPORTED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS URGE NOVEL. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA HI
AT KINS I BASE HI BECKER. I FOR
JUST FIVE BRADFORD I HAVE ADAM
HI COURTESY. HI DALLY I DONT HI
TORONTO I EGGMAN HI GLAZER. I
CONSOLIDATE MY GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
HI JONES I CAN LONGER FIVE
LAYERED HI LLEVA HI THE MON.
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S I MEN. HI
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT HI NIELSEN. BY
A SHOW OF BOTH. HI PAM I
FOURTEEN TINA HI HI RALPH FIVE
RUBIO. HI SKINNER HI I. STERN.
HI NUMBER FIVE WHITE HOUSE E.
WINNER. HI WELCOME. HI PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
LIMONEIRA I CASKEY HI HI. HIGHS
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY
FIVE SENATOR LEE MORAN IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. PRESIDENT
AND MEMBER- THIRTY FIVE JUST A
SECOND. WE'LL GET TO YOUR-
SENATE BILL FOUR NINETY SEVEN
BY SENATOR LEE MON AN ACT
RELATING TO DIRECT DEPOSIT OF
FUNDS NOW THE FLOOR IS YOURS IN
AN EARLY MORNING THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
SENATE BILL FOUR NINETY SEVEN
WILL CLOSE A LOOPHOLE THAT
ALLOWS NON BANK ENTITIES FOR ME
BEATING CALIFORNIA FEDERAL LAWS
BY CHARGING OVERDRAFT FEES ON
ACCOUNTS FOR INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVING PUBLIC ASSISTANCE.
SUCH AS UNEMPLOYMENT
COMPENSATION STATE DISABILITY
OR CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS
DISTRIBUTED BY THE STATE
CURRENT LAW PROTECTS RECIPIENTS
OF PUBLIC ASSISTANCE INCLUDING
UNEMPLOYED WORKERS FROM THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE FUNDS BY
SETTING DIRECT DEPOSIT
REQUIREMENTS FOR QUALIFYING
ACCOUNTS HOWEVER TO KEEP
CHARGING OVERDRAFT FEES CERTAIN
NONBANK ENTITIES PREPAID CARD
PROVIDERS HAVE STARTED TO OFFER
SO CALLED BANK ACCOUNT THAT DID
NOT COMPLY WITH THE FEDERAL AND
CALIFORNIARULES FOR PREPAID
ACCOUNTS. THESE FAKE FAKE FAKE
THESE FAKE BANK ACCOUNTS WHICH
ARE SOLD BY ALTERNATIVE
FINANCIAL SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE
DYING ARE DESIGNED TO ENCOURAGE
OVERDRAFT FEES THAT PUT LOW
INCOME CONSUMERS IN A
VULNERABLE AN ENDLESS CYCLE OF
DEBT THIS BILL CLOSES AN
IMPORTANT PEOPLE THAT WILL
PROTECT VULNERABLE FAMILIES TO
ENSURE STATE FUNDS ARE USED
APPROPRIATELY AND EFFICIENTLY
AND MAKE IT CLEAR THAT PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE SHOULD NOT BE
SUBJECT TO OVER DRAFT FEES SUCH
AS UNEMPLOYMENT. THIS BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
COMMITTEE THANK YOU KNOW
STRICTLY ASPIRIN IRA. IS. THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION BOARD.
SINGMAN THIS BILL IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION. SEEING
NONE ICE FORTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTY. SENATOR PARDON T. NOW
ARE YOU PREPARED. HE IS PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR PORTMAN TINO AND ACTS
RELATED TO HOUSING. ENTER
PARDON TINO THE FORAGERS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
TODAY I'M PRESENTING SP FIFTEEN
WHICH WILL GIVE INCENTIVES TO
CITIES THAT CONVERT ABANDONED
RETAIL SITES INTO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SPECIFICALLY SP FIFTEEN
WILL ENABLE LOCAL CITIES TO
RECEIVE FROM H. E. D. THE
AVERAGE OF THE ANNUAL AMOUNT OF
SALES TAX REVENUE GENERATED. BY
THAT SITE FOR THE LAST SEVEN
YEARS IF THE SITE HAS BEEN
CONVERTED IN OCCUPIED WITH NEW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THESE FISCAL
INCENTIVES WILL BE USED BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO REPLACE
THE SALES TAX REVENUE LOSS FROM
THE CLOSURE OF THESE BIG BOX
RETAILERS AS WE ALL KNOW
CALIFORNIA IS IN A HOUSING.
CRISIS AND CITIES HAVE LONG
BEEN INCENTIVIZED TO CREATE
RETAIL OVER HOUSING THIS BILL
SEEKS TO SWITCH THAT PARADIGM
CREATE A- EFFORT THAT BOTH
HOUSING ACTIVISTS- BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ALL LIGHT BECAUSE IT'S
INCENTIVE BASED AND WILL LEAD
TO MORE AFFORDABLE AND
WORKFORCE HOUSING. IF YOU COULD
JUST WAIT A SECOND WE'LL GET
YOU BACK ON LINE. GET YOUR LAST
COUPLE OF SENTENCES EIGHT
SEEDED BY EIGHT SEEDED MY TIME
LIMIT I GUESS- RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR ANOTHER VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. CENTER GROVE. IT IS
REPORTED AS WAIT A SECOND WE'LL
GET YOU WANT TO CHECK THRE YOU
GO THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION BECAUSE OPPOSE
RECOMMENDATION- BASED ON SOME
COST FACTORS IN THIS BILL BUT
THE THEORY OF THE BILL TO TAKE
THESE- BIG BOX STORES AND
TURNING INTO HOUSING PROJECTS
IS A BRILLIANT IDEA- IT'S EVEN
A MORE BRILLIANT IDEA TO ALLOW
A BACK FILL FOR TAX CREDITS-
MOST OF YOU GUYS DON'T KNOW
THAT KERN COUNTY PRODUCES 51%
OF THE STATE'S RENEWABLE
ENERGY. I THINK WE'RE ALL ABOUT
OIL BUT BASICALLY 51% OF THE
ENERGY THAT'S RENEWABLE THAT
HELPS THE GOVERNOR AND ALL OF
YOU MEET YOUR CLIMATE CHANGE
GOALS COMES FROM MY DISTRICT IN
THE ENERGY GOES NORTH AND SOUTH
BUT WE GET NO TAX INCENTIVE
WHATSOEVER ON IT BECAUSE THESE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE THESE OCCUPIED
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
ACRES FOR SOLAR PROJECTS WE
DON'T GET THE TAX INCENTIVES OR
THE TAX- THEY DON'T PAYTAXES
AND SO WE CAN'T USE A TIRE LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND ALL THOSE
THINGS SO TO ADD THAT PROVISION
IN THE BILL IS ABSOLUTELY
BRILLIANT BECAUSE AND YOUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES WOULD BE
ABSENT THAT TAX REVENUE THAT
THOSE BIG ABOUT BIG BOX STORES
WOULD NORMALLY PAY- IF THIS
DOES TURN INTO A HOUSING
PROJECT SO I JUST THANK YOU FOR
MAKING SURE THAT THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ARE COVERED UNDER
THIS SECTION AS WELL. ANY
FURTHER TO. DEBATE CENTER PARTY
NO YOU MAY CONCLUDE GREAT THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS AND I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO ADD THAT A CRITICAL PIECE OF
THIS IS THE JOBS GONNA CREATE
AND THE PROTECTIONS FOR THOSE
WORKERS ARE IMPORTANT AS WELL
AS MAKING SURE THAT THE FOLKS
WHO BUILT THESE FOUR DOUBLE
HOUSING UNITS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PURCHASE THOSE
HOUSING UNITS AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FRIEND ABOUT.
ADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT
KENS FIVE BASICS. BECKER HI FOR
JUST HI BRADFORD I KERR BIO HI
PROTESTING HI DELHI I DON HI
THERE ARE SO. I EGGMAN HI
GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES HIGH
GROWTH HIGH HURTS FOR. WESA
FIVE HER TADO HI JONES. CAN
LONGER. I LAYERED I LABOUR HI
THE MOON. I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN- SHOW BOTH. I PAN FIVE
FORTUNE TINO I BROUGHT HI RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER. HI STERN I AM
BERG HI WE CASTING FIVE WINNER.
HI WELL I. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BAIT. FIVE
HERTZBERG. JONES MELINDA'S.
NIELSEN HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. HERTZBERG I.
JONES MELINDA'S. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
GO BACK TO ITEM NUMBER SIXTY
THREE SENATOR LEYVA SHE IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR LEYVA AND ACTUALLY INTO
EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR LABOR YOU
MAY PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS SP SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
AIMS TO PREVENT WAGE THEFT
WITHIN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT WE ARE SEEKING TO GO AFTER
THE BAD ACTORS IN THE INDUSTRY
AND TO HELP THOSE THAT PLAY BY
THE RULES AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR WORKERS ARE PAID ON TIME.
CALIFORNIA'S CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY BUILT OUR WORLD CLASS
INFRASTRUCTURE IS A KEY DRIVER
OF THE STATE'S ECONOMY AND
PROVIDED HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF HOUSING UNITS ANNUALLY TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF A GROWING
CALIFORNIA POPULATION. DUE TO
THE SKILLS REQUIRED AND THE
FAIR WAGES AND BENEFITS WORKERS
RECEIVED THE INDUSTRY PROVIDED
A PATHWAY TO MIDDLE CLASS FOR
THE MIDDLE CLASS FOR TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS WHO COULD THEN AFFORD
TO PURCHASE THE HOMES THAT THEY
BUILT. UNFORTUNATELY FOR MORE
THAN THE LAST FORTY YEARS THOSE
STANDARDS HAVE GRADUALLY BEEN
ERODING ACCORDING TO THE UNITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT CRITERIA.
OVER 50% OF CALIFORNIA'S
CONSTRUCTION WORKFORCE FAMILY
FAMILIES CURRENTLY FALL IN LOW
INCOME CATEGORIES LESS THAN 80%
OF THE MEDIAN FAMILY INCOME.
OVER ONE THIRD OF ALL
CONSTRUCTION FAMILIES ARE
CLASSIFIED AS VERY LOW INCOME
EARNING LESS THAN 50% OF THE
MEDIAN FAMILY INCOME. LIKE MANY
OTHER SECTORS CONSTRUCTION
WAGES HAVE GONE DOWN BUT WAGE
THEFT IN CASH PAYMENTS HAVE
INCREASED AT A KEY FACTOR FOR
THIS IS THE LACK OF ENFORCEMENT
OF BASIC LABOR LAWS ON
JOBSITES. UNSCRUPULOUS
CONTRACTORS THAT DO NOT PLAY BY
THE RULES HAVEN'T ILLEGAL AND
UNFAIR ADVANTAGE OVER HONEST
CONTRACTORS AS THEY UNDERMINED
WAGES AND WORKING CONDITIONS
THROUGHOUT THE INDUSTRY. BUT I
WILL SHARE WITH YOU THAT A B.
SEVENTEEN OH ONE BY SOMEONE
MEMBER THEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
THURMAN WHICH TOOK EFFECT IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN HAS MADE
A DIFFERENCE. IT HAS NOT DONE
ENOUGH SOME CONTRACTORS STILL
CONSIDER WAGE THEFT JUST THE
COST OF DOING BUSINESS.
COLLEAGUES AT THIS TIME THAT WE
TREAT WAGE THEFT IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY SIMILAR
TO HOW WE DO I OTHER
INDUSTRIES. HOWEVER MEMBERS I
DO REMAIN COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH CIA AND THE SPONSORS TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH PAYROLL
MONITORING. THAT IS NOT OVERLY
BURDENSOME AND TO CREATING A
WORKSITE ENVIRONMENT THE
CHANGES THE CULTURE OF
NEGLIGENCE BOTH CAN BE ACHIEVED
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. VOTE. SENATOR ATKINS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN FOR TWO SIMPLE REASONS AS
ALREADY INDICATED BY THE AUTHOR
IT PROTECTS CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS WAGES AND HELPS LAW
ABIDING CONTRACTORS COMPETE IN
AN INDUSTRY THAT HAS LONG BEEN
PLAGUED BY WAGE THEFT. ALSO AS
INDICATED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN-
AB SEVENTY NO ONE BY THEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN I
SUPPORTED THAT BILL WHICH MAY
GENERAL CONTRACTORS JOINTLY
LIABLE FOR THE WAGES OWED BY
THEIR SUBCONTRACTORS TO THE
WORKERS IT WAS AND IT CONTINUES
TO BE AN IMPORTANT VICTORY FOR
WORKERS AND NOT JUST THOSE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE REPRESENTED
BY A UNION BUT FOR ALL
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS THE FOLKS
WHO BUILD OUR GROCERY STORES
PLACES OF WORSHIP COMMUNITIES
AND OUR HOMES. BUT CHANGE IS
NOT EASY ESPECIALLY FOR AN
INDUSTRY IS COMPLEX AND
TRANSITORY AS CONSTRUCTION
WHICH IS WHY WE MUST PUSH A
LITTLE MORE TO ENSURE THE
CULTURE OF NEGLECT ON JOBSITES
IS REPLACED WITH ONE OF FAIR
COMPETITION AND SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY FOR BOTH WORKERS
AND LAW ABIDING BUSINESSES. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CHINO HAS WORKED
VERY HARD TO ENSURE THAT SB
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN REPRESENTS
BOTH FAIRNESS. IN THE SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WORKERS AND
CONTRACTORS BY INCLUDING THE
RIGHT TO Q. WERE A VIOLATION.
WITHOUT ANY PENALTIES AS LONG
AS THE PROPER STEPS ARE TAKEN.
WORKERS NEED THEIR EMPLOYERS
FOR THEIR LIVELIHOOD AND
CONTRACTORS CAN BE ONLY AS THE
ONLY BE SUCCESSFUL WITH THE
SKILLED LABOR AND HARD WORK OF
THEIR EMPLOYEES. I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THE
GREAT WORK ON THIS BILL
INCLUDING THE SENATOR FROM
CHINO. THE CHAIR OF SENATE
LABOR COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR
OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND WHAT THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR I. SENATOR AWESOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. IS THE
SEVENTY SEVEN MAKES ONE CHANGE
IN EXISTING LAW EXTENDS JOINT
LIABILITY TO ANY CONTRACTOR
THAT HIRES A SUBCONTRACTOR. WHO
DOES NOT RESPECT THE LAWS FOR
THE WORKERS THAT'S ALL I THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD A SUBCONTRACTOR HAS TO
KEEP RECORDS THAT'S A LOT AND
THEY HAVE TO PAY MINIMUM WAGE
THAT'S THE LAW. UNFORTUNATELY
SO MANY WHO WORK IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN IMAGINE
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS WITH THEIR
SKILLS BEING PAID BELOW THE
CALIFORNIA POVERTY STANDARD
WORK IN THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY
THAT IS PAID CASH OFF THE BOOKS
IS DESCRIBED AS RAMPANT BY THE
CALIFORNIA BUREAU OF FIELD
ENFORCEMENT. IN A RECENT CASE
OF MORE THAN ONE MILLION
DOLLARS OF WEIGHT TO THEM THE
SONG WAS THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
SAID SHE COULD NOT IDENTIFY
MANY OF THE WORKERS BECAUSE OF
THE SCANDAL EMPLOYEE RECORDS
HONEST GENERAL CONTRACTORS CAN
AND THEY DO KNOW WHAT THEIR
SUBCONTRACTORS ARE DOING ON THE
JOB. IF YOU ABIDE BY THE LAW
AND MONITOR YOUR SUBCONTRACTORS
YOU WILL OT BE LIABLE
COLLEAGUES YOU'VE HEARD ME
SPEAK ABOUT GARMENT WORKERS AND
SOMETIMES ABOUT FARM WORKERS
ALL THEY'RE ASKING FOR IS TO
GET PAID BY THE LAW. R. MARKER
JR FIVE OH THANK. YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM PRESIDENT JUST WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AS THIS MEASURE
WENT THROUGH THE PROCESS THAT
THE AUTHOR ACCEPTED THE
CONTRACTORS AMENDMENTS WHICH
PROVED TO BE QUITE REASONABLE
THAT RELIEVE THE GENERAL
CONTRACTOR OF ANY ADDED
LIABILITIES IF THEY TAKE THE
FOLLOWING. THREE INTERVALS ONE
WE ARE LIKELY REVIEW LEGALLY
REQUIRED PAY WAR RECORDS OF
THEIR SUBS TO TAKE CORRECTIVE
ACTIONS UPON BECOMING AWARE OF
A FAILURE TO PROPERLY PAY THEIR
WORKERS INCLUDING WITHHOLDING
PROGRESS PAYMENTS UNTIL THE
PROBLEM IS CORRECTED THREE
BEFORE THE FINAL PAYMENT IS
MADE REQUIRING A SIGNED
AFFIDAVIT UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY THAT THE SUBCONTRACTORS
PROPERLY PAID THEIR WORKERS.
THIS AMENDMENT TWO WHICH IS
STANDARD PROCEDURE IN THE
FORMAL- IN THE IN THE FORMAL
CONSTRUCTION ECONOMY HAS MOVED
ALMOST ALL OF THE CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATIONS FROM OPPOSED TO
NEUTRAL IT IS A THOUGHTFUL
PRACTICAL ELEMENT TO THIS
LEGISLATION I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVENTY SIX IT'S
A FAIR COMMONSENSE MEASURE THAT
PROTECTS NOT ONLY THE WORKER
BUT THOSE ARE HORRIBLE-
CONTRACTORS WHO DO THEIR JOB
AND ACCOUNT FOR THEIR SUB
CONTRACTORS AND MAKING SURE
THOSE EMPLOYEES ARE ARE PAID IN
A TIMELY MANNER- IN INDIAN
UNDERGROUND KHAN ACADEMY- THIS
MEASURES SHOULD ONLY BE FEARFUL
BY THOSE BAD OPERATORS WHO FAIL
TO PAY THEIR WORKERS IN A
RESPONSIBLE MANNER AND IT PUTS
A LITTLE ONUS ON THOSE
CONTRACTORS TO OVERSEE AND MAKE
SURE. THAT THOSE WORKERS GET
PAID ON THE STAIRWAY FOR ON THE
STATE WORK AND IT GIVES THEM A
LITTLE AND SENT PUTS A LITTLE
SKIN IN THE GAME SO IF- THEY'RE
DOING THE RIGHT THING THEY HAVE
NOTHING TO FEAR BUT IF THEY'RE
NOT THEY SHOULD BE HELD LIABLE
SO I ASKED. FOR A VOTE ON SB
SEVEN TWO SEVEN. ENTER AMBER.
AND COLLEAGUES- I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
CHINO FOR BEING FLEXIBLE IN
WORKING WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
IN JUDICIARY COMMITTEE I THINK
WE PRODUCED A GOOD PRODUCT IS
STILL A LITTLE BIT OF WORK TO
BE DONE BUT I THINK WE PRODUCED
A GOOD PRODUCT JOINT SEVERAL
LIABILITY IS A HEAVY HAMMER BUT
IS APPROPRIATE WHEN WAGES ARE
BEING STOLEN- I REGIONAL VOTE.
THANK YOU. SAYING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CENTER
LABOR YOU MAY CONCLUDE THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I LIKE TO
THANK ALL THE MEMBERS WHO SPOKE
IN FAVOR OF THE BILL AND THANK%
YOU FOR RECOGNIZING. THAT WAGE
THAT SHOULD NOT BE A COST OF
DOING BUSINESS AND I DO RESPECT
FAST FOR NINE VOTE. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
ADKINS I BAIT. NO BACKER.
GORGEOUS NO BRADFORD I KERR BIO
HI CORTESE HI DALLY NO DOT HI
THERE ALSO HI EGGMAN. HI GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH. HERTZBERG
I WITH SO I HER TADO I JONES NO
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA I
LIVE ALONE. I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MEN HI NEWMAN I
NELSON. NO A SHOW OF BOTH NO
PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH
I RUBIO. HI SKINNER I STERN I
AM BERG I LIKE HOW SKI FIVE
WINNER I WILL. NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER.
LASER. GROSS NO. HIGHS TWENTY
NINE KNOWS NINE THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY
ONE. SENATOR SKINNER ARE YOU
PREPARED. BE TEMPORARILY PASS-
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY
FOUR SENATOR NAME ON. SHE IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FIFTY BY SENATOR LYNN MON
AN ACT RELATING TO EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE CENTER IN
AMMAN YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS AS A
WORKING MOTHER OF AN INFANT I
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES THAT
MANY FACE RELATED TO CHILD CARE
MANY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS FACE
THE SAME STRUGGLE CURRENTLY OUR
SYSTEM IS ONLY SERVING 10% OF
ELIGIBLE INFANTS AND TODDLERS
ONLY TEN PERCENT. SENATE SB
FIFTY WILL OPEN MORE CHILDCARE
OPTIONS FOR INFANTS THIS BILL
DOES NOT REQUIRE PROVIDERS TO
MAKE ANY CHANGES BUT DOES ALLOW
FOR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS AND
PARENTS MORE FLEXIBILITY SB
FIFTY OPENS UP THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM TO CHILDREN
ZERO TO FIVE. IT ALLOWS FOR
PROVIDERS TO TRANSFER BETWEEN
STATE PRESCHOOL AND CHILD CARE
CONTRACTS GIVING PROVIDERS MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO SERVE THE NEEDS
OF THE COMMUNITIES AND ENSURE
THAT CHILDREN DO NOT LOSE CARE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A BIRTHDAY
FINALLY THIS BILL WILL MAKE IT
EASIER FOR FAMILIES TO ENROLL
AND STAY ENROLLED IN CHILDCARE
IT EASES THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN ON PARENTS AND PROVIDERS
BY ESTABLISHING TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS OF CONTINUOUS
ELIGIBILITY AND FOR ALLOWING
FOR CATEGORICAL ELIGIBILITY. SP
FIFTY HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. IS THERE ANY DISK OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN.
ARCHULETA HI AT I BASE HI
BECKER. GORGEOUS HIGH BRADFORD
I COULD BUY A FIVE CORTEZ C. HI
DALLY. DOT HI TORONTO BY ADMIN
HI GLAZER. I CONSOLIDATE HIGH
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI WITH SO.
HI HER TADO. FIVE JONES I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA. HI
THE MON HI WIRE I MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NELSON BUT SHOW
A VOGUE HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO.
FIVE ROTH I REVIEW I SKINNER.
FIVE STERN. I AM BERG I WOULD
CASKEY FIVE WINNER I WILL. HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN I. BECKER DALLY. GROSS I.
MELINDA'S I. NIELSEN. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE
MORE TIME. BACKER I. DALLY I.
NIELSEN. I THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTY EIGHT SENATOR RUBIO. ARE
YOU PREPARED. EARLY WILL PASS
THAT TEMPORARILY SENATOR
MCGUIRE YES PAST TEMPORARILY
SENATOR LEYVA. ITEM NUMBER
NINETY FILE ITEM NUMBER NINETY
SHE'S GOOD TO GO PLEASE READ.
SUCH IDM NUMBER. NINETY SENATE
BILL TWO FIFTEEN BY SENATOR
LEYVA AN ACT RELATING TO
EVIDENCE CENTER LABOR THE
FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN
MEMBERS SENATE BILL TWO FIFTEEN
CREATES A SURVIVOR HOLD PORTAL
IN CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING RAPE
KIT TRACKING SYSTEM THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT FORENSIC EVIDENCE
TRACKING SAFETY BASE THIS
PORTAL WILL ALLOW SURVIVORS OF
RAPE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT TO
PRIVATELY AND SECURELY TRACK
THE STATUS OF THEIR INDIVIDUAL
SEXUAL ASSAULT EVIDENCE KITS
THROUGH THE SELECTED TO DO THE
ELECTRONIC SAFETY BASE
DATABASE. THROUGH THIS PORTAL
CALIFORNIA WILL ENSURE THAT
SURVIVORS HAVE ACCESS TO
CRUCIAL AND TIMELY INFORMATION
REGARDING THEIR CASES ON THEIR
OWN TERMS THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE WILL EMPOWER SEXUAL
ASSAULT SURVIVORS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND HELP THEM TO
CONTINUE IN THEIR HEALING
PROCESS MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING THAT MEMBERS OF THIS
ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IF THERE IS NO
OBJECTION. SEEING NO OBJECTION
EYES FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER NINETY ONE
SENATOR WIENER IS READY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY
ONE BY SENATOR WIENER AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE SENATOR WIENER THE
FORGERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH BYE
TO PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I RISE
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL TWO
TWENTY ONE. WHICH WILL
ESTABLISH CLEAR TIMELY ACCESS
STANDARDS FOR FOLLOW UP CARE
NEEDED BY PATIENTS WHO ARE
BEING TREATED FOR MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS- IT
DOES SO BY EXPANDING AND
CLARIFYING EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS. FOR PEOPLE WHO
REQUIRE ONGOING CARE CURRENTLY-
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW TIMELY
ACCESS REQUIREMENTS SPECIFIED
THAT APPOINTMENTS FOR AN
INITIAL MENTAL HEALTH OR
SUBSTANCE USE TREATMENT
PROVIDER MUST OCCUR WITHIN TEN
BUSINESS DAYS. SO THAT PEOPLE
GET QUICK ACCESS TO CARE AND
DON'T HAVE TO WAIT FOR A LONG
TIME WHICH COULD MAKE THEIR
CONDITION WORSE. MMHM
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S NO
EXPLICIT EXPLICIT REQUIREMENT-
THAT THIS FIVE TEN DAY TEN
BUSINESS DAY- LIMITATION
APPLIED BEYOND INITIAL
APPOINTMENTS AS A RESULT WE'RE
SEEING PATIENTS WHO GOT A QUICK
FIRST MENTAL HEALTH
APPOINTMENTS BUT THEN HAVE TO
WAIT. FOR SIX EIGHT WEEKS OR
MORE OR EVEN MONTHS TO GET A
SUBSEQUENT APPOINTMENT WHICH
UNDERMINES THEIR CARE
SIGNIFICANTLY. WE KNOW THAT
WOULD COVER NINETEEN ARE
ALREADY BAD MENTAL HEALTH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
SITUATION HAS GOTTEN A LOT
WORSE- WE KNOW NATIONAL SURVEY
DATA SHOWS. THAT ANXIETY AND
DEPRESSION HAVE TRIPLED OVER
THE LAST YEAR. AND A RECENT CDC
STUDY FOUND THAT AN ASTOUNDING
ONE IN FOUR PEOPLE AGED
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR HAS
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERED SUICIDE-
IN THE PAST. THIRTY DAYS. WE
NEED TO MAKE PEOPLE ARE ACCESS
TO TREATMENT THE LEGISLATION
WILL DO SO BY ENSURING TIMELY
FOLLOW UP APPOINTMENTS I
RESPECT FOR US FROM MY BILL. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN. I ARCHULETA HI
AT KINS. BASED NO BACKER. HI
PORGES. BRADFORD I HAVE I
CORTEZ HE I DALLY. DODD HI
TORONTO HI EGGMAN I GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATES I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WISH SO HI HER TADO
HI JONES. NO CAM AUGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA. HI THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN. I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I WOULD SHOW
UP BOTH. NO PAN FIVE FORTUNE
TINO HI RALPH I REVIEW. I
SCANNER FIVE STERN I AM BERG I
LIKE CASSIE I WINNER I WILL. NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS GORGEOUS. DALLY NO.
GROVE NO. CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
AT KANSAS. FOR JUST. FIVE
THIRTY ONE NO SEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER NINETY TWO
SENATOR DODD IS PREPARED PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY
TWO BY SENATOR DODD AN ACT
RELATING TO WATER. SENATOR DODD
THE FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS SP TWO
TWO TWO TWO WOULD ESTABLISH THE
WATER RATE ASSISTANCE FUND AND
THE WATER RATE SYSTEM PROGRAM
TO HELP PROVIDE ASSISTANCE FOR
BOTH DRINKING WATER WASTEWATER
SERVICES. TO LOW INCOME
RATEPAYERS EXPERIENCING
ECONOMIC HARDSHIPS THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
RECENTLY SURVEYED HUNDREDS OF
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS AROUND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
DETERMINE HOW MUCH WATER THAT
WATER SYSTEMS CUSTOMERS WERE
CREWING EASY AND THE RESULTS OF
THAT SURVEY WERE SOBERING. HERE
ARE SOME EXAMPLES OF HOW
SERIOUS THE PROBLEM OF WATER
UNAFFORDABILITY HAS BECOME OVER
ONE AND A HALF MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS ARE BEHIND ON THEIR
WATER BILLS THAT'S OVER FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE STRUGGLING TO
PAY FOR CLEAN SAFE DRINKING
WATER. AND WASTEWATER. 12% OF
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS HAVE A
DOUBT IT AT LEAST FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN MORE THAN A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND OF THESE
HOUSEHOLDS HAVE DEBTS GREATER
THAN A THOUSAND DOLLARS. WELL%
I'M GRATEFUL TO THE GOVERNOR-
FOR PROPOSING ONE BILLION
DOLLARS OF WATER- DEBT RELIEF
THE TRUTH IS THAT THE TRUTH IS
THE PROBLEM OF WATER
AFFORDABILITY FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS WILL CONTINUE TO
PERSIST. THAT'S NOT GOOD FOR
THE RATEPAYERS THAT'S ALSO NOT
GOOD FOR THE. WATER DISTRICT'S
THEMSELVES. L. HAS A LOWER RATE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS FOR
ELECTRICITY AND NATURAL GAS
UTILITIES IT'S ABOUT TIME WE
HAVE A STATEWIDE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. FOR PEOPLE WHO
STRUGGLE TO PAY FOR THEIR
DRINKING AND WASTEWATER.
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS MADE THE OPERATION
OF THIS BILL CONTINGENT UPON A
FUTURE- APPROPRIATION. OF FUNDS
WHICH I INTEND TO PURSUE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ON
THIS CRITICALLY NEEDED PROPER
PROGRAM. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. CENTRE HER TITLE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWO TWO
TWO WHICH IS STATUS AS A LOW
INCOME WATERY ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM WATER IS KEY TO LIFE AS
A STATE WE RECOGNIZE THIS
DECLINE ACCESS TO WATER AS A
HUMAN RIGHT BUT CLIMATE CHANGE
IS CREATING THE WATER CRISIS
UNFORTUNATELY FOR SOME IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT ACCESS IS
BECOMING MORE AND MORE
EXPENSIVE. AS PRICES RISE THE
MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE THE FIRST TO
MOST IMPACTED MY CONSTITUENTS
ARE AMONG THEM I'M SUPPORTING%
THIS BILL BECAUSE I KNOW IT'S
TIME WE MAKE GOOD ON OUR
PROMISE IN ESTABLISHING WATER
AS A HUMAN RIGHT. CAN I RESPECT
LAST FOR MY BOOK. IN ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. I
SEE NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SENATOR DODD YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. RESPECT FOR NASSAR
EITHER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA I AT. I BAIT.
BACKER I PORCHES. BRADFORD I
KERR BIO HI CORTESE HI DALLY NO
DOG. HI TORONTO BY ADMIN. I
GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES FIVE
GROWTH FIVE HERTZBERG I WAS SO.
HI- TANTO HI JONES NO CAN
LONGER HI LAYERED I. LEIVA FIVE
THE MON. I REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S.
HI MAN. NEWMAN I NELSON NO A
CHOKE NO PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO.
I. ROSS HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER.
FIVE STERN HI NUMBER NINE I
PLAY CASKEY FIVE WINNER FIVE
WELK NO PLEASE PLEASE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MELINDA'S I DON'T KNOW. BATES
NO. BARGES MEN. FIVE THIRTY ONE
NO SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT
SENATOR CABALLERO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY FIVE BY
SENATOR KABBADI AUTO AN ACT
RELATING THAT TO THE HEALTHY
OUTCOMES IN PREVENTION
EDUCATION ACT IN MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE. CENTER
CALERO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT SP
THREE NINETY FIVE THE HEALTHY
OUTCOMES AND PREVENTION
EDUCATION ACT. E. CIGARETTES
CONTAIN A HARMFUL COMBINATION
OF NICOTINE FLAVORING FLAVORING
AND OTHER CHEMICALS ADDITIVES
ALTHOUGH THEY ARE CURRENTLY
TAXED AS OTHER TOBACCO
PRODUCTS- OTP THE TAX RATE IS
MUCH LOWER THAN THAT OF
TRADITIONAL CIGARETTES THEREBY
CONTRIBUTING TO THE GROWING
DISPARITY BETWEEN THESE
PRODUCTS AND UNDERMINING THE
EFFORTS TO CURB VAPING. THIS
MEASURE SEEKS TO CREATE PARITY
BETWEEN THESE TWO PRODUCTS
THESE TWO TOBACCO PRODUCTS AS
YOU KNOW VAPING HAS BECOME
INCREASINGLY POPULAR DESPITE
THE HIGH RISK OF ADVERSE HEALTH
OUTCOMES THIS IS ESPECIALLY
PROBLEMATIC AMONG OUR YOUTH.
ACCORDING TO THE CDC'S NATIONAL
YOUTH TOBACCO SURVEY NEARLY 20%
OF HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
REPORTED CURRENT E. CIGARETTE
USE AND ABOUT 40% REPORTED
HEAVY USE OF E. CIGARETTES THE
AVAILABILITY OF YOUTH APPEALING
FLAVORS AND MARKETING HAS IN
LARGE PART CONTRIBUTED. TO THIS
TREND TOBACCO RETAILERS ARE%
MORE PREVALENT IN THE POOREST
AND MOST ETHNICALLY DENSE
NEIGHBORHOOD WHICH. INCLUDES
POPULATION MOST AT RISK.
BECAUSE OF IN A HEALTH CARE
ACCESS AND COVERAGE IT'S B.
THREE NINETY FIVE PROPOSES TAX
PARITY BETWEEN THE SALE OF
FAITH AND TRADITIONAL TAX
PRODUCTS PROCEEDS OF THE
REVENUE GENERATED GO TO
EXISTING VOTER APPROVED SOURCES
INCLUDING EARLY CHILDHOOD-
SERVICES PUBLIC HEALTH AND
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE PROGRAMS.
TO INCLUDE FUNDING FOR
PHYSICIAN STUDENT LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAMS FOR THOSE
WORKING IN OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED STUDENT
COMMUNITIES THE BILL ENJOYS
BROAD SUPPORT FROM PUBLIC
HEALTH ORGANIZATION LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY AND HAS NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU
SENATOR CAFIERO MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE- I'M SORRY
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
TODAY I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
AS A CO AUTHOR MYSELF WHEN IT
COMES TO CHILDREN- WE CAN'T SAY
THIS ENOUGH WE HAVE TO PASS
THESE POLICIES TO HELP THEM-
YOU KNOW CHIEF HEALTH AND THIS
ONE BILL IN PARTICULAR- WE
DEFINITELY NEED TO. PUT
RESOURCES INTO EDUCATION AND
THIS BILL DOES JUST THAT AND SO
I'M HERE TO ALSO URGE AN IDOL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
QUESTIONS CONCERNS AND
SECRETARY PROJECT CLOSER TO
COVER YOUR RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR YOUR I. BOATS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA I AT KINS I BASE.
BACKER I FOR JUST. BRADFORD I
KERR BY OTHER I. CORTEZ HE I
DALLY. NO DODD. I TORONTO HI
ADNAN I GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ I
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG. WEST SO.
HI HER TADO. JONES NO CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA. I THE
MON I REQUIRE FIVE MELINDA'S.
NO MAN. NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A
SHOW OF BOTH NO PAN HI FORTUNE
TINO. BROTH FIVE RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN. HI AMBER. BY
CAL SKI FIVE WINNER I WILL NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN BAYTEX. BORDERS. HERTZBERG
I HER TADO. MAN FORTUNE TINO.
AMBERG THE CALL CENTER MOVES A
CALL WE WERE REMOVING THE FILE
ITEM ONE ELEVEN SENATOR
CABALLERO MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FOUR
SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR KERR BIO
AN ACT RELATING TO CORRECTIONS
SO THE COPIER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT FOR SEVENTY S. BEFORE
SEVENTY TWO THE PAY FOR SUCCESS
GRANT PROGRAM THIS BILL EXTENDS
THE SUNSET OF THE PAY FOR
SUCCESS GRANT PROGRAM AN
INNOVATIVE OUTCOMES BASED AND
RESCINDED ANTI RECIDIVISM
PROGRAM. IT WOULD GET EXTENDED
TO TWENTY THIRTY ONE AND
EXTENDS THE OPPORTUNITY TO EDIT
IT ADDITIONAL FIVE COUNTIES TO
APPLY FOR GRANT FUNDING. IN
ADDITION THE BILL EXPANDS
QUALIFYING PROGRAMS TO THOSE
THAT ADDRESS THE NEXUS BETWEEN
RECIDIVISM AND HOMELESSNESS AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE THIS BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION AND ENJOYS
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND IS A PROVEN METHOD TO
LEVERAGE MINIMAL STATE FUNDING
TO HAVE A DIRECT IMPACT WITHIN
OUR COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR
CAFIERO MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE. SIMON SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. ARCHULETA
I AT KINS I BASE I BECKER HI
FOR JUST. BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM HI CORTESE HI DALLY. I
DONT HI THERE ALSO HI ADNAN I
BELIEVE HER. HI CONSOLIDATES
HIGH GROWTH. HERTZBERG FIVE
WEST SO. HI HER TADO FIVE JONES
I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LABOR.
LABOUR I WILL MOAN I REQUIRE
FIVE MELINDA'S I MEN. FIVE
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN FIVE A SHOW
BOTH I PAM I FORTUNE TINO.
BRAVO I RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN
I AM BERG HI BY CAL SKI I
WINNER I WELL I. FIVE THIRTY
SIX NO ZERO UP MOVED OUT-
ABSOLUTELY FORGOT- WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE THE COLONISTS. MEMBERS
ARE GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER NINETY SEVEN CENTER
EARLY MORNING IS READY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL TWO NINETY
SIX BY SENATOR LEE MOANS AND
ACT RELATED TO CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS. CENTERING ON THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ARE
CHARGED WITH ENFORCING STATE
AND LOCAL HOUSING LAWS AND
VARIOUS PESTS MOLD LEAD AND
OTHER REGULATIONS CONCERNING
HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS. THIS WORK
IS CRITICAL TO IMPROVING
HOUSING CONDITIONS HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS.
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF THE
WORK CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
ARE EXPOSED TO A RANGE OF
HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS AND
ENVIRONMENT. COULD ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS ARE OFTEN THREATENED
HARASSED OR EVEN ASSAULTED AND
TRAGICALLY THERE HAVE BEEN
COULD ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS HAVE
BEEN MURDERED IN THE LINE OF
DUTY. THE CURRENT CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS ALSO INCREASED
HEALTH THREATS TO CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TO
CONTINUE THEIR WORK DESPITE THE
ADDITIONAL HAZARDOUS TO THEIR
HEALTH WELL MANY CITIES HAVE
DEVELOPED SAFETY STANDARDS TO
HELP PROTECT PEACE OFFICERS.
MAJORS DIXON'S LAX STANDARDS
APPLICABLES TO CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS SP TWO NINETY SIX
WOULD DIRECT EACH LOCAL
JURISDICTION THAT EMPLOYEES PUT
HIM FORCING OFFICERS TO DEVELOP
APPROPRIATE SAFETY STANDARDS.
BASED ON THE NATURE OF THEIR
WORK AND THE ISSUES THEY FACE
THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
TO PROTECT CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS THAT RISK THEIR SAFETY
HEALTH AND LAW AND PROTECT.
LIVES FOR OUR COMMUNITY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ITEM.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE SIDE. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE PLEASE. SENATOR PAN YES
CENTER I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT TO SATURDAY TO RISE
AND SUPPORT THIS BILL I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT- ACTUALLY BACK
IN JANUARY WE HAD A RESTAURANT
SPECTER HERE IN SACRAMENTO WHO
WAS MURDERED- THIS IS IMPORTANT
THAT- PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING THE
WORK OF THE PEOPLE- SHOULDN'T
NEED PROTECTION AND- AGAIN WITH
HER TONIGHT. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA FIVE
ATKINS I BASE I BACKER. I FOR
JUST. BRADFORD I KERR BUY A HI
HI COURTESY. I DALLY I DON FIVE
TORONTO HI ADNAN I PLEASE SIR
HI CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROWTH HI
HURTS BERG I WAS SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I. LEIVA. I LIVE ALONE
I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN
FIVE NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. HI A
CHOKE I PAM I FORTUNE TINO.
ROTH HI RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN
I AM BERG I LIKE HOW SKI FIVE
WINNER I WILL I SYNERGY MOON
MOVES A CALL MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER NINETY NINE SENATOR
CORTESE ARE YOU PREPARED HE IS.
PLEASE PLEASE READ OUR. CENTER
CASEY WOULD LIKE TO PASS ON
FILE MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED SENATOR RUBIO. PASS
ON FILE AS WELL SENATOR WIENER-
I DON'T I DON'T NUMBER ONE NO
ONE HE IS PREPARED PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY NINE
BY SENATOR WIENER AN ACT
RELATING TO VEHICLES. SENATOR
WIENER THE FLOOR'S YOURS. YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT CALLING SENATE
BILL THREE THIRTY NINE- THE GAS
TAX ALTERNATIVE PLAN THAT WILL
EXTEND THE EXISTING- ROAD
CHARGE TECHNICAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE FROM TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TO TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN.-ALLOW THIS PILOT PROGRAM- TO
CONTINUE- THIS PILOT WHICH WAS
CREATED BACK IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN. AND IS ADMINISTERED
BY THE- THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY AND THE
CITY C. ALLOWS FOR THE STUDY OF
AN ALTERNATIVE TO THE GAS TAX A
ROAD USER CHARGE. OR CHARGE FOR
DRIVERS BASED ON THE MILES THEY
TRAVEL CURRENTLY THE GAS TAX
THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE PLAYS A
CRITICAL ROLE IN FUNDING
CALIFORNIA STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM
OUR LOCAL ROADS. UNDER PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
HOWEVER THE GAS TAX IS NOT A
VIABLE LONG TERM SOLUTION FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING. I DO
TOO AND THIS IS A GOOD THING
INCREASES AND VEHICLE-
EFFICIENCY AND THE RISE OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES WE WANT THESE
THINGS TO HAPPEN BUT THAT MEANS
LESS USE OF GAS WHICH IS A GOOD
THING BUT THAT MEANS LESS GAS
TAX TO FUND OUR TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM. TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM
SO WE DON'T EXPERIENCE A CLIFF
AT SOME POINT IN THE FUTURE. A
FUNDING CLASS. SO THAT WE CAN
FIND OUR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE WE NEED TO PLAN
FOR A TRANSITION AWAY FROM THE
GAS TAX AND TOWARD A FORM OF A
ROAD USER CHARGE. ON SP THREE
THIRTY NINE DOES NOT REQUIRE
ANYTHING NO ONE WILL BE
REQUIRED TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PILOT PROGRAM NO ONE WILL BE
REQUIRED TO PAY- THE ROAD
CHARGE AS PART OF THIS PILOT
PROGRAM CITED PURELY VOLUNTARY.
IT SIMPLY ALLOWS FOR FURTHER
STUDY OF THIS CRUCIAL POLICY
THROUGH A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM SO
THAT PEOPLE CAN PARTICIPATE.
ONLY IF THEY WANT TO. SP THREE
THIRTY NINE ALL THE PIE IN A
FEW WAYS. FIRST IT'LL FOR THE
TO BE ACTUALLY. REVENUE FROM
THE VOLUNTEER PARTICIPANTS. OF
PREVIOUS VERSIONS USE MOCK
INVOICES TO COLLECT A ROW
CHARGED BUT THIS CHANGE WILL
ALLOW THE CITY SEE TO TEST. THE
ACTUAL COLLECTION PROCESS AND
UNDERSTAND POTENTIAL REVENUE
STREAMS SECOND THE BILL SPLIT
PARTICIPANTS INTO TWO GROUPS.
ONE WITH THE ROAD CHARGE BASED
SOLELY ON MILEAGE ANOTHER
pINTO ACCOUNT THE EFFICIENCY OF
THE V. UP TO SOMEONE'S VEHICLE-
AND TO DEMONSTRATE THE
POTENTIAL BENEFITS OF THE ROAD
USER CHARGE. AND TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND HOW WE SHOULD SET-SUCH A FEE. THE CDC WILL REPORT
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE WITH
ALL OF THE RELEVANT DATA
CALLING SERVICES- GOOD BILL.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK HERE I
GO. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SINGMAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BASE NO
BACKER HI FOR JUST NO BRADFORD
I HAVE A HI CORTESE. I DALLY NO
DODD HI DERISIVE HI ADNAN I
GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES I GROW.
NO HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO. JONES NO CAMELOT- I
LAYERED HI LLEVA I LIVE ALONE
HI MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO MAN.
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF
VOGUE. NO PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO.
RALPH FIVE RUBIO I SKINNER. HI
STERN HI AMBERG. WHITE HOUSE E.
FIVE WINNER I WILL. NO SENATOR
WIENER MOVES A CALL. MOVING ON
TO ITEM ONE OH THREE SENATOR
NEWMAN ARE YOU PREPARED HE IS
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL THREE
SIXTY TWO BY SENATOR NEWMAN AN
ACT RELATING TO HEALING ARTS
CENTER NEWMAN THE FLOOR'S
YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I RISE TO
PRESENT SP THREE SIXTY TWO
WHICH WILL PROHIBIT THE
APPLICATION OF SALES QUOTAS OR
OTHER PERFORMANCE BASED METRICS
WHICH WOULD INTERFERE WITH THE
PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S LICENSED
PHARMACISTS. OR NEIGHBORHOOD
PHARMACIST DISPENSED NEARLY 70%
OF ALL PRESCRIPTIONS
UNFORTUNATELY THEY ARE
INCREASINGLY SADDLED WITH
PROFIT DRIVEN SALES QUOTAS SUCH
AS UP SELLING PATIENTS INTO
AUTOMATIC REFILL PROGRAMS ARE
FILLING A MINIMUM NUMBER OF
PRESCRIPTIONS PER HOUR. AS WELL
AS OTHER CORPORATE DIRECTOR
OBJECTIVES WHICH NOT ONLY HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE SAFE
PRACTICE OF MEDICINE BUT CAN
INTERFERE WITH THEIR ABILITY TO
DO JUST THAT IN ACCORDANCE WITH
THE PROFESSIONAL POST THIS BILL
ISN'T MERELY ABOUT PROTECTING
PHARMACIST IT'S ABOUT
PROTECTING THEIR PATIENTS AS
WELL WHICH IS TO SAY ALL OF US.
AND ALL OF OUR FAMILIES FROM
THE MISTAKES THAT INEVITABLY
ARISE FROM INATTENTION ENCASED
IN A PHARMACY PHARMACISTS ARE
THE LAST LINE OF DEFENSE
AGAINST POTENTIALLY DEADLY DRUG
INTERACTIONS AS THEY FILL
PRESCRIPTIONS THEY MUST CONTACT
PRESCRIBING PHYSICIANS VERIFY
CORRECT DOSING CHECK FOR DRUG
INTERACTIONS. AND ALLERGIC
REACTIONS AND COUNSEL EDUCATE
AND ANSWER PATIENT QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE MEDICINE THEY
PRESCRIBE. EACH YEAR NEARLY ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS ARE HARMED BY
UNINFORMED OR IMPROPER USE OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS PHARMACY
SALES QUOTAS AND THEIR
DETRIMENTAL IMPACT ON
PHARMACISTS HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH CNSCIENTIOUS PATIENT CARE
AND EVERYTHING TO DO WITH
CORPORATE PROFITS THE
PHARMACIST LIKE DOCTORS MUST BE
FREE TO PRACTICE MEDICINE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE ETHICAL
DICTATES OF THEIR PROFESSION.
AS P. THREE SIX TWO IS A
NECESSARY AND REASONABLE
MEASURE TOWARD RESTORING THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF PATIENTS
AS A TOP PRIORITY AND WILL
ENSURE THE PHARMACIST WILL BE
ABLE TO ADHERE TO THEIR- TO
MAKE MEDICAL DECISIONS BASED
CLEARLY AND SOLELY ON PATIENT
NEEDS. RECENT AMENDMENTS REMOVE
THE BUSINESS LICENSE OR
SUSPENSION AND REVOCATION
PENALTY PROVISIONS AS WELL. AS
THE ORIGINALLY PROPOSED
ORIGINALLY PROPOSED ONE MILLION
DOLLARS PROVIDE. HIGH RISK ASK
FOR YOUR I. VOTE TODAY. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU- MADAM
PRESIDENT I JUST WANT TO STAND
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURES
WELL YOU KNOW IN MY PREVIOUS
LIFE AND THE OPPORTUNITY
SERVICE A MEMBER OF THE BOARD
OF PHARMACY AND LEARN A LOT
ABOUT THE INDUSTRY AND THERE'S
NO QUESTION THESE COMMUNITY
PHARMACISTS ARE REALLY THE
FRONT LINE OF DEFENSE TO HUGELY
IMPORTANT UNDERSTANDING DRUG
INTERACTIONS AND I JUST- YOU
KNOW AND REALLY WORKED ON THIS
BEFORE BUT I JUST AS I SEE IT
NOW PRESENTED BEFORE THE FLOOR.
AND HAVING THAT EXPERIENCE
SERVING AS A PUBLIC MEMBER ON
THE BOARD FOR FOUR YEARS I JUST
WANT TO STAND STRONG SUPPORT
OF- THIS MEASURE THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SENATOR SKINNER. RIGHT.
LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE ASKING FOR IS
THE MEMBERS- SOME OF US TO
REALIZE THAT PHARMACISTS ALSO
HAVE LIABILITY. IF THEY'RE- IF
A PRESCRIPTION ORDERED BY
DOCTOR IS IN CONFLICT WITH
ANOTHER MEDICINE THAT PATIENT
IS TAKING EVEN IF THE DOCTOR
DID NOT PRESCRIBE THE OTHER
MEDICINE SO PHARMACISTS HAVE A
GREAT DEAL OF LIABILITY SO WE
REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE JUST
AS THE AUTHOR SPOKE. THAT THEY
ARE PAYING PROPER ATTENTION AND
LOOKING AT THE RECORDS OF WHAT-
PRESCRIPTIONS THEY FILLED ANY
OTHER MEDICINES POSSIBLY THAT
THERE- CLIENT MAY BE TAKING AND
EVEN ASKING QUESTIONS IF THEY
KNOW THERE'S ADVERSE. AFFECTS
OF INTERACTIONS WITH VARIOUS
DRUGS AND I THINK PROVIDING
THIS BILL BY ENSURING THAT THEY
TAKE THE APPROPRIATE TIME IS A
VERY IMPORTANT WITHOUT I ASKED
HER ABOUT. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SENATOR
NEWMAN YOU MAY CONCLUDE- I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES
THOUGHTFUL WORDS IN THEIR
EXPRESSIONS OF SUPPORT AND I
RESPECT THE ASTRONOMICAL. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA R. HI AT KINS I
BASICS. BACKER HI PORCHES NO
BRADFORD I HAVE MY OTHER HIGH
COURTS HAS HE HI DALLY. NO DODD.
DURAZO FIVE A GIVEN I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I BROKE. NO HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO. I HER TADO. HI
JONES NO CAMEL OWNER I LAYERED
HI LLEVA I LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE.
I MELINDA'S NO MAN. I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN NO A TOTAL OF BOTH. NO
PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO. ROTH HI
RUBIO I SKINNER. HI STERN HI
I'M I WOULD CASKEY I WINNER I
WILL KNOW THE SENATOR NEWMAN
MOVES A CALL. MEMBERS ARE GONNA
MOVE ONTO I'D ITEM WHEN- FOR
CENTER LATE BUT SHE IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR LEYVA AN
ACT RELATING TO VEHICLES. UNDER
CENTER LABOR THE FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS SP THREE
SEVENTY TWO ESTABLISHES THE
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE FLEET
PURCHASING ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
WHICH WILL IN CONSULTATION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS DESIGN NEW
FINANCING TOOLS TO HELP OWNERS
OF MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES PURCHASE CLEANER ZERO
EMISSION ALTERNATIVES AS MANY
OF YOU ARE AWARE MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS AND BUSES ARE
A MAJOR SOURCE OF AIR
POLLUTION. IN CALIFORNIA
CONTRIBUTING TO POOR AIR
QUALITY A NEGATIVE RESPIRATORY
HEALTH OUTCOMES REPLACING THESE
VEHICLES WITH ZERO EMISSION
ALTERNATIVES IS NEEDED TO
REDUCE THE HARMFUL AIR
POLLUTION THAT NEGATIVELY
IMPACTS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
WORSENS CLIMATE CHANGE. AS THE
THREE SEVENTY TWO WILL ALSO
CREATE A ONE STOP SHOP WEBSITE
TO PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT
ALL OF THE POTENTIAL FINANCING
GRANT OPTIONS AND OTHER
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT IS
AVAILABLE TO HELP OBTAIN
FINANCING FOR THESE VEHICLES.
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS TO
GET THE STATE TO THINK
CREATIVELY ABOUT HOW WE CAN
BEST LEVERAGE STATE FUNDS BRING
IN PRIVATE CAPITAL IN INSTANCES
WHERE THEY MAKE SENSE. AND
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND MAXIMIZE THE ABILITY FOR
FLEETS OF ALL SIZES TO
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
OPTIONS AND ULTIMATELY HELP
ACCELERATE OUR ABILITY TO GET
CLEANER AND GREENER TRUCKS ON
THE ROAD MEMBERS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
SENATOR MEN. THANK YOU MAN
PRESIDENT PRESIDENT- I JUST
WANT TO- MEDICARE I'M SORRY I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
CHINO FOR THIS BILL IF WE HAVE
SEEN IN VICIOUS MANDATES IN THE
STATE WE ARE TRYING TO LEAD ON
REVERSING THE TRENDS IN CLIMATE
CHANGE BUT TO DO THAT WE CAN'T
JUST IMPLEMENT MANDATES WE ALSO
NEED TO PROVIDE SUPPORT AND
THIS IS EXACTLY THE TYPE OF
SMART BILL THAT WE NEED MORE
OF. THANK YOU I ASKED FOR A
VOTE. THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CNN
CENTER LABOR YOU MAY CONCLUDE
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. HAVE A- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA I ADKINS FIVE BASE HI
BECKER FIVE PORGES HI BRADFORD
I KERR BY OTHER HIGH COURTS AS
HE- I DALLY. DODD HI THERE
AWESOME I HATE MEN I LASER EYE
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH FIVE
HERTZBERG. I WAS SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I. LEIVA. I LIVE MON.
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S I MEN FIVE
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF
BOTH. HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO.
ROTH HI RUBIO. I SKINNER I
STERN HI AMBER HI BY CAL SKI.
FIVE WINNER I WILL HI. SENATOR
LABOR MOVES THE CALL. SENATOR
STERN I AM NUMBER. ONE OH
SEVEN. HE IS PREPARED PLEASE
READ. SENATOR FOR TWENTY THREE
BY SENATOR STERN AN ACT
RELATING TO ENERGY. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS PRESENT
AS BEFORE TWENTY THREE TO YOU
ALL TO. POSE A CALIFORNIA TYPE
SOLUTION TO THE ROLLING
BLACKOUTS WE SAW- LAST AUGUST
AS OPPOSED TO BY THE WAY TEXAS
IS PROPOSED TO REBUILD THEIR
GRID DOUBLING DOWN. ON THE
ISLAND IN THEIR OLD FOSSE WAYS
HE IN CAL WITH WE CAN DO BETTER-
THE EXTRA HEAT WAVES ARE ENDING
ANYTIME SOON. AND WE TO BE SURE
THAT I. EXISTING RESEARCH RICH
THERE BE RUDE- BY OUR ENERGY RE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO SEE SEE SEE
THE P. YOU SEE IN OTHER
AGENCIES LOOK AT THE OUTAGES OF
THE PAST FEW YEARS AS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT. OF GRID
RESILIENCY SOLUTIONS I KNOW
THERE'S A NUMBER OF
TECHNOLOGIES IN WAYS WE CAN GET
THERE AS WE ACHIEVE OUR SP ONE
HUNDRED GOALS INCLUDING
GEOTHERMAL OFFSHORE WIND GREEN
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN LONG
DURATION ENERGY STORAGE MULTI
DAY ENERGY STORAGE AND OTHER
RESOURCE IDENTIFIED. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED THIRTY FIVE
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND
TO SUPPORT THIS IMPLEMENTATION
AND MORE ON OFFSHORE WIND
DEVELOPMENT BUT WE ACTUALLY
NEED THE AGENCIES. TO GET
FOCUSED AND COORDINATE AMONGST
THEMSELVES TO GET THIS WORK
DONE THAT MEANS INCLUDING I
SERVE ON THE AIRPORT AS WELL.
AND FOR THE C. SEED TO ADOPT
RECOMMENDATIONS TO LOOK AT
STRENGTHENING THESE NEAR MEDIUM
AND LONG TERM TARGETS WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD THAT
OUR ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE IN A
WAY HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WILL NOT JUST PUT PEOPLE BACK
TO WORK. AND KEEP OUR LIGHTS ON
BUT HOPEFULLY ACHIEVE A LIVABLE
CLIMATE FUTURE IN THE PROCESS.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IPHONE. THREE DISK OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA I AT KINS I BASE NO
BACKER I FOR JUST NO BRADFORD.
CABRERA I PROTESTING I DALLY NO
DODD HI THERE ALSO I EGGMAN HI
GLAZER. HI CONDOLENCES I GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG HI WITH HI- TIDO I
JONES NO CAN LONGER. HI LAYERED
I LABOR. HI LYNN MON. REQUIRE
HI MELINDA'S NO MAN HI NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO BUT SHOW BOTH. PAN
HI FORTUNE TINO. ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN HI NUMBER FIVE
CASSIE I WINNER I WILL NO
SENATOR STERN MOVES A CALL
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER ONE
TEN SENATOR HER TADO ARE YOU
PREPARED. SHE IS PLEASE READ
SEND UP OF FOUR SIXTY FOUR BY
SENATOR HER TADO AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES SENATOR HERTEL TO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU. I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SP FOUR
SIX FOUR. LAST WEEK I
INTRODUCED SB ONE ZERO EIGHT
THE HUMAN RIGHT TO FOOD ACT. S.
B. FOUR SIX FOUR ADDRESS IS
FEEDING THE RESIDENTS OF OUR
STATE IT WORKS TO ENSURE THERE
IS GREATER EQUITY IN
CALIFORNIA'S FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS. PRIOR TO THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
APPROXIMATELY ONE IN TEN
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCE FOOD
INSECURITY THE PANDEMIC AND
RESULTING ECONOMIC CRISIS HAS
EXACERBATED FOOD INSECURITY
ACROSS THE STATE PARTICULARLY
AMONG LOW WAGE. IMMIGRANTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. IT'S ESTIMATED
THAT ONE IN FOUR UNDOCUMENTED
HOUSEHOLDS ARE FOOD INSECURE.
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS DACA
RECIPIENTS TEMPORARY PROTECTED
STATUS HOLDERS AND CERTAIN VISA
HOLDERS WERE DEEMED ESSENTIAL
WORKERS DURING. THE PANDEMIC.
UP AND THEY ALSO HAVE TO
PROVIDE FOOD FOR THEIR OWN
DINNER TABLES AND THE DINNER
TABLES OF OTHERS AT THE RISK OF
THEIR OWN LIVES. THE SAME
WORKERS ARE EXCLUDED FROM THE
FEDERAL CALFRESH AND OUR STATE
FUNDED CALIFORNIA FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. THESE
EXCLUSIONS HAVE FORCED
IMMIGRANT HOUSEHOLDS TO MAKE
IMPOSSIBLE CHOICES BETWEEN
BUYING GROCERIES AND COVERING
THE COST OF RENT OR OTHER BASIC
NEEDS. THEY WORK IN THE SHADOWS
AND SUFFER IN SILENCE. FOOD FOR
ALL MEANS MORE THAN SOMEONE'S
FOOD SECURITY STATUS AND FOOD
SECURITY MEANS MUCH MORE THAN
SOMEONE STATUS. PUT FOR ALL
MEANS GOOD HEALTH WITHOUT
HEALTHY FOODS CHILDREN'S
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH AS
WELL AS ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT
AND FUTURE PROSPERITY ARE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED. THE
PANDEMIC HAS LAID BARE THE
INEQUITIES AND INJUSTICES THAT
ARE EMBEDDED THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND SOCIETY. AS
BEFORE SIX FOUR WILL HELP
UNITES US BECAUSE FOOD UNITES
US THIS IS NOT ABOUT
IMMIGRATION STATUS OR US VERSUS
THEM- MEANS OPPORTUNITIES SUCH
AS THOSE MY PARENTS FOUND IN
FOOD. IT'S ABOUT ENSURING THAT
NO ONE GOES HUNGRY SP FOUR SIX
FOUR MODERNIZES THE CALIFORNIA
FOOD ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY FOR STATE
FUNDED NUTRITION BENEFITS. TO
ANYONE IN ELIGIBLE FOR CALFRESH
TO SOLELY TO THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS IN DOING SO THE BILL
PROVIDES GREATER FOOD SECURITY
TO LOW INCOME IMMIGRANT WORKERS
HELPING THEM LIVE. HELPING LIFT
THE LEFT THEM OUT OF POVERTY AS
CALFRESH IS PROVEN TO DO SO.
THIS IS A BILL THAT IS BOTH
GOOD FOR FARMERS AND FARM
WORKERS. FOOD IS HEALTH FOOD IS
LIFE FOOD IS A HUMAN RIGHT AND
LET'S MAKE SURE CALIFORNIA IS A
STATE WHERE FOOD IS FOR ALL.
CAMILLA PARKER BOWLES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FRIEND ABOUT.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA HI ADKINS HI BAIT NO
BECKER HI FOR JUST. BRADFORD
BYE BYE UNDER EYE CORTESE HI
DALLY. NO DODD I TORONTO I
EGGMAN. FIVE GLAZER I BEEN
SOLID HIGH GROWTH NO HERTZBERG
I WISH SO. HI HER TADO FIVE
JONES NO CAN WANDER. I LAYERED
I LABOR. I THE MON. MCGUIRE
FIVE MELINDA'S NO MAN HI NEWMAN
I NIELSEN. BUT SHOW VOGUE NO
PAN I FORTUNE TINO ROTH FIVE
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN HI
NUMBER FIVE WHAT KIND OF SKI I
WINNER I WILL. NOW FOR JUST NOW
SENATOR HERTEL REMOVES A CALL.
RIVERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER ONE TWELVE SENATOR
MAN IS PREPARED PLEASE READ.
CENTER I'M IF YOU JUST HOLD ON
A SECOND- READ READ THE BILL.
SENATE BILL FOUR SEVENTY SIX BY
SENATOR MAN AN ACT RELATING TO
THE PACE PROGRAM CENTER BIN MEN
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. AMBER'S SP FOUR
SEVENTY SIX ESTABLISHES TWO
CRITICAL REFORMS THAT HELP
ADDRESS SOME OF THE MOST COMMON
CONSUMER ABUSES WE CONTINUE TO
SEE IN THE PACE PROGRAM. WITH
RESPECT TO THE SOLICITATION AND
FINANCING ASPECTS. FIRST THE
BILL REQUIRES A QUALIFIED THIRD
PARTY TO PERFORM AN ENERGY
AUDIT. TO ENSURE THE HOME
IMPROVEMENTS WILL REDUCE ENERGY
CONSUMPTION OR FOSSIL FUELS USE.
A SOLICITOR'S OFTEN PROVIDE
UNREALISTIC ESTIMATES ABOUT HOW
MUCH MONEY HOMEOWNERS WILL SAVE
IN ENERGY COSTS. CONSUMERS ARE
PROMISED ENERGY SAVINGS THAT
MAY NEVER MATERIALIZE AND
PITCHED UPGRADES THEY MAY NOT
NEED. AS BEFORE SEVENTY SIX WAS
AMENDED TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE SENATE BANKING
COMMITTEE AND OPPOSITION
RELATED TO THE OPPOSITE
RELATING TO THE AUDIT
PROVISIONS SPECIFICALLY RECENT
AMENDMENTS CLARIFY WHO CAN
CONDUCT THE REQUIRED ENERGY
AUDIT. AND EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
QUALIFIED AUDITORS TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS AROUND THAT. THEY ALSO
NARROW THE SCOPE OF THE ENERGY
AUDIT BY REQUIRING ONLY BECAME
HOME IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE
BEING MADE TO BE ASSESSED FOR
SUITABILITY- THEY WAIVE THE
AUDIT FOR EMERGENCY HOME
IMPROVEMENTS. THE SECOND
IMPORTANT REFORM THE SP FOUR
SEVENTY SIX MAKES IS HALTING
PAYMENTS TO A CASE CONTRACTOR
UNTIL A PROGRAM ADMINISTRATOR
HAS OBTAINED COPIES OF PERMITS
FOR FINAL INSPECTIONS TO VERIFY
THAT ALL WORK HAS BEEN
ADEQUATELY PERFORMED.
RESIDENTIAL CASE HAS A HISTORY
OF CONSUMER COMPLAINTSREGARDING UNFINISHED OR
UNACCEPTABLE WORK AND
IMPROVEMENTS THE CONTRACTORS
HAVE CHARGE FOR BUT NEVER
INSTALLED. HAVING A COMBINATION
OF AN UPFRONT ENERGY AUDIT AND
A BACK AN INSPECTION ARE MODEST
IMPROVEMENTS OR CHANGES THE%
PROGRAMS THAT WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE PAY FRAUD
IN THE PACE PROGRAM. AS BEFORE
SEVENTY SIX IS SUPPORTED BY A
WIDE COALITION OF CONSUMER
ADVOCATES BANKS AND OTHER
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS AND
HOUSING ADVOCATES AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD AS WE HAVE
CONTINUED TO MENACE MY OFFICE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS IN TRYING TO MAKE
THIS THE BEST DEAL POSSIBLE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DRIVER. IS
THERE ANY DID DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
MAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA. ATKINS I BASE. HI
BECKER. FIVE FOUR JUST.
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM I
CORTESE. I DALLY NO DODD I
YOU'RE AWESOME HI ADNAN I
GLAZER. HI CONSOLIDATES I GROW
HI HURTS BERG. I WAS SO HIGH
HER TADO I. I LAYERED I LIVE IN
I LIVE MON. THE CHOIR.
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A CHOKE. PAN FIVE
FORTUNE TINO. RALPH I REVIEW. I
SKINNER. STERN HI NUMBER HI MY
COW SKI. WINNER I WILL. NO
INTERMENT MOVES A CALL BUT
YOU'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER ONE SIXTEEN SENATOR
BAKER IS PREPARED PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE OH THREE BY
SENATOR BACKER AND ACTUALLY
DEVOTING CENTER BECAUSE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THE MORNING
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS. SP
FIVE WITH THREE IS ALL ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY INCREASING
CORPORATE COMMUNICATIONS WITH
VOTERS BETTER DATA AND
CODIFYING WHAT WE KNOW WORKS
FROM THE NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION. CALIFORNIA'S LIKE TO
VOTE FOR HOME FROM HOME WE'VE
SEEN INCREASING PERCENTAGES.
BUT PRIOR TO THE NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION THERE
WERE NO CLEAR STATEWIDE
STANDARDS FOR EVALUATING
SIGNATURES. WHEN YOU'RE GO
STANFORD LAW STUDENTS
IDENTIFIED SIGNATURE
DISPARITIES FROM COUNTY TO
COUNTY IN FACT THE NUMBER
PROJECTED MAIL IN BALLOTS
SURPASSED ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND.
IN THE MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
PRIMARY ALONE. SB FIVE A THREE
IN SHORT THE COUNTIES ACROSS
THE STATE ARE USING THE SAME
UNIFORM PRACTICES FOR SIGNATURE
SUSSMAN. AND REPORTING
REJECTIONS. JOHN SIGNATURES
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT THE
MOST FORMAL CALIFORNIANS THOSE
WITH LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY DISABILITIES FIRST
TIME AGING VOTERS AND VOTERS OF
COLOR. THIS ACT ALSO INCREASES
COMMUNICATION BEYOND THE SIMPLE
LETTER TODAY ALLOWING EMAIL AND
PHONE CALLS TO VOTERS WHOSE
SIGNATURES ARE CHALLENGED. SP
FIVE A THREE GETS CONFERENCE TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS THAT ELBOWS
AREN'T ACCOUNTED COLLEGE
ESPECIALLY AFTER I VOTE. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA HI AT
KINS I BASE NO BECKER. HI
PORGES NO BRADFORD. OR I COME
BY ADAM HI CORTESE I DALLY NO
DODD HI YOU'RE AWESOME I A
GIVEN. I GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES
HI GROSS. HERTZBERG I WAS SO.
HI HER TADO I JONES. NO CAN
WATER I LAYERED I FLAVOR. HI
THE MON THE CHOIR FIVE
MELINDA'S NO MAN. I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. A SHOW OF BOTH. NO PAN
FIVE FORTUNE TINO. RALPH HI
RUBIO I SKINNER HI STERN I AM
BERG I LIKE HOW SKI FIVE WINNER.
WELL NOW. SENATOR BAKER MOVES
THE CALL. MEMBERS MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER ONE SEVENTEEN IS
SENATOR PAN IS READY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL FIVE TEN BY
SENATOR PAN AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE IN
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
SENATOR PAN YOU MAY PROCEED
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS SP FIVE TEN REQUIRES
HEALTH PLANS AND INSURERS TO
COVER TOBIN NINETEEN TESTING
AND VACCINATION WITHOUT COST
SHARING OR- OR RIOR
AUTHORIZATION. FROM BOTH THE
END NETWORK AND OUT OF NETWORK
PROVIDERS DURING THE FEDERAL
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. THESE
PROTECTIONS REMAIN FOR IN
NETWORK TESTING IN VACCINES
FOLLOWING THE PUBLIC FEDERAL
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. THIS
BILL ALSO PROHIBITS BALANCE
BILLING BY PROVIDERS FOR COVER
NINETEEN TESTING STATIONS EVEN
AFTER THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY EXPIRES. WE CAN
ALREADY TAKE LESSONS LEARNED
FROM THIS PANDEMIC PUT A
FRAMEWORK IN PLACE TO ALLOW
FEDERALLY APPROVED TESTING AND
IMMUNIZATIONS WITH NO COST
SHARING FOR FUTURE PANDEMICS
WELL WE HAVE MADE TREMENDOUS
PROGRESS AND WE ARE STILL
WORKING TOWARD THE MAJORITY
ACTUALLY BORN MAJORITY
POPULATION BEING VACCINATED-
THE GENERAL FOCUS PRIORITIES
ENSURING THAT EVERYONE CAN GET
A VACCINE. WE CANNOT LOSE SIGHT
OF ENSURING EVERYONE HAS ACCESS
TO COVERT NINETEEN TESTING
INDEX. NATIONS OUT OF OUT OF
POCKET COSTS. THAT'S WHY S. B.
FIVE TEN IS THE NOW THERE'S
NEED TO BE DIFFERENT NEEDS TO
BE CONSISTENT LAWS REGARDING
COVER NINETEEN TESTING ANY
MUSICIANS TO PROTECT CONSUMERS.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS CONSISTENT
APPROACH TO MY HEALTH PLAN
PARTERS STAKEHOLDERS AND
BENEFICIARIES TO STOCK UP AT
NINETEEN AND HAVE AN EXISTING
FRAMEWORK FOR FUTURE PANDEMICS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR KNIFE AT.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEAMAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA R. I. ATKINS I BASE
NO BACKER. I PORCHES HI
BRADFORD. I HAVE ITEM I CORTESE
HI SALLY. NO DODD HI TORONTO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES
HIGH GROWTH. HERTZBERG I WAS SO
HI HER TADO. I JONES NO CAN
LONGER. I LAYERED HI LLEVA BY
THE MON. MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S.
MAN HI FIVE NEWMAN. I NIELSEN.
NO A SHOW OF BOTH. NO TEN FIVE
FORTUNE TINO. RALPH HI RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN. HI I'M BERG I
BREAK OUT SKI I WINNER I WILL.
NO CENTER CAN MOVE THE CALL
EVEN UNDER ONE EIGHTEEN SENATOR
WIENER IS PREPARED PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETEEN BY
SENATOR WIENER AN ACT RELATING
TO CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES CENTER
WINNER THE FORAGERS. I THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT CALLERS
ARRIVED TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL FIVE NINETEEN- WHICH WOULD
DECRIMINALIZE THE POSSESSION
AND PERSONAL USE OF CERTAIN
PSYCHEDELIC SUBSTANCES TO
ENCOURAGE SAFER USE THIS BILL
ALSO DECRIMINALIZE DRUG TESTING
KITS AND PERMITS THE POSSESSION
OF PARAPHERNALIA TO USE THESE
SUBSTANCES ARE SAFE WAY. SP
FIVE NINETY WILL ALSO CONVENE
AN EXPERT WORKING GROUP UNDER
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THAT WILL DEVELOP
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT HOW
CALIFORNIA CAN REGULATE LEGAL
ACCESS TO THESE SUBSTANCES. IN
A MANNER THAT IS SAFE
RESPONSIBLE AND EQUITABLE. THIS
APPROACH MOVES US AWAY FROM THE
FAILED WAR ON DRUGS WHICH- WAS
BASED ON THE FLAWED. BADLY
FLAWED PREMISE THAT
CRIMINALIZING ARRESTING
PROSECUTORS PROSECUTING AND
IMPRISONING PEOPLE FOR USING
DRUGS WILL SOMEHOW DETER THEIR
USE AND WILL SOMEHOW IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY. THERE'S ANYTHING
WE'VE LEARNED FROM THE PAST
HALF CENTURY IS THAT THROWING
PEOPLE IN JAIL FOR USING DRUGS
DOESN'T STOP DRUG USE IT ON
THESE TOPIC DICTION. IT DOESN'T
STOP. ANY OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
ADDRESS WITH THE WAR ON DRUGS
IT HAS BEEN A COMPLETE FAILURE.
COGS IN BRINGING SENATE BILL
FIVE NINETY BEFORE YOU TODAY
BECAUSE WE NEED TO CHANGE OUR
APPROACH ON A RESPONSE TO
SUBSTANCE USE INSTEAD OF MAKING
IT WORSE. IN RECENTYEARS
VARIOUS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
DECRIMINALIZED THE POSSESSION
AND PERSONAL USE OF
PSYCHEDELICS INCLUDING SANTA
CRUZ IN OAKLAND. AS WELL AS
WASHINGTON DC AND SOMERVILLE
MASSACHUSETTS THIS PAST
NOVEMBER OREGON VOTERS PASSED
TO BELLINGER SERVICE ONE TO
DECRIMINALIZE PERSONAL USE OF
ALL SUBSTANCES. AND ANOTHER
FOCUSED ON- SIX PSILOCYBIN
ASSISTED THERAPY PROGRAMS.
OTHER COUNTRIES SUCH AS
PORTUGAL HAVE ALSO SUCCESSFULLY
MOVED IN THIS DIRECTION. THE
BUILDER FOR YOU TODAY. DOES NOT
PROPOSE TO DECRIMINALIZE ALL
SUBSTANCES IT FOCUSES ON
PSYCHEDELIC SUBSTANCES. AND
COLLEAGUES AS THOSE OF YOU WHO
AND I WANT TOTHANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO LOOK AT THIS
BILL. THERE IS GROWING AND
POWERFUL EVIDENCE THAT
PSYCHEDELIC DRUGS. ARE
EXTREMELY HELPFUL AND COULD
HELP SAVE PEOPLE'S LIVES WHO
ARE SUFFERING FROM MENTAL
HEALTH AND ADDICTION CHALLENGES.
VETERANS ARE PARENTS CONCERNED
ABOUT THEIR CHILDREN PEOPLE WHO
HAVE PTSD AFTER COMING BACK TO
THIS COUNTRY AFTER FIGHTING FOR
OUR COUNTRY. PEOPLE WHO ARE
ADDICTED TO HEROIN. WITH THESE
SUBSTANCES HAVE CHANGED THEIR
LIVES. HAVE BEEN ABLE TO HELP
THEM STOP USING DRUGS. VETERANS
SUFFERING FROM PTSD AND
DEPRESSION WHO'VE BEEN ABLE TO
TURN THEIR LIVES AROUND. AND
RIGHT NOW WE ARE FORCING THESE
COMBAT VETERANS WHO WENT TO
FIGHT FOR OUR COUNTRY WE'RE
FORCING THEM TO LEAVE THE
COUNTRY TO GET TREATMENT THAT
WILL TURN THEIR LIVES AROUND.
WE SHOULD NOT BE DOING THAT
IT'S SHAMEFUL. LET'S STOP
ARRESTING AND PROSECUTING
PEOPLE FOR POSSESSING AND USING
THESE DRUGS LET'S TAKE A
SCIENCE AND HEALTH BASICALLY
BASED APPROACH. INSTEAD OF A
CRIMINALIZATION APPROACH WHEN
IT COMES TO DRUG USE COLLEAGUES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPO.
SENATOR MELINDA THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN-
I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL AND I WILL TELL YOU AS A
VETERAN MYSELF AS SOMEONE
MARRIED TO A VETERAN AS SOMEONE
WHO'S HAD A PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
WITH A FAMILY MEMBER WHO IS
SUFFERING FROM PTSD I TAKE
ISSUE WITH THIS BILL BEING
PROPPED UP AS SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO HELP VETERANS THIS
BILL PROPOSES TO LEGALIZE A
NUMBER OF DRUGS ON THE AUTHOR
MENTIONS PSYCHEDELICS BUT ONE
IN PARTICULAR THERE'S A GREAT
CONCERN TO ME. IS CARRYING.
THIS BILL PROPOSES TO MAKE CAN
MEAN LEGAL FOR RECREATIONAL
PURPOSES CAN I MEAN AS A DATE
RAPE DRUG. I DON'T KNOW WHY IN
THE WORLD WE WOULD BE
CONTEMPLATING. LEGALIZING A
DRUG. LIKE CAN I MEAN USED TO
INCAPACITATE YOUNG WOMEN AND
GIRLS FOR THE PURPOSES OF
RAPING THEM. AND KEEP IN MIND
THAT 61% ROUGHLY. OF RAPES BY
AN ACQUAINTANCE PERHAPS SOMEONE
AT YOUR COLLEGE AT A PARTY THAT
YOU ATTENDED THAT YOU'VE SEEN A
FEW TIMES 61% OF THOSE TYPES OF
RAPES ARE NEVER REPORTED.
ROUGHLY HALF. OF THOSE DONE BY
A BOYFRIEND OR SOMETHING OF
THAT NATURE ARE NOT REPORTED SO.
SOMEONE MIGHT SUGGEST THAT.
THIS BILL ISN'T INTENDED TO
ALLOW ACTIVITY LIKE THAT AND
I'M SURE IT'S NOT. BUT FOR
EVERY ONE PERSON YOU MAY CATCH
USING THIS DRUG FOR THAT
SPECIFIC PURPOSE OF RAPING
SOMEONE FOR EVERYONE PERSON YOU
CATCH DOING THAT I GUARANTEE
YOU THERE'S AT LEAST TEN MORE
YOU WILL NEVER CATCH. BECAUSE
IT'S HARD. TO FIGURE OUT WHO
DID THAT TO NOW YOU GONNA TAKE
A BILL TO MAKE HAVING CANNOT
MEAN LEGAL FIGURED ANY COLLEGE
PARTY OR ANY BAR FOR THAT
MATTER. AND YOU HAVE IT IN YOUR
POCKET. NO ONE CAN DO ANYTHING
TO YOU THEY CAN ASK YOU WHAT
YOU INTEND TO DO IT HEN YOU
CAN SAY I KNOW I JUST. IT'S FOR
MYSELF AND THEN LATER ON. YOU
DROP IT IN SOMEONE'S DRINK. A
YOUNG WOMAN IS RAPED AND SHE
HAS NO IDEA WHO DID IT HAT
COULD BE YOUR DAUGHTER. OR YOUR
GRANDDAUGHTER. FOR YOUR NIECE
OR NEPHEW FRANKLY. I DON'T
DISPUTE. THAT CAN MEAN- HAS
POTENTIAL. THEY HAVE BEEN DOING
TRIALS BUT PLEASE REMEMBER.
THEY CAN I MEAN THAT IS BEING
USED TO TREAT VETERANS WITH
PTSD OR THOSE WITH DEPRESSION.
IS BEING DONE IN A CLINICAL
SETTING IT IS NOT RECREATIONAL
USE IT IS TYPICALLY GIVEN
EITHER THROUGH AN IV OR THROUGH
A NASAL MIST WHICH IS A
PRESCRIPTION. IT'S NOT A PELL.
AND IS DONE IN A VERY
CONTROLLED MEDICAL SETTING IN A
DOCTOR'S OFFICE AND IT IS
SHOWING POTENTIAL. THE FDA HAS
APPROVED IT WE STILL DON'T KNOW
IT COULD PROVE TO BE HELPFUL
BUT NOT IN THE WAY THAT THIS
PROBE THIS BILL PROPOSES FOR IT
TO BE YEARS SO I JUST WANT YOU
TO THINK ABOUT THE SAFETY. OF
THE YOUNG WOMEN AND GIRLS WHO
MAY FALL VICTIM TO SOMEONE WHO
TAKES ADVANTAGE OF A LOT LIKE
THIS BEING PASSED. IT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT YOU'RE AGAINST
HELPING PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUFFERING FROM DEPRESSION BUT I
THINK THERE'S A BETTER WAY WE
CAN CRAFT POLICY TO HELP PEOPLE
LIKE THIS WITHOUT ALSO
ENDANGERING. THE LIVES OF
UNSUSPECTING VICTIMS THANK YOU
AND I ASK FOR YOUR NUMBER.
SENATOR LEYVA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT OF WIND THE SENATOR
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO FIRST
ASKED ME ABOUT HIS- BILL I SAID
NO I SAID I DIDN'T THINK I
COULD SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
THEN AFTER READING AND
RESEARCHING AND MEETING WITH
THE VETERANS GROUPS THAT I MET
WITH- ONE IN PARTICULAR STANDS
OUT I MET WITH A COMBAT VETERAN
A NAVY SEAL AND AN ARMY RANGER
ALL OF THEM WHO SAW THINGS THAT
NONE OF US HAVE SEEN AND NONE
OF US PROBABLY NEED TO SEE. THE
THINGS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
LIVE THE LIVES THAT WE CHOOSE
TO LIVE AND I ASKED THEM I SAID
TELL ME WHY THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT TO YOU TELL E WHY
THIS IS HELPING YOU AND THEY
EXPLAINED TO ME THAT EVERYTHING
THAT THEY HAD TRIED BEFORE
EVERYTHING THAT THEY HAD BEEN
PRESCRIBED BEFORE SOME OF THEM
WERE TAKING THIRTEEN OF
FOURTEEN PRESCRIPTIVE DRUGS PER
DAY AND IT WASN'T HELPING THEY
TALK TO ME ABOUT MICRO DOSING
THEY TALKED TO ME ABOUT HOW
THEY USE THIS AND HOW IT'S BEEN
LIFE CHANGING FOR THEM AND
THEIR FAMILIES. THEY HAVE
STARTED OTHER GROUPS TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR VETERANS HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS FOR MEMBERS I
I'M A CREATURE OF HABIT
SOMETIMES I HEAR THINGS AND I
THINK OH NO THIS ISN'T THE WAY
WE'VE EVER DONE IT BEFORE BUT
WE KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING TO
HELP OUR VETERANS IS NOT
WORKING SO WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING AND TRY SOMETHING
DIFFERENT. AND I UNDERSTAND
WHERE THE SENATOR FROM ELSINORE
IS COMING FROM ANYONE WHO KNOWS
ME IN MY SEVEN YEARS THAT I'VE
BEEN HERE I HAVE DONE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK ON
WOMEN'S ISSUES SPECIFICALLY
AROUND RAPE AND YES CAN I MEAN
HAS BEEN USED AS A DATE RAPE
DRUG BUT I'M NOT SURE IF YOU'RE
AWARE THAT THE NUMBER ONE DATE
RAPE DRUG IS ALCOHOL SO UNTIL
WE FIND A WAY AROUND THAT I
THINK THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
THAT ISSUE AS WELL AND IF YOU
WANT TO TALK ABOUT RAPE I THINK
IT'S A DIFFERENT SUBJECT AND
TALKING ABOUT. HOW WE CAN FIX
THAT SITUATION BUT MEMBERS I
WOULD ASK YOU. TO THINK A
LITTLE BIT OUTSIDE YOUR COMFORT
ZONE. THINK ABOUT THESE. MEN
AND WOMEN WHO HAVE SERVED OUR
COUNTRY. AND THIS MIGHT BE A
SMALL STEP IN HELPING THEM TO
REGAIN THEIR LIVES AS THEY HAVE
FOUGHT TO MAKE SURE WE CAN LIVE
OUR LIVES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I HAVE A- SENATOR
BURGESS. I THINK
DECRIMINALIZATION LAW. IS TIED
TO THE RECORD SHOULD BE TIED TO
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF PERSONS
MOST KNOWLEDGEABLE IN THIS BILL
CURRENTLY PROPOSES THE CREATION
OF A TASK FORCE. I WOULD FEEL
FAR MORE COMFORTABLE EVALUATING
THE MERITS. OF POTENTIAL
DECRIMINALIZATION IF THERE WAS
A TASK FORCE THAT. I HAD
ALREADY BEEN FORMED IN PUT
FORWARD THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS.
SO I THINK THIS I SLIGHTLY YOU
KNOW THE CART BEFORE THE HORSE
SCENARIO AND I THINK BECAUSE OF
THAT WE WOULD BE BETTER SERVED
AS A MATTER OF POLICY AND
PROCEDURE. TO LISTEN TO FOLKS
PRIOR TO MAKING A DEAL
CRIMINALIZATION BILL. THE
SECOND ISSUE I THINK I HAVE
WITH THIS IS THE SOCIAL SHARING.
NOW WE'VE HEARD FROM- FROM
FOLKS WHO ARE KNOWLEDGEABLE ON.
HOW THIS COULD BE BENEFICIAL-
TO FOLKS OF SUFFERING FROM
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER.
BUT CAN'T THAT TYPE OF
TREATMENT BE ACHIEVED THROUGH
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE- A
PRESCRIPTION. BUY IN NOT THE
DECRIMINALIZATION OF THAT. BUT
THE IDEA OF SOCIAL SHARING GOES
AGAINST THAT NOTION THAT YOU
SHOULD BE SURGICAL IN TARGETED
TO THOSE MOST NEEDING AT THAT
SOCIAL SHARING COMPONENT TURNS
THIS INTO A RECREATIONAL
DECRIMINALIZATION. SO I THINK
FOR THOSE TWO REASONS- I WON'T
BE IN A POSITION TO SUPPORT
THIS AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
AUTHOR WHO. DOES GREAT HOMEWORK
ON HIS BILLS THAT MAYBE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS COME BACK
AFTER TASK FORCES CREATED SO WE
COULD HEAR WHAT THOSE
PROFESSIONALS ARE TRULY
RECOMMENDING RATHER THAN DOING
IT IN THE REVERSE. SENATOR
NEWMAN. THANK YOU MATCHER I'D
LIKE TO LINE MY SELF WITH MY
WITH THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CHINO YEAH I
RISE AS A PROUD THAT AND I
ASSUME SEEMINGLY UNLIKELY. CO
AUTHOR OF SP FIVE NINETEEN.
BASED UPON MY DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR AN EXAMINATION THE
MOST RECENT RESEARCH. AND ALSO
A CONSULTATION WITH BETTER NOW
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN PERSUADED
THAT THE PSYCHEDELIC THE
PSYCHEDELIC THERAPIES OFFER
POTENTIALLY BREAKTHROUGH
BENEFITS TO CALIFORNIA'S
VETERANS AND OTHERS SUFFERING
FROM POST TRAUMATIC STRESS.
PSYCHEDELIC THERAPY HAS
RECENTLY BEEN DEMONSTRATED TO
BE A PROMISING APPROACH FOR
MANY VETERANS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING WITH PERSISTENT
TREATMENT RESISTANT CHALLENGES
CAUSED BY BATTLEFIELD TRAUMA
AND LIFE CHANGING INJURIES.
CURRENTLY INDIVIDUALS SUFFERING
FROM POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS TEND
TO RESPOND POSITIVELY TO
CONVENTIONAL THERAPIES ONLY
ABOUT 50% OF THE TIME AT BEST
WHETHER THAT'S THROUGH
PSYCHOLOGICAL COUNSELING OR
MEDICATIONS. OR SOME
COMBINATION THEREOF HAVE IS OF
COURSE BETTER THAN NOTHING- BUT
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE WHO ADORE
TRAUMA. IN THEIR SERVICE TO OUR
NATION NEARLY HALF IS STILL
CLEARLY INSUFFICIENT. IN RECENT
YEARS VETERAN SUICIDE RATES
HAVE STEADILY RISEN AS THE
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS IN THIS
COUNTRY HAS CONTINUED TO WORSEN
AT THIS POINT MANY VETERANS OF
OUR MOST RECENT WARS. HAVE
ACTUALLY LOST MORE OF THEIR
FELLOW SERVICE MEMBERS TO
SUICIDE IN TWO DEPLOYMENTS WITH
FAIRLY CLEAR AT THIS POINT THE
CONVENTIONAL APPROACHES TO THE
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT OF OUR
VETS. ARE NOT SATISFACTORY AND
REQUIRES SOME LEVEL OF
INNOVATION CREATIVITY AND OPEN
MINDEDNESS I'M SUPPORTING SP
FIVE NINETEEN BECAUSE MANY OF
OUR NATION'S MOST ACCOMPLISHED
RESEARCHERS ARE ENCOURAGED AS A
RESULT OF EVIDENCE BASED
RESEARCH. BY THE POTENTIALLY
BENEFICIAL EFFECTS OF MDMA AND
OTHER PSYCHOTROPIC SUBSTANCES
WHEN COMBINED WITH STRUCTURED
THERAPY PROGRAMS TO ALLEVIATE
THE PAIN AND SUFFERING OF
MILITARY VETERANS AND OTHER
PEOPLE WHO ARE SUFFERING FROM
THE EFFECTS OF POST TRAUMATIC
STRESS. I'M ALSO SUPPORTING SP
FIVE NINETEEN BECAUSE THE BILL
OFFERS NEW HOPE TO OUR MILITARY
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEIR FRIENDS. AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO MANSION
UNFORTUNATELY AT THE MOMENT
ACCESS TO THESE PROMISING
EMERGING THERAPIES ARE
CURRENTLY ONLY LEGALLY
AVAILABLE OUTSIDE. THE UNITED
STATES THIS FORCES MILITARY
PTSD SUFFERERS SUFFERERS MANY
OF WHO HAVE TRIED FOR
EVERYTHING. AND FIND THEMSELVES
ON THE VERGE OF GETTING UP TO
LEAVE THE U. S. AND PAY FOR THE
COSTS OF TRAVEL AND LIVING
ABROAD. IN AN UNFAMILIAR FOLK
CULTURE SIMPLY TO RECEIVE AID
AND COMFORT THAT THEY TRULY
DESERVE. WIN CALIFORNIA'S WE'VE
CONSISTENTLY DONE MUST CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE LEADERSHIP AND
INNOVATION IN OUR APPROACH IS
PROVIDING EFFECTIVE REMEDIES
FOR THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
SACRIFICE THEIR SAFETY AND
THEIR WELL BEING. IN SERVICE TO
THE REST OF US I URGE YOU TO
JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING THIS
LEGISLATION. AS A VETERAN AND
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
VETERANS I RESPECTFULLY URGE- I
VOTE TODAY. SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
MUST RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL OUT OF PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
OF MANY DECADES AGO AND PERHAPS
SOME OF YOU WHERE WE'RE MAYBE
NOT EVEN ON THE PLANET YEAH BUT
I WAS A SOCIAL CASE WORKER IN
INTAKE SUPERVISOR IN THE
SIXTIES AND SEVENTIES AT THE
TIME THAT LSD BECAME OUT OF THE
GO TO DRUG FOR SOCIAL SHARING I
THINK YOU MIGHT REMEMBER THE
NAME TIMOTHY LEARY WHO WAS
CONSIDERED THE GURU OF BEING
ABLE TO. TAKE THIS SPECIFIC
DRUG LSD AND FIND YOURSELF IN
ANOTHER WORLD OUT OF BODY
EXPERIENCES WELL MY CASELOAD AT
THAT TIME- CONTINUED THE NUMBER%
OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAD TRIED
TO- THAT EXPERIMENT THROUGH
SOCIAL SHARING I BRING FORWARD
AND IT WERE NOT ABLE TO RETURN
TO THEIR BODY OR FROM THAT
OTHER WORLD THAT THEY FOUND
THROUGH THAT JOB SO THEY BECAME
A- TOTALLY INCAPACITATED OF MY
CASELOAD WITH AID TO THE
DISABLED AT THAT TIME AND I HAD
A NUMBER OF THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO ARE PRACTICALLY MY AGE AT
THAT TIME- BASICALLY HAD. NO
FURTHER ON CAPACITY AND FOUND
THEMSELVES IN ASSISTED LIVING
OR WHAT WAS AVAILABLE FOR
PEOPLE IN THAT AGE AT THAT TIME
SO THE SOCIAL SHARING PART OF
THIS DRUG IS VERY VERY
CONCERNING AND I THINK WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
PSYCHEDELIC EXPERIENCES THAT
WILL GO ON AT PARTIES SOCIAL
SHARING R. AS COMPARED TO A
THERAPEUTIC USE FOR OUR
VETERANS THEY'RE QUITE
DIFFERENT AND SHOULDN'T I DON'T
BELIEVE BE CONTAINED IN A
MEASURE LIKE THIS. IF WE WANT
TO CONFINE IT. SPECIFY IT POURS
THROUGH. USE OUR BAD. ARE I TA
SUPPORT THAT BUT I DO BELIEVE
THAT THIS STEP SWAY OVER THAT
IN IN PROMOTING SOCIAL SHARING.
OF THESE VERY VERY
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTFUL DRUGS
AND YOU NEED ONLY GO TO THE
SCIENCE OF THAT IS AVAILABLE TO
SHOW WHAT. THE IMPACTS OF
PSYCHEDELIC DRUGS ARE FINE AND
CERTAINLY VERY YOUNG MINDS IN
OFF HOPEFULLY IN TERMS OF THOSE
WHO ARE. SUFFERING BOB PTSD IN
THOSE. PARTICULAR CONDITIONS
IT'S QUITE A DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCE ARE BASED ON FINANCE
SO IT NEEDS TO BE SEPARATED AND
I THINK MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
CART BEFORE THE HORSE HERE. WE
SHOULD HAVE THE RESULTS OF THE
TASK FORCE OF THE STUDIES ARE
DONE BEFORE WE TAKE THIS STEP
SO I URGE YOU KNOW VOTE.
SENATOR PENN. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- SENATORS- I CAN RISE
IN SUPPORT OF- THIS BILL HAS TO
BE FIVE NINETEEN AND- THIS BILL
WAS- HEARD AND- HEALTH
COMMITTEE- THESE ARE-
MEDICATIONS THAT ARE SHOWING
CONSIDERABLE PROMISE AND EVEN
MORE THAN PROMISE AND HELPING
TREAT- SIGNIFICANT. MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES INCLUDING- POST
MAX STRESS DISORDER AND
DEPRESSION- AND BECAUSE OF
CURRENT LAW WE ACTUALLY TELL
PEOPLE IF YOU ACTUALLY HAVE IT
ON YOU- YOU ARE BREAKING THE
LAW WHICH THEN FORCES PEOPLE
THEY HAVE TO LEAVE THE COUNTRY
IN ORDER TO GET TREATMENT- I
THINK OUR- SO. I THINK BOTH ARE
VETERANS OR ANYONE ELSE WHO
SUFFERS FROM PTSD AND DESERVES
BETTER AND SHOULD HAVE ACCESS
TO THESE MEDICATIONS- AND SO
WITH THAT HIGH- CAN I VOTE ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU. SENATOR
MELINDA'S. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I JUST HAVE A FEW
MORE- THINGS TO ADD M. A. N.
YOU KNOW TO SAY THAT A
PARTICULAR DRUG SHOWS PROMISE.
PROBABLY SOUNDS ENCOURAGING TOO
MANY. BUT IS IT GOOD POLICY TO
MAKE THE DRUG LEGAL FOR
RECREATIONAL PURPOSES ONE THAT
YOU HAVE DECIDED JUST SHOWS
PROMISE. IS THAT SAFE POLICY TO
PUT INTO PLACE. VETERANS RIGHT
NOW IF THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT. VETERANS RIGHT
NOW HAVE ACCESS TO CARE TO MEAN
THERAPY. WHAT THEY DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO IS OVER MEDICATING
THEMSELVES WHICH WE KNOW IS
COMMON IN THOSE WHO SUFFER FROM
DEPRESSION AND SEVERE PTSD THEY
WERE THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THEM
TO OVER MEDICATE. THEMSELVES
WITH A JOB LIKE THIS AND I
THINK THAT'S THE EXACT OPPOSITE
EFFECT THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
WE WANT THOSE WHO HAVE SEVERE
DEPRESSION. AND OTHER TRAUMA TO
BE ABLE TO GET BETTER WELL YOU
CAN'T GET BETTER IF YOU ARE
OVER MEDICATING YOURSELF. THIS
IS AGAIN A SIGN FROM THE POINT
THAT I MADE THAT YOU ARE
PUTTING YOUNG WOMEN AND YOUNG
GIRLS AT GREAT RISK. BY MAKING
A DRUG LIKE THIS. LEGAL FOR
RECREATIONAL PURPOSES NOT
THERAPEUTIC. PURPOSES
RECREATIONAL PURPOSES. SENATOR
KAMMERER. THANK YOU MADAM.
CHAIR I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE NINETEEN- AND JUST WANT TO
REMIND FOLKS THAT YOU KNOW
PSYCHEDELICS HAVE PLAYED A ROLE
IN SO MANY CULTURES SINCE PRE
HISTORY- THEY HELP THOSE WITH
MENTAL ILLNESSES WITH
DEPRESSION WITH ANXIETY WITH
PTSD- AND THEY'VE ALSO HELPED
HEALTHY PEOPLE TO. THEY OFFER
NOT ONLY THERAPEUTIC BUT
SPIRITUAL AND CREATIVE BENEFITS
AS WELL. AS THE AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL MENTIONED- THEY WERE.
CRIMINALIZED AND IN FACT USED-
AS A POLITICAL TOOL. IN FACT IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR AND NIXON
AIDE ADMITTED. THAT THE WAR ON
DRUGS WAS A POLITICAL TOOL
DESIGNED TO TARGET. BLACKS AND
THOSE PROTESTING THE VIETNAM
WAR. AND SAID THAT SINCE YOU
COULD NOT MAKE BEING BLACK OR
BEING A HIPPIE LEGAL. THEN YOU
COULD MAKE THE DRUGS THAT THEY
TOOK THE LEGAL. AS A RESULT THE
TRIALS THAT WERE GOING ON IN
THE FIFTIES AND THE SIXTIES
ACTUALLY STOPPED BECAUSE OF.
THIS MANUFACTURED WAR ON DRUGS.
I THINK THIS BILL IS ABOUT
PUBLIC HEALTH. RESEARCH
AGGRESSIVE RESEARCH HAS STARTED
BACK UP AGAIN. WHICH DOES SHOW.
THAT THERE IS PROMISE FOR
TREATMENT USING THESE DRUGS AND
AVALON AS WE HAVE SEEN JUST
WITH LAST YEAR I THINK MANY OF
US ARE MANY FOLKS MANY
AMERICANS ACTUALLY- PUTTHEIR
FAITH IN THE PROMISE. OF A
VACCINE. THAT IS MEDICATION.
THAT DID NOT GO THROUGH WHAT
THE NORMAL LONGER CHANNELS OF
RESEARCH AND TESTING WOULD
REQUIRE. BECAUSE THEY SHOWED
ENOUGH PROMISE TO ACCELERATE. I
JUST WANT TO ALSO ADD THAT YOU
KNOW. GREAT BUSY LEGAL NO
MATTER IF YOU ARE USING DRUGS
SOME KIND OF. SUBSTANCE OR
FORCE. AND THIS IS NOT ABOUT
DECRIMINALIZING ERRANT BEHAVIOR.
IT'S ABOUT DECRIMINALIZING THE
USE OF CERTAIN PSYCHEDELICS.
THAT HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO BE
USEFUL. FOR MANY FOLKS WHO NEED
THEM. AND THIS ALSO SHOULD NOT
BE ABOUT JUDGMENT OFTEN TIMES
WE WANT TO PLACE OUR OWN
PERSONAL JUDGMENT OR OUR OWN
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES. ON TO
OTHER FOLKS WITHOUT REALLY
UNDERSTANDING THEIR OWN MENTAL
HEALTH. THEIR MEDICAL NEEDS.
AND THEIR ABILITY TO HAVE
CONTROL OVER THEIR BODIES AND
THE MEDICAL DECISIONS THAT THEY
WANT TO BE ABLE TO MAKE AND I
WOULD HOPE THAT WE WOULD THINK
ABOUT THIS. IN THE SPACE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. RATHER THAN IN
THE SPACE OF CRIMINALIZATION
AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON SP
FIVE NINETEEN. SEEING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR WIENER YOU MAY
CONCLUDE- I AM I'M SORRY
SENATOR CHILEAN. HI PAULA THANK
YOU MADAM. SHE'S VERY THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. AND I HOPE
TODAY. BECAUSE WE JUST HAD
MEMORIAL DAY I AM A VETERAN I'M
A COMBAT VETERAN I'VE SERVED AS
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
COMMISSIONER OF MILITARY
VETERAN'S AFFAIRS FOR TWENTY
FOUR YEARS. YOU TELL ME WHO'S
DONE THAT. YOU TELL ME WHO SAT
DOWN WITH FAMILY AFTER FAMILY
AND VETERAN AFTER VETERAN AND
HELD THEM AND AS THEY CRIED.
SAID WHAT CAN I POSSIBLY DO
WITH MY SON HE'S DRINKING. HIS
BIGNESS WIFE HE'S DOING THIS
HE'S DOING THAT AND WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO PICK UP THE PHONE AND
GET. THE VETERANS
REPRESENTATIVE THE SOCIAL
WORKERS THE SOCIAL WORKERS WHO
WORK WITH THE VA TO SET UP THE
APPOINTMENT TO GET HIM INTO THE
VA SYSTEM AND ONCE THEY GOT
INTO THE VA SYSTEM ONCE THEY
WENT TO THE EAST LA VET CENTER.
WELL WE'VE HAD NOTHING BUT
SUCCESS THERE GOD BLESS THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND SO NOW I KNOW
ONE THING THAT. MY QUESTION IS
WHERE ARE THEY GOING TO GET
THIS L. AS THE DRUG THEY HAD TO
GET IN THE ALLEY ON A SATURDAY
NIGHT ARE THEY GOING TO GO DOWN
TO THE CORNER. COMPTON WATTS
WHERE ARE THEY GOING TO GET
THIS DRUG BUT WHEREVER THEY GET
IT I'LL BET YOU TWO DOLLARS TO
DONUTS THEY'RE GONNA BE GETTING
ADDITIONAL DRUG ADDITIONAL
DRUGS WHY BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING
TO BE SELF MEDICATING
THEMSELVES. THEY DON'T NO ONE
FROM THE OTHER THEY'RE GONNA
EXPERIMENT. L. S. D. IS NOT A
GOOD THING AND IF IT IS THEN
LET'S DO THE RESEARCH LET'S
FIND OUT LET'S LET THE VA DO
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO FIND
THE RESEARCH AND RIGHT NOW
THERE SHOULD BE A- BILL ABOUT
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS THIS
SHOULD BE ABOUT OUR VETERANS.
WHO SERVED I'VE GOT A SON WHO'S
GOT FIVE TOURS FIVE TOURS IN
COMBAT. HE'S BEEN THERE HE'S
SEEN IT I'M A PAIR TO PUT MY
OTHER SON'S BROKE THREE OF US
THREE PARATROOPERS IN THE SAME
FAMILY AND WE SIT DOWN WE TALK.
IN THERE AS HEALTHY AS YOU A
NINE. BECAUSE THEY MAINTAIN THE
MILITARY WAY IS MEETING WITH
THE SOCIAL WORKERS AND THE
ABILITY TO TALK TO THEIR
BODIES. SO THIS THIS THING
ABOUT SELF MEDICATION AND THIS
IS WHAT IT IS SO I'M ASKING
YOU. AND. AND I'M GOING TO HAVE
STAYING ON THIS BILL. IN I
THINK IT WE JUST WAIT. JUST
WHAT IS THE HURRY. LET'S WAIT
ON ON. ON TO SEE WHAT THE
RESEARCH WE ASKED ABOUT A TASK
FORCE DO WE HAVE ONE OR THEY'RE
MOVING ALONG. IF WE CAME BACK
NEXT YEAR AND SAID THIS IS THE
FINDING THIS IS THE DOOR. FINE
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THIS WE
CAN'T SPARE ONE SINGLE LIFE. AT
ALL. BECAUSE HE OVERDOSED. AND
SO I ASK YOU. TO BEAR WITH US.
END UP STAYING TODAY SO WE CAN
DO MORE RESEARCH. AND AS A
VETERAN I TELL YOU AND THERE'S
A VETERAN SITTING RIGHT OVER
THERE MAKE ONE HERE IN THIS ONE
THERE. WE'VE GOT THE VETERAN'S.
COMMITTEE MADE UP OF SEVEN
VETERANS FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
OUR HISTORY AND I'M THE CHAIR.
AND I TELL YOU WE'RE ALL
WORKING FOR THE SAME THING AND
IF I PERSONALLY FELT. THIS
WOULD HELP VETERANS ACROSS THE
BOARD I WOULD BE FORT. BUT IT
DOESN'T NOT JUST YET. SO LET'S
BE PATIENT AND- I'D LIKE YOU TO
ASK TO INDULGE ME IN. AND
GIVING US THE CHANCE. OF
STAYING ON THIS VOTE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. SENATOR DODD.
YES MA'AM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
WAS NOT PLANNING ON SPEAKING ON
THIS IN FACT I'VE MADE
STATEMENTS- IN PUBLIC THAT I
WAS NEVER GOING TO VOTE FOR
THIS BILL. HEY YOU KNOW. I HAD
A NUMBER OF PEOPLE COME TO ME
AND TRY AND LOOK AT IT'S NOT
ABOUT BEING. RIGHTEOUS IT'S NOT
ABOUT YOUR BEING RIGHT OR WRONG
IN IN TERMS OF AKING THIS
DECISION. THE WAY IT COMES DOWN
TO ME ATTHIS POINT IN TIME IS.
WE ARE LOSING PEOPLE. AT GREAT
RATES IN OUR COUNTRY THAT HAVE
GONE OVERSEAS TO FIGHT. ON OUR
BEHALF INDIA WE'VE ALSO LOST-
YOU'LL TALK TRIBE I TALKED TO A
NUMBER SERVICE PEOPLE THAT HAD
TO LEAVE THE COUNTRY TO GO TO
PERU TO GO TO MEXICO TO GO TO
EUROPE TO GO TO OTHER PLACES
SPEND MORE MONEY TO BE ABLE TO
DO THIS TO FACILITATE IT. I'VE
ALSO HAD PARENTS THAT HAVE
CALLED ME AND SAID THEIR KIDS.
WERE A LOST CAUSE. ON HEROIN
IT'S CETERA CETERA. THANK GOD
ON THIS DRUG THERAPY. WITH THE
RIGHT PEOPLE NOW THEY'RE
LOOKING THERE'S NO GUARANTEE
ONCE IS BELIEVES THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTROL EVERY SINGLE
SINGLE SITUATION CERTAINLY
WE'RE NOT CONTROLLING EVERY X.
SITUATION TODAY AND WE'RE
LOSING KIDS TO THE WAR ON DRUGS
STILL. WE'RE LOSING OUR
VETERANS ARE TAKING THEIR OWN
LIVES SO FOR ME. IT'S A MATTER
OF- I JUST YEAH I'D LIKE TO DO
NO HARM. BUT AT THE BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY I THINK WE SAVE
WAY MORE LIVES IN WE HELP MORE
FAMILIES. HE MOVED FORWARD TO
TWO TOGETHER IN THESE VETERANS
IT I'M GONNA SUPPORT THIS BILL
I'VE HAD NUMEROUS PEOPLE IN
TERMS OF- YOU KNOW CONTACTED ME
REACHING OUT I WAS FRANKLY
BLOWN AWAY. ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT THIS IS REALLY
HELPED OUR COUNTRY SO WITH THAT
I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. SAYING
NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ALL THIS TIME SENATOR- YOU MAKE
INCLUDE. I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT BECAUSE I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR THE FOR THE
PASSIONATE ANDTHOUGHTFUL
DISCUSSION. ABOUT THIS- BILL
THESE ARE HARD ISSUES. DRUGS
MENTAL HEALTH ADDICTION ARE
HARD ISSUES AND THESE ARE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE FRANKLY NOT
GRAPPLE WITH AS A SOCIETY AND
WE HAVE TRIED SUPERFICIAL
POLITICALLY EXPEDIENT SOLUTIONS
I HAVEN'T WORKED ON I WANT TO
THANK THE SERVER NOT PREFER
RAISING PEOPLE WHO AREN'T
VETERANS WE HAVE AN AMAZING
COALITION OF VETERANS. WHO
PEOPLE WHOSE LIVES HAVE BEEN
SAID TO HAVE BEEN YOU KNOW
WORKING THEIR BEHINDS OFF TO
MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THERE'S ALSO A LOT.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THAT
EARNS. SOME OF YOU HAVE CITIES
ALL LETTER THAT WAS SUBMITTED-
BY TWO PEOPLE BY THE NAME OF
DAVID AND GRACE. AND DAVID AND
GRACE TALKED ABOUT ABOUT TEN OR
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO. THEIR SON
THEY'RE TEENAGE SON BECAME
ADDICTED TO HEROIN. THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE RESOURCES THEY
TRIED. EVERY THING EVERYTHING.
THAT YOU COULD POSSIBLY TRY
EVERY TREATMENT EVERY
REHABILITATION EVERY PRINT
EVERYTHING. IT ALL FAILED AND
HE WAS SPIRALING TOWARDS
HOMELESSNESS AND DEATH THAT'S
WHERE HE WAS HEADED. THEY SENT
HIM BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO MEXICO TO AN IDLE
GAME PROGRAM WHICH IS A
PSYCHEDELIC COVERED BY THIS
BILL IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT CAN I
MEAN. DESPITE WHAT SOME THE
POLITICAL EXPEDIENCE OF
FOCUSING ON ONE DRUG TO AN IDLE
GAME PROGRAM IN MEXICO HE HAS
NOT USED HER ONE SENSE IT SAVED
HIS LIFE. SO FOR DAVID AND
GRACE OR FOR OTHER PARENTS OR
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO WANT TO SAVE
THEIR KIDS AND THEIR SISTERS
THEIR COUSINS LIFE. SHOULD WE
TELL THEM NO YOU CAN'T DO IT
UNTIL THE FDA GETS AROUND TO
RESCHEDULING THESE DRUGS THAT
MIGHT BE IN THREE YEARS OR FIVE
YEARS OR SEVEN YEARS JUST WAIT
UNTIL THE FDA TAKES ACTION.
VENUE CAN SAVE HIS LIFE WAIT
FOR THE TASK FORCE TO MEET.
ONCE THE TASK FORCE COMES BACK
THEN YOU CAN SAVE HIS LIFE I
HOPE HE DOESN'T DIE BEFORE THEN.
PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING NOW. NOT
IN THREE OR FIVE YEARS THEY'RE
SUFFERING RIGHT NOW PEOPLE ARE
DYING NOW THEY ARE IN CRISIS
RIGHT NOW I KOBE HAS MADE UP
AWFUL SITUATION EVEN WORSE.
PEOPLE ARE SELF MEDICATING NOW
WE NEED TO STOP PRETENDING THAT
CRIMINALIZING DRUGS AND
ARRESTING PEOPLE SOMEHOW STOPS
PEOPLE FROM USING DRUGS BUT IF
YOU ONLY MAKE IT A CRIME TO
HAVE THE DRUG. OR SO IT'S GOING
TO DO WHAT YOU SAY AND STOP
USING HOW DOES THAT WORK FOR
THE LAST FIFTY YEARS WELL WE
HAVE INCARCERATED ON ENDING
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE FOR
POSSESSING A LOW LEVEL DRUG
OFFENSES PUTTING THEM AWAY FOR
YEARS OR DECADES. NONVIOLENT
DRUG OFFENDERS SO THAT WE CAN
GET THEM TO STOP USING HAS THAT
STOPPED ON. NOT AT ALL IT'S
WORSE NOW BEFORE IN TERMS OF
DRUG USE THERE'S MORE DRUGS
BEING USED NOW. IT HAS FAILED
TO SURPRISE OVER SAYING THIS
BILL IS NOT TO STOP ARRESTING
PEOPLE. LET'S JUST STOP
ARRESTING PEOPLE YES WE WANT
THE FDA TO GET AROUND TO DOING
WHAT IT NEEDS TO DO. BUT WE
DON'T KNOW WHEN THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN LET'S SEE WHAT WE CAN
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. TO REMOVE
THESE BARRIERS TO PEOPLE
GETTING THE HELP. THAT THEY
NEED COLLEAGUES I AM SO
GRATEFUL FOR THE CONVERSATION
TODAY AND I RESPECT PLAYERS
FROM RIVAL. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA. ATKINS I BASE NO
BECKER HI FORTUS NO BRADFORD I
HAVE BIO I COURTESY HI DALLY NO
DODD HI TORONTO I EGGMAN I
GLAZER NO GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG. WITH SO. HER TADO.
NO JONES NO CAMEL OWNER I
LAYERED I LLEVA I THE MON.
REQUIRE FIVE MELINDA'S NO MAN
NO NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A SHOW
OF BOTH. NO PAN HI PERSON TO
KNOW. ROSS FIVE RUBIO. NO
SKINNER I STERN. NUMBER NO
WHITE HOUSE SKI. WINNER I WILL
NO NO PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. ARCHULETA NO.
HERTZBERG. WEST SO I. LIVE MON.
FORTUNE TINO NO. STERN BY CAL
SKI HI. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. HERTZBERG LIMONIUM
STERN. FIVE TWENTY ONE NO
SIXTEEN THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO
ITEM NUMBER ONE HUNDRED SENATOR
RUBIO PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
THREE TEN BY SENATOR RUBIO AND
ACTUALLY DO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
SENATOR RUBIO THE FLOOR'S YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE TODAY'S ARE RAISED TO
PRESENT SP THREE TEN A CRITICAL
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT WILL
HELP SAVE LIVES OF CANCER
PATIENTS ACROSS OUR STATE. THIS
BILL CREATES A VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM THAT WILL ALLOW CANCER
PATIENTS TO DONATE I NEED THIS
MEDICATION TO PATIENTS IN NEED
THROUGH A CERTIFIED PHYSICIAN.
TRAGICALLY RECENT STUDY SHOWS
ABOUT THIRTY FOUR MILLION
PEOPLE HAVE REPORTED KNOWING AT
LEAST ONE FRIEND OR FAMILY
MEMBER IN THE PAST FIVE YEARS
WHO DIED AFTER NOT RECEIVING
THE PROPER CARE. AND MUCH
NEEDED- MEDICATIONS SENATORS.
TIONS HAVE DIED BECAUSE THEY
CANNOT AFFORD THE COUNTER
MEDICATION WE CANNOT MAKE
ACCESS ONLY FOR THE WEALTHY. AT
LEAST FOURTEEN OTHER STATES
ALREADY HAVE SIMILAR PROGRAMS
AND IT'S TIME THAT CALIFORNIA
CATCH UP I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR IF YOU COULD SO THAT WE
CAN HEAR. APPARENTLY THE
PRESENTER IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE AT THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
SINGMAN EYES FORTY NO ZERO
ASURE IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
ONE TWENTY SENDER LEMOND ARE
YOU PREPARED SHE IS PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY FIVE BY
SENATOR LEE MOANS AND ACTUALLY
INTO HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
SYNERGY MOON YOU MAY PROCEED
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES SP FIVE THREE FIVE
ELIMINATES PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
AND STREAMLINED THE BIOMARKER
TESTING PROCESS BY PROHIBITING
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION FOR.
FILEMAKER TESTING IN PATIENTS
WITH ADVANCED OR METASTATIC
STAGE THREE AND FOUR CANCER
THIS BILL WILL BENEFIT- THE
HEALTH PLANS HEALTH INSURERS
AND MEDICARE RECIPIENTS. SP
FIVE THREE FIVE AIMS TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO CARE AND OVERALL
REDUCES HEALTH CARE COSTS FROM
FEWER OUTPATIENT DOCTOR VISITS
HOSPITALIZATION AND HOPICE
CARE BUT STILL HAS RECEIVED
COMMITTEE. HAS RECEIVED A
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
COMMITTEES AND- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN ISLAND. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NONE ICE FORTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER ONE TWENTY THREE
SENATOR HERTZBERG HE IS READY.
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FIVE
FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
AN ACT RELATING TO WATER
SENATOR HERTZBERG THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATOR SHOULD KNOW.
WE'RE LIVING IN EXTRAORDINARILY
DIFFICULT TIMES WE- FIVE
USUALLY FACING ALL THE
DIMENSIONS OF THIS PANDEMIC
LAST YEAR FOUR MILLION ACRES OF.
CALIFORNIA BURNED AND WHO IN
THE MIDST OF A DROUGHT. TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE TO TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN IT'S ESTIMATED TO BE
THE DRIEST FOUR YEAR PERIOD. IN
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS WE
AS POLICYMAKERS NEED TO AND PUT
OUR BRANS TO THIS AND OFFER
SOLUTIONS TO AFFECT PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA IN A POSITIVE WAY IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. YOU KNOW SO
MANY FOLKS IN SMALL WATER
DISTRICTS ARE HAVING BOTTLED
WATER DELIVERED TO THEIR
IMPACTED HOUSEHOLDS 75% OF THE
DROUGHT IMPACTED PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEMS ARE THESE SMALL SYSTEMS
WHERE THE FAMILIES ARE SO
RESTRICTED IN TERMS OF WATER
WE'VE SEEN THE HORROR STORIES
AND IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE.
SENATORS THAT IS CALIFORNIA.
THIS MEASURE AND- SAYS THAT FOR
DISTRICTS THE SMALL DISTRICTS
BETWEENFIFTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND NINE OR NINE AND
CONNECTIONS HAVE TO PUT
TOGETHER A- ACTIONPLAN A- ARM.
A PROCESS WHEREBY THEY CAN
PREPARE FOR EMERGENCIES IS ONE
OF THE ELEMENTS THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT WHEN WE DID A BILL A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO ON DROUGHTS
AND IS NECESSARY AS WE- MOVE
FORWARD I ASKED FOR YOUR- VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
I ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I BASE I
BACKER. I FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD. OKAY I HAVE A I WHAT
HAS HE- FIVE DALLY I DON HI
THERE ASA I EGGMAN I GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ I GROWTH HI HERTZBERG
I WAS SO. HI HER TADO I JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA HI
THE MON I REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S
FIVE MEN FIVE NEWMAN I NELSON.
I SHOW BOTH I PAN FIVE FORTUNE
TINO. HI RALPH HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER I STERN I AM BERG RIGHT
I Y. CAO SKI FIVE WINNER. WELL
HI. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. WINNER. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME. WINNER. I HIGHS FORTY NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON TO ITEM ONE TWENTY FIVE
SENATOR RUBIO ARE YOU PREPARED.
PASS ON FILE SENATOR PARDON
TINO ITEM NUMBER ONE TWENTY SIX.
HE IS PREPARED PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE SIXTY TWO BY
SENATOR PART INTO YOU KNOW AN
ACT RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE CENTER PRINTING OF THE
FOR TWO YEARS. THANK YOU- MADAM
PRESIDENT AND- MEMBERS. SP FIVE
SIXTY TO. ELIMINATE SIGNIFICANT
ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS IMPOSED BY
HEALTH PLANS THAT ARE
PREVENTING FAMILIES FROM
ACCESSING BEHAVIOR HEALTH
TREATMENT FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH
AUTISM. RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
CHILDREN WITH AUTISM WHO
RECEIVED BEHAVIOR HEALTH
TREATMENT EARLY CAN SHOW
REMARKABLE PROGRESS THIS BILL
ALSO CODIFIES REQUIREMENTS FOR
QUALIFIED AUTISM SERVICE
PROFESSIONAL IN PARA
PROFESSIONAL. TO ENSURE HEALTH
INSURANCE COVERAGE STATISTICS
TELL US THAT ONE IN FIFTY NINE
CHILDREN MORE TODAY ARE
DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM. EARLY
INTERVENTION IS THE KEY TO
HELPING THEM LIVE UP TO THEIR
COMPLETE POTENTIAL AND WE NEED
TO DO THAT AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I VOTE TO HELP THEM
GET THE CARE THEY NEED. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SAYING MAN THIS BILL IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
SAYING NON ICE FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. WHERE TO
MOVE ON TO ITEM ONE THIRTY ONE
SENATOR BRADFORD IS READY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SIX OH
THREE BY SENATOR BRADFORD AN
ACT RELATING TO CANNABIS CENTER
READ FOR THE FOUR YEARS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THIS IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE FOUR
YEARS AGO I PASSED THAT'S P.
TWELVE NINETY FOUR THAT THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED THAT WAS FIRST.
SOCIAL EQUITY CANNABIS BILL IN
THIS NATION. AND DURING THAT
SINCE THAT TIME WE HAVE SPENT
FIFTY FIVE MILLION ENCOURAGING
MINORITY OWNED WOMEN OWNED A
DISABLED VETERANS TO ENTER THE
SPACE UNFORTUNATELY WE SPENT
MORE ON ENFORCEMENT IN ONE
YEAR. THAN WE'VE DONE IN THE
THREE YEARS- REGARDING THE
SOCIAL EQUITY PROGRAM FIFTY
FIVE MILLION IS JUST A DROP IN
THE BUCKET ON WHAT'S REALLY
NEEDED WHAT THIS MEASURE DOES
PROVIDE A FEE WAIVER AND- FOR-
AND A TAX CREDIT. FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ONE ENTER THE SPACE
MANY INDIVIDUALS HAVE TO FIRST
SECURE LOCATION BEFORE THEY CAN
EVEN APPLY FOR A LICENSE AND
THAT CAN COST HIM TENS IF NOT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS. THIS ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS TO HAVE A FEE
WAIVER THE SPONSOR THE MEASURE
FIVE NINE FIVE THAT WAS PASSED.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND IT
ALLOWS THOSE INDIVIDUALS AGAIN
TO ENTER THIS BUSINESS AND JUMP
START. THEIR CAREER. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR BAIT OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SIX NINE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WITH ALAN
I ARCHULETA I ACTIONS I FACE.
BACKER I FOR JUST. BRADFORD
FIVE CABRERA I COURTESY I DALLY
NO DON. HI TORONTO BY ADMIN
FIVE GLAZER I CONSOLIDATES HIGH
GROWTH. HI HURTS BERG. I WAS SO.
HI HER TADO I JONES. CAN LONGER.
I LAYERED I LABOR I THE MON I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON. BUT SHOW BOTH.
PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO HI ROTH
HI RUBIO I SKINNER HI STERN HI
AMBERG. I LIKE HOW SKI HI
WINNER I WILL. HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BABIES
BARGES. JONES MELINDA'S.
NIELSEN. A SHOW A BUG HI. PRICE
THIRTY FOUR NOS ONE THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO GO
BACK TO ITEM ONE TWENTY NINE.
WHICH IS- SENATOR NEWMAN- THAT
IT IF YOU GIVE US A SECOND
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FIVE
EIGHTY THREE BY SENATOR NEWMAN
AN ACT RELATING TO ELECTIONS.
MATTER ORGANISERS SANDERS SAID
I RISE TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
ON SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTY
THREE WHICH WOULD IMPLEMENT A
BACKEND AUTOMATIC VOTER
REGISTRATION SYSTEM SIMILAR TO
THE SYSTEMS BEING USED IN
COLORADO OREGON AND NEVADA THIS
PROPOSED REGISTRATION SYSTEM.
WOULD STREAMLINE AND IMPROVE
OUR CURRENT MOTOR VOTER SYSTEM
AND REGISTER MORE PEOPLE TO
VOTE INCLUDING OUR HARDEST TO
REACH POPULATIONS IT WILL ALSO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S VOTER
ROLLS ARE AS ACCURATE AS
POSSIBLE YOU PROVIDE INCREASED
PROTECTIONS FOR NON CITIZENS.
WE HAVE IN CASE THE DMV IN THE
CALIFORNIA. RECENT MEMBERS
REFLECT THEIR FEEDBACK ABOUT
BEST APPROACHES TO
IMPLEMENTATION SPECIFICALLY WE
HAVE AGREED TO EXTEND THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE TO TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE IN OF CLARIFIED
THAT THE DMV WOULD NOT BE
REQUIRED TO ESTABLISH A REAL
TIME CONNECTION TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S VOTER
DATABASE TO OPERATIONALIZE THIS
BILL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
I'LL VOTE TODAY. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SENATOR BRADFORD. IS YOUR
MY CUP. YOU OKAY. HEY IF ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SIX SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I BASICS.
BECKER HI FORGES. BRADFORD. I
HAVE ITEM HI CORTESE HI DALLY.
NO DODD FIVE THERE ARE SO BY
ADMIN I GLAZER. HI CONSOL IS
HIGH GROWTH. HERTZBERG I WAS SO.
HI HER TADO. I JONES NO CAN
LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA FIVE
THE MOON. I REQUIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH. NO
PAN HI FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH I
REVIEW. HI SKINNER I STERN. HI
AMBERG I WAKE COUNTY FIVE
WINNER I WILL NO. FOR JUST NOW
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BASICS NO GROVE. NOW. FIVE
THIRTY ONE. KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM ONE
THIRTY THREE SENATOR ROCK IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SIX OH SEVEN BY SENATOR
ROTH AN ACT RELATING TO
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS IN
AMERICA MAKING APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE CENTER OFF THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES THIS IS
PART OF OUR- SUNSET REVIEW
PROCESS SENATE BILL SIX OH
SEVEN SIX ZERO SEVEN IS A-
SUNSET BILL JUNIOR IF YOU WILL.
THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
CODE OMNIBUS BILL IT CONTAINS
SEVERAL CHANGES TO A NUMBER OF
PRACTICE SEX ADMINISTERED BY
VARIOUS PROGRAMS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
THE CHANGES CONTAINED IN THIS
BILL STEM FROM PRIOR SUNSET
REVIEW OVERSIGHT DISCUSSIONS.
CONSIDERED NON CONTROVERSIAL
SUBSTANTIVE CODE CLEANUP
RESPECTFULLY AS FEAR OF A- IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
AT KINS I BASICS. BECKER I
PORCHES. BRADFORD I HAVE A
HYPERTENSIVE I DALLY. DOT FIVE
DURAZO HI ADNAN I GLAZER. I
CONSOLIDATE BY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
I JONES. I CAN LONGER I LAYERED
I LATER. HI THE MON I REQUIRE.
I MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON. I A SHOW OF BOTH HI PAM
I PERSON TINO. HI RALPH. HI
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN I AM
BERG ALL RIGHT I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BASE FOR JUST.
DALLY. GROVE I. MELINDA'S WILKE.
I THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. YOU'RE MOVING
ON TO ONE ITEM ONE THIRTY FOUR
SENATOR PORTENT TINO PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SIX TWELVE BY
SENATOR FORTUNE TINO AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTRICITY. C.
SENATOR THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SO I'M
PRESENTING SP SIX TWELVE WITHIN
WHICH ENSURES FAIR AND EQUAL
ACCESS TO THE BENEFITS OF
LEGACY CONTRACT RESOURCES FOR
ALL CUSTOMERS AND ENSURES THAT
I- USED PORTFOLIOS ARE MANAGED
TO MAXIMIZE VALUE AND REDUCE
UNNECESSARY COSTS FOR ALL
CUSTOMERS. MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S
ELECTRICITY POLICIES WERE
ADOPTED YEARS AGO WHEN INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES WERE THE
PREDOMINANT PROVIDER OF ENERGY
AND DO NOT REFLECT CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT LANDSCAPE NO LONGER DO
THE BULK OF CALIFORNIANS
RECEIVE POWER FROM THE BIG
THREE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
PG&E SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
AND SAN DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC.
IN FACT OVER THE LAST DECADE
MORE THAN ELEVEN MILLION PEOPLE
IN MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED CITIES
AND COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE AND HAVE TRANSITIONED TO
COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATION OR
C. C. A.'S. C. C. H. NOW OCCUPY
ONE THIRD OF THE ORIGINAL I OWE
YOU FOOT PRINT AND FIFTY
PERCENT. A P. GENIES ORIGINAL
SERVICE TERROR TERRITORY ALONE
AND THE NUMBER IS EXPECTED TO
GROW. COMBINE THE CCA
TRANSITION WITH THE EXPANSION
OF DIRECT ACCESS AND WE HAVE A
VERY IFFERENT LANDSCAPE. SO
THIS BILL SEEKS TO. RE EQUITY
AND FAIRNESS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I BOTH. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEAMAN PLEASE CALL THE
REAL ROLE. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I FACE. BECKER I PORCHES
NO BRADFORD I HAVE A HI
COURTESY FIVE DALLY. DODD FIVE
THERE ARE SO I ADMIN I. LASER
I. GONZALEZ HI GROVE NO
HERTZBERG. HI WITH SO HI HER
TADO. JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA I LIVE ALONE I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN. HI NIELSEN BY A SHOW OF
OAK. NO PAN HI PERSON TINO I.
ROSS. HI RUBIO. I SKINNER. HI
STERN I AM BERG I CAN'T SPEAK.
WHITE HOUSE GAME FIVE WINNER
FIVE WELL HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES NO. DALLY
HER TADO. MELINDA'S HI. PLEASE
CALL THE ABDUCTED MEMBERS ARE
MORE TIME. DALLY I. HER TADO.
FIVE THIRTY FOUR KNOWS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM ONE
THIRTY FIVE SENATORS. I'M
SORRY- SENATOR NIELSEN YES SIR
I WANTED TO SWITCH FROM I LIKE
TO KNOW. YOU EVEN OUT VOCAL IS
THERE ANY IS. LEAVE IT THIS IS
ON THE LAST VOTE SENATOR NELSON
YES. IT WE'LL PUT IT BACK UP
AGAIN IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO.
TRANSACTION. TO ALLOWING THIS
CHANGE OF A VOTE. SEEING NO
OBJECTION. NIELSEN I DON'T KNOW
YEAH. VERY GOOD. I NEED THE
NUMBER. HIGHS THIRTY THREE NO
SIX SAT. A LOT OF. AT LEAST.
RIGHT THANK YOU.
OKAY. YEAH
YEAH. I DID YEAH. OKAY MEMBERS
ARE GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM ONE
THIRTY FIVE WHICH IS SENATOR
DIROCCO SHE IS PREPARED PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SIX THIRTY
NINE BY SENATOR ALSO AND
ACTUALLY TO IMPLEMENT CENTER
DRIVE SO THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR TODAY
PRESENT AS THREE SIX THIRTY
NINE. THIS IS A BILL THAT
ENSURES THAT WORKERS WITH
DISABILITIES CANNOT SHOULD NOT
BE PAID LESS THAN MINIMUM WAGE
SINCE THE NINETEEN THIRTIES THE
STATE HAS BEEN ABLE TO PAY
WORKERS WITH DISABILITIES LESS
THAN MINIMUM WAGE THROUGH THE
ISSUANCE OF FOURTEEN C.
CERTIFICATES UNDER THE FEDERAL
FAIR LABOR STANDARDS ACT. SO
EVEN AS CALIFORNIA PRIDES
ITSELF IN LEADING THE COUNTRY
WITH A FIFTEEN DOLLAR MINIMUM
WAGE AND WORKER PROTECTIONS
THERE ARE STILL THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH DISABILITIES
ARE STILL BEING EXPLOITED IN
SEGREGATED SETTINGS FOR AS LOW
AS TWO DOLLARS AN HOUR. S. B.
SIX THIRTY NINE PROHIBITS THE
ISSUANCE OF NEW FOURTEEN C.
CERTIFICATES BY JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND IT
DEVELOPS A PHASE OUT PLAN FOR
CURRENT EMPLOYERS TO ENSURE A
PATH TO COMPETITIVE AND
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT. BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THIS BILL
WOULD END THE PRACTICE OF
SEGREGATED SUB MINIMUM WAGE
EMPLOYMENT ENTIRELY. COLLEAGUES
THIS PRACTICE IS AN ARCHAIC
RELIC OF THE NINETEEN THIRTIES
AND THE DATES TO A TIME WHEN
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES WERE
DENIED AN EDUCATION. BEFORE
CIVIL RIGHTS LEGISLATION SUCH
AS THE AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITIES ACT RECOGNIZE THE
FULL HUMANITY OF PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES. IF AND WHEN AND
ACTED CALIFORNIA'S GONNA JOIN
OTHER STATES THAT HAVE ALREADY
PASSED THIS LEGISLATION ALASKA
CONNECTICUT MARYLAND NEW
HAMPSHIRE NEW YORK RHODE ISLAND
TEXAS AND WASHINGTON IN
PROHIBITING SUB MINIMUM WAGE
EMPLOYMENT OR SHELTERED
WORKSHOPS. THIS IS A MEASURE TO
OFFER DIGNITY TO WORKERS WITH
DISABILITIES AND IT PROVIDES A
PATH TO ECONOMIC INDEPENDENCE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR RIVAL.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. YES
SENATOR- WESSEL REPRESENTED
JUST CAUGHT THE LAST KING OF
MEMBERS URGE THEIR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL I CARRIED THIS BILL
HERE IN THE SENATE FLOOR. BACK
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THIS IS A
THIS IS A GOOD- HUMANE AND
THINGS TO DO WITH THAT WILL
GIVE THESE INDIVIDUALS THESE
WONDERFUL PEOPLE THAT ARE SOME
OF THEM WORK VERY HARD EVERY
DAY. THE DESERVE AT LEAST A
MINIMUM WAGE- THE RIGHT TO GET
ONE IN OUR STATE I DON'T WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE DESERVE A LAW
SAY THAT PEOPLE ARE HALF A
PERSON OR A QUARTER OF A PERSON
OR A- EVEN A SIXTEEN PER PERSON
SO- THIS IS A VERY HUMANE
WONDERFUL BILL MINORS PEOPLE TO
VOTE FOR IT. SEND GLACIER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS HI THIS BILL CERTAINLY
HAS GOOD INTENTIONS TO PREVENT
THE EXPLOITATION OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. BUT THERE ARE
SOME UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES-
THAT I WANTED TO RAISE. I'VE
BEEN HEARING FROM MY
CONSTITUENTS THAT THE BILL
WOULD PREVENT PEOPLE WITH THE
MOST SERIOUS DISABILITIES.
INCLUDING THOSE BORN WITH
SEVERE DOWN SYNDROME. CEREBRAL
PALSY AUTISM FROM EVEN GETTING
A JOB. THESE FOLKS ARE
CURRENTLY EMPLOYED BY WHAT ARE
KNOWN AS SHELTERED OR WORK
ACTIVITIES WORKSHOPS FOR THOSE
WITH SIGNIFICANT DISABILITIES.
THIS LEGISLATION AS THE AUTHOR
INDICATED WOULD ELIMINATE THIS
CATEGORY. IF THIS HAPPENS THE
COMPANIES THAT NOW EMPLOY THESE
PEOPLE WILL LIKELY HIRE PEOPLE
IN THE DISABLED COMMUNITY WHO
COULD DO THE JOB MORE QUICKLY.
OTHERWISE THEY'D BE PAYING
TWICE AS MUCH PER HOUR. SAVE
FIFTEEN DOLLARS RATHER THAN
SEVEN FIFTY. TWO PEOPLE WHO
MIGHT TAKE TWICE AS LONG TO DO
THE TASK. THAT'S NOT A
SUSTAINABLE MODEL FOR THEM. AND
IN THE LONG RUN IT COULD HARM
THE VERY PEOPLE THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO HELP. I WOULD
ENCOURAGE AND URGE THE AUTHOR
IS SHE MOVES THIS BILL FORWARD.
TO CONSIDER WAYS TO PROTECT THE
MOST VULNERABLE. IN THE
DISABLED COMMUNITY SO THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK THE INTENTIONS
OF THE BILL- ADMIRABLE BUT
THERE IS A CLASS. OF THOSE THAT
ARE DISABLED THAT REALLY CAN'T
BE HARMED. BY THIS LEGISLATION
THANK YOU. IS THERE. I HAVE
MORE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ON
THIS ITEM. AT CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND I
DO TEND TO AGREE WITH MY
COLLEGE IS CALLING IT JUST
BRIEFLY SPOKE I AM I DO KNOW
THE AUTHOR'S HEART AND THEN IT
IS IN THE RIGHT PLACE TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES ARE
MAKING MORE AT THE MINIMUM WAGE
FOR MORE AND THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT BUT THEREARE
INDIVIDUALS OUT THERE AT OUR
BAKERSFIELD ASSOCIATION ARE
BIGGER SO ARC EMPLOYEES PEOPLE-
IN THE SHELTERED WORKSHOPS. AND
SOME OF THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
MAKE MINIMUM WAGE- CAN BAG A
PRODUCT RIGHT YOU KNOW FIFTY TO
A HUNDRED PRODUCTS TODAY AND
THEN SOME INDIVIDUALS WITH IT
YOU KNOW SEVERE INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES- ONLY BACK MAYBE
THREE PRODUCTS A DAY WHEN THEY
DO THIS PROCESS BUT THE DIGNITY
OF BEING ABLE TO GO TO WORK
EVEN IF YOU'RE ONLY BAGGING
THREE PRODUCTS A DAY OR A SIT
ASSEMBLING THREE BAGS TO BE
DISTRIBUTED. WHEN I SAY BAGS OF
STUFF THAT GOES INTO THE PRISON
SYSTEM AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
COME FRESH- TOOTHPASTE SOAP.
THE INDIVIDUALS WITH THE SEVERE
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES ARE
GOING TO BE THE ONES THAT ARE
HURT. WHEN YOU GO TALK TO THESE
PEOPLE. IT'S NOT THE FACT THAT
THE BAG ONLY THREE THREE PUT
TOGETHER THREE PACKAGES A DAY.
IT'S THE FACT THAT THEY CARRY
THEIR LUNCH PAIL AD THEY'VE
GOT A JOB AND- THEY TAKE PRIDE
IN THAT JOB IT MAY TAKE THEM
SEVERAL HOURS TO PUT THOSE
SMALL PACKAGES TOGETHER- BUT I
JUST SEE THAT. WITH THIS BILL-
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU FIX IT
I MEAN I DON'T I DON'T EVEN
HAVE A SOLUTION I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU. GAUGE IT ON SOMEBODY'S
DISABILITY- THOSE ARE SEVERELY
IMPAIRED WOULD STILL BE ABLE TO
WORK IN THE SHELTERED WORKSHOPS
AND- AND BE PAID IN ORDER TO
HAVE THAT DIGNITY OF HAVING A
JOB WITH THOSE THAT ARE. YOU
KNOW MORE QUALIFIED OR OR LESS
DISABLED I'M NOT SURE HOW YOU
EVEN WORD IT. BECAUSE IT'S A
VERY TOUGH K- AREA TO WORK IN.
AND I SEE YOUR HEART ON THE
LEGISLATION AND THEY SHOULD BE
PAID MORE THAN YOU KNOW MINIMUM
WAGE- BUT- BUT I JUST DON'T SEE
EMPLOYERS. I DON'T SEE
EMPLOYERS OR INDIVIDUALS HIRING
INDIVIDUALS TO DO. A JOB THAT
WOULD TAKE SOMEONE ALL DAY TO
DO IT BECAUSE OF THEIR
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY. AND
THEN NOT HAVING THAT. THAT
PRIDE OF HAVING A JOB I HAVE A-
INDIVIDUAL SEVERELY DISABLED.
RUN DOWN SYNDROME SEVERELY DOWN
SYNDROME. YOUNG MAN HE'S TWENTY
THREE YEARS OLD AND HE CARRIES
HIS LUNCH BAG HIS BAIL HIS
LUNCH PAIL. LIKE HIS DAD EVERY
DAY TO WORK. AND HE'S ONE OF
THE LOWEST PERFORMERS IN THAT
DRIVE. BUT THE IDEA THAT HE HAS
A JOB AND HE GETS A LUNCH
BREAK. AND HE TALKS TO HIS
COLLEAGUES AND HE HAS A LIFE
OTHER THAN BEING AT HOME- I
THINK IT'S SIGNIFICANT FOR HIM.
BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT HE WOULD
BE SOMEBODY THAT WOULD LOSE HIS
JOB HIS NAME IS GARRETT. AND I
BELIEVE THAT HE WOULD BE
SOMEBODY THAT WOULD LOSE HIS
JOB BECAUSE THERE'S NO WAY THAT
SOMEBODY WOULD PAY MINIMUM WAGE
TO DO THE WORK PRODUCT THAT HE
DOES- AND I JUST THINK THAT
LIKE I SAID YOUR HEART IS RIGHT
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES.
BUT I HAVE A GRAVE CONCERN
ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHO WOULD LOSE
THEIR JOB AND THEIR DIGNITY.
BECAUSE. THEY COULDN'T FULFILL
THE OBLIGATIONS OF WITH A
MINIMUM WAGE EARNER WOULD-
BECAUSE- TO DO. SENATOR LEYVA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
JUST HAVE TO STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT I LOVE THIS BILL- WHEN
I WAS FIRST ELECTED I TOURED A
COUPLE FACILITIES IN MY
DISTRICT WITH A DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED FOLKS WHO WERE WORKING
AND WE'RE SO EXCITED AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD SAYS
THEY WERE SO EXCITED TO BE
WORKING AND BEING PRODUCTIVE
AND AS WE WERE WALKING THROUGH
A SATELLITE WILL HOW MUCH DO
THEY MAKE IT AND SOME ARE MADE
LIKE TWO DOLLARS SO MAYBE LIKE
THREE DOLLARS AND I SAID. DID I
HEAR YOU. AND I JUST THOUGHT
THAT THAT WAS APPALLING THESE
FOLKS WHO ARE COMING TO WORK
AND ARE EXCITED TO COME TO
WORK. THAT WE COULD BE ALLOWED
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THEM I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE COULD BE
SOME CONFLICT OR SOME. OTHER
PROBLEM BECAUSE MAYBE THEY
DON'T PRODUCE AS MUCH SOME
GROUPS OF PEOPLE. BUT YOU DON'T
LET'S NOT JUST SAY NO WHAT'S UP
WITH THE BABY OUT WITH THE BATH
WATER LET'S FIND A WAY TO MAKE
IT WORK MAYBE THERE'S A SUBSIDY
THAT CAN BE PUT IN FOR THAT
THAT PARTICULAR COMPANY. ALL
WORK HAS VALUE AND BECAUSE
YOU'RE A LITTLE SLOWER THAN
SOMEONE ELSE. I THINK IT'S
REALLY INSULTING TO SAY THAT
YOU DON'T EVEN DESERVE MINIMUM
WAGE I PERSONALLY THINK THAT WE
ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THESE
FOLKS. BECAUSE THEY ARE
MENTALLY DISABLED SO I STRONGLY
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT. AND
FOR THOSE WHO ARE WORRIED ABOUT
BUSINESSES BEING PUT OUT OF
BUSINESS OR WHATNOT I THINK
THAT'S A VERY SMALL FRACTION OF
THE PEOPLE THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. AND LET'S FIND A WAY TO
TAKE CARE OF THAT SO WE DON'T
CONTINUE DISADVANTAGING THESE
PEOPLE ARE SHOWING UP AND
WORKING HARD EVERY DAY AND
WE'RE ASKING IS THAT THEY MAKE
MINIMUM WAGE. SO I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING IT
FORWARD AND I STRESS AND STRONG
SUPPORT. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SINGMAN CENTER DRAWS SO
YOU MAY CONCLUDE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- AND I UNDERSTAND
SOME OF THE ISSUES HAD THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED AND THAT'S
BECAUSE FRANKLY AS A SOCIETY WE
STILL HAVE A TUNEL BARRIERS
BERRY IS A STILL EXIS FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
NOT LOOKING AT THEM WITH THE
FULL HUMANITY THAT THEY
REPRESENT AND THE FACT THAT
THEY LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE CAN BE
DIFFERENT FROM ONE ANOTHER JUST
LIKE WE'RE DIFFERENT FROM ONE
ANOTHER. THEY SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT TO LOOK FOR WHAT IT KIND
OF WHAT KIND OF CAREER THEY
WANT JUST LIKE WE DO. AND AND I
THINK THAT MORE AND MORE
BECAUSE OF OUR LAWS THAT WERE
PASSING CALIFORNIA HAS THIS
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT BLUEPRINT GOING IN
THAT DIRECTION- THERE ARE MORE
OF THESE ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE
PRIDE INDUSTRIES AND THE SAN
DIEGO GROUP OPTIONS FOR ALL
THAT HAVE ALREADY PHASED OUT
THERE SOME MINIMUM WAGE
PROGRAMS WE'RE GOING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION LET'S LET'S GO
EVEN FURTHER BY ALLOWING THESE
MEN AND WOMEN- TO. GET
MINIMALLY THE STATE MINIMUM
WAGE APPRECIATE AN URGENT I
BOTH THANK YOU. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. ARCHULETA R. I.
ATKINS FIVE BABIES. BACKER HI
FOR JUST. BRADFORD FIVE KOBE
ADAM HI CORTEZ V. FIVE DALLY.
DODD HI TORONTO BY ADMIN. HI
GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI GROSS.
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO HI- TADA I
JONES NO CAMELOT- I LAYERED. I
LABOUR I THE MON HI WHERE I.
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH. PAN
FIVE FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH HI
RUBIO. SKINNER. STERN HI AMBERG
HI BY CASKEY I WINNER I WILL.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN I. BASE PORGES. DALLY
GLAZER. GROVE MELINDA'S.
CONTROL OF BOTH. NO RUBIO.
SKINNER I WELK. PLEASE CALL THE
OB TO MEMBERS. BAYTEX FOR JUST.
DALLY GLAZER. GROVE MELINDA'S.
RUBIO I WELL. FIVE THIRTY ONE
KNOWS TOO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER ONE THIRTY SIX
SENATOR ARCHULETA ARE YOU
PREPARED HE IS PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX FORTY THREE BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA AN ACT
RELATING TO AIR POLLUTION
SENATOR TO LEAD IN THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL SIX FORTY
THREE. SENATE BILL SIX FORTY
THREE PASS THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD IN CONSULTATION
WITH THE ENERGY COMMISSION AND
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
TO PREPARE A STATEWIDE
ASSESSMENT OF THE FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLE FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FUEL
PRODUCTION NEEDED TO SUPPORT
THE ADOPTEES AT IT TO GIVE TO
SUPPORT ADOPTING A ZERO
EMISSION- TRUCK FOR TRUCKS
BUSES AND OFF ROAD VEHICLES.
HYDROGEN FUEL CELLS ARE AN
IDEAL ALTERNATIVE FUEL SOLUTION
TO ELECTRIFIED MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY COMMERCIAL VEHICLES AND
THESE VEHICLES ARE NECESSARY
COMPONENT TO ACHIEVING
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE AND AIR
QUALITY GOALS. HOWEVER THERE
EXISTED A KNOWLEDGE GAP
REGARDING THE HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS REQUIRED
FOR CALIFORNIA MEET ITS CARBON
NEUTRALITY GOALS THE STATE
AGENCIES LIKE ENERGY UTILITIES
AND THAT LEGISLATOR BLACK
SPECIFIC KNOWLEDGE OF THE
AMOUNT OF HYDROGEN FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HYDROGEN
FUEL PRODUCTION NEEDED TO MEET
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN AIR GOALS.
THIS BILL SENATE BILL SIX FORTY
THREE WILL HELP BRIDGE THE
KNOWLEDGE GAP AND ALLOW
CALIFORNIA TO ADEQUATELY PLAN
AND IMPLEMENT HYDROGEN FUEL
CELLS AS AN ALTERNATIVE ENERGY
SOURCE THE ASSESSMENT REQUIRED
BY THIS BILL WILL FOCUS ON
PRODUCTION AND DISTRIBUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE DISPENSING AND
DISTRIBUTION EQUIPMENT STORAGE
EQUIPMENT SUPPORTING HARDWARE
AND SOFTWARE. AND MOST
IMPORTANT AREAS OF
COLLABORATION ACROSS HYDROGEN
SECTOR FOR EXAMPLE THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN PRODUCTION
STORAGE AND DISTRIBUTION WITH
THE INFORMATION FROM THIS
ASSESSMENT CALIFORNIA WILL BE
ABLE TO MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS
ABOUT OUR CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED NO VOTES
NO NO VOTES AND BI PARTISAN
SUPPORT. AND FOR THESE. REASONS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
NINE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
HI ARCHULETA I ACTIONS BY BASE
I BACKER HI PORGES HI BRADFORD
I CAN BY ADAM HI CORTESE HI
DALLY. I DON FIVE DURAZO. FIVE
EGGMAN. GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES
HIGH GROWTH. HI HURTS BERG I
WAS SO. I- TANTO I JONES I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA HI
THE MON. HI MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN I WOULD SHOW UP BOTH HI
PAM. FIVE FORTUNE TINO I ROTH I
RUBIO HI SKINNER I STERN I AM
BERG I LIKE HOW. I WINNER I
WILL HI PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. EGGMAN I MELINDA'S.
FIVE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER ONE
THIRTY EIGHT SENATOR UMBERG HE
IS PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SIX SIXTY FIVE BY SENATOR
UMBERG AN ACT RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT CENTER UNDER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES- THERE'S
BEEN A FEW BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
PRESENT ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
THAT HAVE USED A SUPPORT FOR
VETERANS AS AT LEAST ONE OF ITS
RATIONALES THIS IS ALSO A BILL
THAT SUPPORTS VETERANS IT
DOESN'T A DIFFERENT WAY IT
SUPPORTS VETERANS. WITH THE
JOB. CALIFORNIA IS IN THE
VANGUARD. IN MANY YEARS IT'S IN
THE VANGUARD WITH RESPECT TO
THIS ISSUE AS WELL BECAUSE
FIFTY STATES. PROVIDE INSTANT
IN TERMS OF THE STATE
GOVERNMENT PROVIDE A PREFERENCE
FOR VETERANS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PROVIDES A HIRING
PREFERENCE FOR VETERANS THIRTY
NINE STATES PROVIDED HIRING
PREFERENCE FOR VETERANS IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR. CALIFORNIA DOES
NOT CALIFORNIA DOES NOT. MAYBE
RECEIVED A FLORAL ARTS
CONSIDERING THIS BILL AND ITS
DISPARATE IMPACT INDEED THERE
IS A DISPARATE IMPACT THERE'S A
DISPARATE IMPACT- MILITARY
HISTORICALLY HAS BEEN DOMINATED
BY MALES THAT'S CHANGING NOT
CHANGING QUICKLY ENOUGH WHEN I
JOINED IT WAS 8% FEMALE NOW IS
18% FEMALE WHEN I JOINED THE
WERE VIRTUALLY NO FEMALE
GENERALS THERE ARE EIGHTY ONE
FEMALE FEMALE GENERALS TODAY. I
KNOW I MARRIED ONE. THINGS ARE
CHANGING MILITARY WOULD
DISCRIMINATE ON THE BASIS OF
SEXUAL ORIENTATION FOR MANY
MANY YEARS THAT'S WRONG THIS
BILL WAS AMENDED AN
APPROPRIATIONS IS APPROPRIATELY
SO TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE WHO
WERE DISCHARGED BECAUSE THEIR
SEXUAL ORIENTATION. WOULD BE
CONSIDERED A VETERAN FOR
PURPOSES OF THIS BILL. THERE IS
A DISPARATE IMPACT. BECAUSE
THOSE WHO JOIN THE MILITARY ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFRICAN
AMERICANS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY LATINO
THEY'RE DISPROPORTIONATELY
POORER THAN MANY OF US. MANY
JOIN THE MILITARY AS I DID. IN
ORDER TO SEEK A COLLEGE
EDUCATION AND FOR THAT REASON
ALONE. AND SO THERE IS A
DISPARATE IMPACT- THE BILL
SIMPLY SAYS THAT THE PRIVATE
SECTOR CAN DO WITH THE
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T PROVIDE A
PREFERENCE FOR VETERANS IN
HIRING ORIGINAL VOTE. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM SENATOR OR CHILL THAT.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE IS THE CHAIR OF THE
MILITARY VETERANS COMMITTEE AND
I URGENTLY- ASK EVERYONE FOR
THEIR I WROTE. THIS BILL TAKES
BIG STEP FORWARD WE TALKED
ABOUT TODAY BODY KNOWLEDGE IN
SUPPORTING OUR VETERANS TO
PROTECTING THEM TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE EQUALLY TREATED
WHEN THEY COME HOME GIVEN EVERY
OPPORTUNITY. THIS IS THE FIRST
STEP IN A LONG ROAD FOR THEM TO
FEEL THAT THEY HAVE BEEN TRULY
WELCOME HOME AND I REALLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU.
CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT HAS UNITED STATES
MILITARY VETERAN I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND I
ALSO. WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR AND THE COMMON CITY MADE
BUT ALSO TO ADD ONE MORE
COMMENT IF YOU'RE A U. S.
MILITARY VETERAN AND YOU CAN
DRIVE A WATER TRAPPED. IN IRAQ
AVOIDING ROADSIDE BOMBS THAN
THOSE SKILLS TRANSFER. TO AND
THE PRIVATE SECTOR THE
GOVERNMENT SECTOR HERE IN IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THOSE SKILLS
ARE REAL AND SO- EVEN THOUGH
THIS BILL DOESN'T ADDRESS THE
SKILL SET TRANSFERS IT DOES
ALLOW AND EMPLOYERS TO GIVE A
PREFERENCE. TO VETERANS FOR
HIRING EMPLOYMENT AND
EMPLOYMENT PRACTICES WITHOUT
BEING WORRIED ABOUT-
DISCRIMINATE LUCIEN LAWSUITS OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT SO. I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S BILL
AND WOULD ASK FOR AN ITEM.
THERE IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE SENDER AMBER YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. I THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FOR THEIR SUPPORT ARJUN I VOTE
THANK YOU. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT KINS
FIVE BASE HI BECKER. I PORCHES
HI BRADFORD I KERR BIO HI
COURTESY HI DALLY. I THANK GOD.
I THEY'RE ALSO. ADMIN HI PLEASE
SIR I CONSOLIDATE. GROVE BY
HERTZ BERG I WAS SO. FIVE HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER.
LAYERED LLEVA FIVE THE MON HI
WIRE. HI MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A SHOW OF
BOTH HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO. HI
RALPH HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER.
STERN HI NUMBER FIVE BY CAL SKI.
WINNER WELL HI PLEASE CALL THE
OB TO MEMBERS. TORONTO GONZALEZ.
CAN LONGER. LAYERED MELINDA'S
SKINNER. WHITE HOUSE SKI.
WINNER I WAS THIRTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER ONE THIRTY
NINE SENATOR DR SO ARE YOU
PREPARED. SHE IS PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR DORADO AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC CONTRACTS SENATOR
EYES OF THE FORGERS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIRMAN. THIS BILL SIX
SEVENTY FOUR WILL SUPPORT THE
CREATION OF EQUITABLE HIGH
QUALITY TRANSPORTATION AND
RELATED MANUFACTURING JOBS IN
OUR STATE. IT'S GOING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE BENEFITS OF THE
TRANSITION TO CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION INCLUDE WELL
PAID JOBS FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
IN PARTICULAR. ON OUTREACH TO
COMMUNITIES THAT HISTORICALLY
BEEN LEFT OUT. THIS BILL WILL
ENACT THE CALIFORNIA JOBS PLAN
TO CREATE A CLEAR PARTNERSHIPS
WITH COMPANIES BENEFITING FROM
PUBLICLY FUNDED TRANSPORTATION
CONTRACTS AND SUBSIDIES WITH
CLEAN AND TRANSPARENT
COMMITMENTS. JOBS PLAN IS A
COMPONENT OF THE APPLICATION
SUBMITTED BY APPLICANTS FOR
COVERED PUBLIC CONTRACTS THAT
SPECIFIES THE MINIMUM NUMBER OF
JOB THEY WILL BE CREATING. THE
PROPOSED WAGES BENEFITS
INVESTMENT IN TRAINING AND
TARGETED HIRING PLANS FOR
DISPLACED WORKERS OR
INDIVIDUALS- HISTORICALLY
EXCLUDED. THE JOBS PLAN
COMPONENT WILL NOT REQUIRE ANY
NEW MINIMUM COMMITMENTS OTHER
THAN THOSE ALREADY REQUIRED BY
RELEVANT FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL LAWS. PRESIDENT BUYING
HAS BEEN CLEARED THE PUBLIC
DOLLARS SHOULD CREATE COMMUNITY
BENEFITS HIS EXECUTIVE ORDER ON
CLIMATE IMPLEMENTS IS THE FIRST
TIME FEDERAL POLICY IS PAIRING
THE URGENT ISSUES. OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS WITH
THE CREATION OF NEW GOOD JOBS
FOR INDUSTRY WORKERS AND PEOPLE
WHO LIVE IN HEAVILY POLLUTED
COMMUNITIES. THAT IS WHY
PARTNERSHIPS WITH BUSINESS CAN
LEAD TO PROSPERITY FOR EVERYONE
AND THE SUSTAINABLE HEALTHY
FUTURE FOR OUR STATE LAST
YEAR'S AB THREE NINETY EIGHT
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE QUOTE
PUTTING CALIFORNIA ON THE HIGH
ROAD OF JOBS AND CLIMATE ACTION
PLAN FOR TWENTY THIRTY.
IDENTIFIES GOODS MOVEMENT AND
THE MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE AS THE
SINGLE BIGGEST CONTRIBUTOR. OF
POLLUTION IT ALSO SAYS THAT THE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM UNDERPINS
OUR ECONOMY THE FREIGHT SYSTEM
MOVES TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
GOODS EACH YEAR SUPPORTING
NEARLY ONE THIRD OF THE ECONOMY
AND MORE THAN FIVE MILLION
JOBS. LAST YEAR. THIS LAST
YEAR'S PULL BACK THE CURTAIN ON
INEQUITIES ACROSS SO MANY OF
OUR INSTITUTIONS MAKE CLEAR
WHO'S HIT HIT THE HARDEST I MET
WITH SEVERAL TRANSIT AGENCIES
RECEIVED IDEAS TO MAKE THIS A
BETTER BILL. WE NEED CLEAR
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR COMMITMENTS
TO JOB CREATION AND PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE PROMISES MADE IN
THE CONTRACTS TAXPAYERS FUND
THIS BILL CURRENTLY HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SAYING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
AT KINS I FACE. BACKER HI FOR
JUST. BRADFORD I KERR BIO HI
CORTESE I DALLY. NO DODD. I
THERE ARE SO HI ADNAN HI
PLEASE- HI CONSOLIDATES HIGH
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO.
HI HER TADO I JONES- NO
CAMCORDER I LAYERED I LAVER I
LIVE ALONE. FIVE MCCOY- I
MELINDA'S. MAN HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. OCHO ABODE. NO PAN.
FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS HI RUBIO.
HI SKINNER. HI STERN I AM BERG
HI HI BY CASKEY I WINNER FIVE
WILKE. PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. BASICS NO FOR JUST NO.
MELINDA'S NIELSEN NO. PAM I
WELL. FIVE THIRTY ONE NO SEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON
TO ITEM ONE FORTY CENTER
KAMMERER SHE IS PREPARED.
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL SIX
SEVENTY NINE BY SENATOR COME
LONGER AN ACT RELATING TO
HOUSING. SENATOR COME UNDER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT SP SIX SEVEN NINE WHICH
WILL CREATE THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SOLUTIONS AGENCY ALSO KNOWN AS
LE CASA. THIS BILL WILL CREATE
A SINGLE INDEPENDENT COUNTY
WIDE AGENCY THAT IS DESIGNED TO
SUPPORT LOW INCOME RENTERS
PRESERVE HOUSING THAT IS
AFFORDABLE AND INNOVATE NEW
WAYS TO CREATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN EVERY COMMUNITY
ACROSS LA COUNTY. WITH A SINGLE
UNIFIED APPROACH WILL MAXIMIZE
THE SCALE AND RESOURCES OF THE
COUNTY. IT WILL ALSO MAKE SURE
THERE IS FAIR REPRESENTATION
FOR EXPERTS CITIES AND THE
COUNTY ON THE GOVERNING AND
CITIZENS OVERSIGHT BOARDS. LA
COUNTY UNFORTUNATELY RANKS LAST
IN THE NATION IN HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY OVERCROWDING AND
UNSHELTERED HOMELESSNESS WE SEE
THE CONSEQUENCES IN OUR
RACIALLY SEGREGATED OVERCROWDED
HOMES. LOW INCOME FAMILIES
BEING PUSHED OUT OF THEIR HOMES
AND FAR AWAY FROM THEIR JOBS
AND OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS
LIVING OUTSIDE ON THE SIDEWALKS.
S. B. SIX SEVEN NINE IS AN
EXCITING BELL IT IS AN
AMBITIOUS BILL THAT IS
SUPPORTED BY A LARGE AND
DIVERSE COALITION OF LABOR AND
JUSTICE ADVOCATES BUSINESS AND
MORE. WE ALL KNOW THAT THE
STATUS QUO ISN'T WORKING. F. B.
SIX SEVEN NINE OFFERS A
POWERFUL WAY FORWARD FOR LA
COUNTY AT THE SCALE THAT WE
DESPERATELY NEED. I AM EXCITED
TO OFFER THIS LEGISLATION AND
APPRECIATE SEVERAL OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM LOS ANGELES
JOINING ON AS CO AUTHORS THIS
IS A PRIORITY BILL FOR THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DELEGATION. I
WANTED TO GIVE SPECIAL
APPRECIATE APPRECIATION TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY SENATOR HERZBERG FOR HIS
SUPPORT DURING MY TRANSITION.
ON THIS BILL AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT YOU KNOW ON MOTHER'S
DAY. I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
RUNNING INTO A FAMILY OF FIVE.
THAT WAS LIVING IN THEIR SUV
AND THE PARK NEXT TO MY HOME.
AND AS I TALK TO THEM I LEARNED.
THAT THEY DRIVE FROM CITY TO
CITY THE DRIVE FROM AGENCY TO
AGENCY LOOKING FOR HELP AND
THEY DO THEIR PART THEY FILL
OUT APPLICATION AFTER
APPLICATION THEY GIVE UP THEIR
PERSONAL INFORMATION TIME AND
TIME AGAIN. LOOKING FOR A
PARKING SPACE WHERE THEY CAN
SLEEP AT NIGHT THAT'S SAFE OR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THIS IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO DO OUR PART. TO
OFFER A COORDINATED SOLUTION A
COORDINATED RESPONSE TO THE
NEEDS. OF THE SHINE AND STAR
AND THEIR THREE CHILDREN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. SENATOR BRING TINA.
THANK YOU AMANDA PRESIDENT- I
RISE SO RESPECTFULLY- TO- A
COMPLIMENT THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
CREATIVE APPROACH TO HOUSING
DOING A COUNTY WIDE BUT I MUST
RESPECTFULLY- LAY OFF THE BILL
TODAY- MIGHT CHALLENGE IS THE
CONCENTRATION OF THE BOARD THE
MAKEUP OF THE BOARD THE
GOVERNANCE- WE'VE SEEN IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THAT- SO OFTEN
BOARDS ARE HEAVILY SKEWED
TOWARDS. THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES IN THIS CASE I BELIEVE
THEY'RE GONNA EIGHT
REPRESENTATIVES ON THE BOARD
AND THEN BUT THE FIVE
SUPERVISORS ON TOP OF THAT
THAT'S MORE THAN HALF OF THE
BOARD MAKE UP WOULD BE
CONCENTRATED IN DOWNTOWN LA AND
I JUST THINK LOS ANGELES COUNTY
IS MADE UP OF EIGHTY EIGHT
CITIES I KNOW THE PART THE
AUTHOR HAS MADE EFFORTS TO TRY
TO SPREAD THE BOARD LEADERSHIP
AROUND- I'M STILL NOT. A 100%
THEY ARE IN SEEING THAT IT'S
NOT SO LA CENTRIC. AND I DO
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT. WHEN
YOU HAVE EIGHTY EIGHT CITIES
YOU CAN'T HAVE ONE PARTICULAR
ORGANIZATION DOMINATING SO MUCH
I KNOW THE CITY OF LONG BEACH.
HAS REPRESENTATION ON THE BOARD
BUT THE LARGE CITIES TO THE
SOUTH OF LA THE LARGE CITIES.
TO THE EAST OF LA INTO THE WEST
OF LA DON'T HAVE THAT
REPRESENTATION DIRECTLY THAT LA
AND LONG BEACH TO SO FOR THOSE
REASONS I'M GOING TO OPPOSE THE
BILL TODAY. SENATOR DRESSEL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I RISE AS
A PRIVATE COLLECTOR IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX SEVENTY NINE AND I'M
PROUD TO SUPPORT UNITED WAY I
WORKED WITH UNITED WAY FOR MANY
YEARS AND ALL THE THING THAT
THEY DO ESPECIALLY AROUND
HOUSING- AND THE HOMELESS HAS
BEEN A VERY VERY IMPORTANT FOR
LOS ANGELES. AND THIS PANDEMIC
WE ALREADY KNOW EXASPERATED
WHAT WE ALREADY KNOW TO BE THE
CASE HOUSING CRISIS IN MY
DISTRICT AND ACROSS LA COUNTY.
MAKE CLEAR WHAT WE KNOW TO BE
TRUE OUR COMMUNITIES ARE BEING
FORCED TO MAKE THE UNTENABLE
CHOICE IN WHERE AND HOW THEY
LIVE. WE ARE CLEARLY NOT DOING
ENOUGH TO PRESERVE AND CREATE
HOMES FOR WORKING PEOPLE FOR
LOW INCOME PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTY. THIS BILL HAS STRONG
SUPPORT. FROM THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ROUTE THAT REPRESENT HARD
WORKING PEOPLE THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES A HOTEL AND
FOOD SERVICE WORKERS THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES WORK. THESE
ARE WORKERS THAT ARE BEING
PRICED OUT OF THEIR COMMUNITY
AND FORCED TO ENDURE LONG
COMMUTES TO THEIR JOBS WE NEED
A COMPREHENSIVE COUNTY WIDE
APPROACH. TO HOUSING-
ESPECIALLY FOR WORKING AND LOW
INCOME PEOPLE THEY CAN ACCESS
IT AND AFFORD- THIS IS A PATH
FORWARD FOR CREATING HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY ACROSS THE
COUNTY. I URGE YOUR EYEBALLS
THANK YOU. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SO.
THE LA COUNTY DELEGATION. WHICH
IS THIRTY SOME MEMBERS. OF BOTH
HOUSES HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE. OF HOUSING FOR A
LONG TIME MORE THAN A YEAR WE
HAD A SERIES OF MEETINGS WE'VE
HAD A NUMBER OF EXPERTS
MACKENZIE AT. UCLA AND THE LIKE.
IN AN EFFORT TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT DO WE DO WITH THE
HOUSING ISSUE IN LOS ANGELES
AND HOW DO WE PROVIDE A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH AS WAS
MENTIONED. THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES WHICH IS NEARLY A THIRD
OF THE POPULATION OF THE CITY
CALIFORNIA INCLUDES EIGHTY
EIGHT CITIES. HE SAID THE
OPERATING DIFFERENTLY. ONE OF
THE GREAT CHALLENGES WITH THE
EXPERTS WITH WHOM WE CAN FOR IS
THAT WE DON'T REALLY HAVE A
COORDINATED ENTITY. SO GROUP OF
FOLKS AS WAS MENTIONED
INCLUDING UNITED WAY AS MANY AS
TWENTY ORGANIZATIONS CAME
TOGETHER IN A VERY THOUGHTFUL
WAY. TO FORM THE FOUNDATION OF
THE IDEAS CONTAINED. IN THIS
MEASURE. THE QUESTION IS CAN WE
CREATE AN ENTITY. THAT CAN DEAL
MORE BROADLY ACROSS THE LINES
OF CITY AFTER CITY. WHATEVER
THOSE REPRESENTATIONS WERE A
LOT OF WORK WAS DONE WITH THE
COUNTIES AND THE CITIES TO GET
TO GOAL WE HAVE IN LA COUNTY. A
SERIES OF ENTITIES THE
SANITATION DISTRICTS THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
INCLUDES OTHER COUNTIES WE HAVE
A WHOLE HOST OF. ORGANIZATIONS
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITIES THE
LIKE THE DEAL WITH THE
COMPLEXITIES THAT WE FACE AS WE
TRY TO GOVERN WHAT IS LOST IN
THE AIR LOS ANGELES AREA. AND
SO I WANT TO APPLAUD AND SAY
THAT I WILL STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE. AND GIVE GREAT
CREDIT TO THOSE BEHIND THIS AS
WELL AS TO THE AUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE. I THINK I'M A CO
AUTHOR I BELIEVE- IF NOT I WANT
TO BE AND- I WOULD APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS MISSION
THANK YOU. SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE- TODAY I WANT TO
STAND AND- VALIDATE THE
COMMENTS OF MY- COLLEAGUE FROM
LOCKING OUT A- I THINK THAT-
IT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT FOR THE
SINGLE FAMILY AND I HAVE TO
SHARE THAT- FIRST OF ALL I
WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING SO CLOSELY WITH ME AND
TRYING TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ISSUES BUT- THE ISSUE IS NOT
THE HOUSING TRUST WE ALL AGREED
THAT WE HAVE TO. DO SOMETHING
TO CREATE MORE HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA BUT IT'S REALLY
ABOUT THE REPRESENTATION OF
TRADITIONALLY HISTORICALLY THE
SANGRO VALLEY HAS BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
SOMEBODY- KELLY WHITE POLICIES
AND WE JUST HAPPEN TO BEONE OF
THE ONLY DISTRICTS WHO ALREADY
HAS A HOUSING TRUST THAT SAID
STATE THAT'S ESTABLISHED IT'S
WORKING IT'S ALREADY PRODUCING
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
HOUSING UNITS AND THAT'S BEEN
DONE IN THE AND THE LAST TWO
YEARS SEOUL. OUR COMMUNITIES
FEAR IS THAT THIS NEW HOUSING
TRUST IS GOING TO DERAIL THE
GOOD WORK THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
IMPLEMENTED AND SO I DO WANT TO
SAY THAT THE AUTHOR IS BEEN
EXTREMELY GRACIOUS AND TRYING
TO WORK WITH ME TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES CAN GET ON
BOARD AND SO WE'VE HAD PLENTY
OF DISCUSSIONS AND SHE'S GIVING
ME EVERY ASSURANCE THAT SHE
WILL CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS OF MY COMMUNITY AND SO
WITH THAT I JUST WANTED TO.
STATE THAT OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
NOT OPPOSED TO HOUSING THE FACT
IS THAT WE'RE ALREADY CREATING
pSURE IT'S AFFORDABLE AND WE
DON'T END UP DERAILING ALL THE
WORK. WE'VE DONE UP TO NOW
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION- OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR WIENER. I THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. WE SAW THE
STORM THE HOUSING COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS THE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE- IT'S A BILL%
THAT IT TOOK A LOT OF WORK AND
I THINK IT'S A VERY WELL
CONSTRUCTED BILL- WE DID THIS
YOU MAY RECALL A FEW YEARS AGO
THE LEGISLATURE AUTHORIZED. THE
BAY AREA TO COME TOGETHER AS A
REGION GO TO THE BALLOT TO
FUND. THIS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
NEED OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING- AND
I'M REALLY THRILLED THAT AWAY-
IS MOVING IN THAT DIRECTION AS
WELL LIKE THE BAY AREA- LA-
CONTINUES TO HEAD IN A
DIRECTION WHERE IT'S- MORE
MORE. DIFFICULT OR IMPOSSIBLE
FOR PEOPLE TO AFFORD TO LIVE
THERE AND SOME PEOPLE LEAVE.
THEY MOVED FAR AWAY OR
TRAGICALLY THEY BECOME
HOMELESS- THIS IS A MEANINGFUL
AND THOUGHTFUL. EFFORT TO TRY
TO STEM THAT TIDE AND I ASKED
FOR AND I VOTE. IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING MAN SENATOR YOU MAY
CONCLUDE THANK YOU I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FROM- THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY AND FROM-
THE BAY AREA FOR THEIR SUPPORT
AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY FOR THEIR- HONEST
CONVERSATIONS WITH ME- ABOUT
THEIR CONSTITUENTS- AND THIS
BILL- YOU KNOW BASED ON THE
RENO GOALS ARE FOR THE IT'S SIX
CYCLE. LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS
SUPPOSED TO PRODUCE. CLOSE TO
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND UNITS. WE ARE ON TRACK
TO PRODUCE LESS THAN TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND. THAT IS NOT
SOLVING THE PROBLEM THAT IS
EXACERBATING THE PROBLEM. AND
THE MORE WE RE ENFORCED THIS
FRAGMENTATION IN OUR COUNTY THE
HARDER THIS ISSUE WILL BE TO
SOLVE. I APPLAUD THE WORK THAT
SENATOR RUBIO DID IN CREATING
THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY HOUSING
TRUST FUND- ABSOLUTELY THAT
WAS- A HEAVY LIFT AND REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THAT COMMUNITY-
AND I WOULD ADD THAT THIS
HOUSING AUTHORITY WOULD ONLY
SUPPLEMENT AND COMPLEMENT THOSE
HOUSING TRUSTS THAT ARE ALREADY
IN EXISTENCE. THE IDEA IS TO.
COLLECTIVELY AS ONE ENTITY WITH
INCREASED TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. FIGHTS ARE
AFFORD CRY. BY PRESERVING UNITS
BY PRODUCING MORE UNITS AND I
PUT RENTERS AND THAT IS WHAT
THE DOES WE HAVE TO BE TETHERED
TOGETHER FOR THE SOLUTION I
WANT TO ALSO ADD THAT WE HAVE
TAKEN A NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS
ARE THE MOST RECENT TAKEN IN
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WHICH PROVIDE A
ROBUST GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE
THAT IS REPRESENTATIVE OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND IN FACT WE
EXPANDED THE BOARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE WAS REPRESENTATION
FROM ACROSS THE REGION. OF LOS
ANGELES. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THIS BILL. I LOOK FORWARD
TO US ALL J. COLLECTIVELY AND
FINE SO. FOR OUR HOUSING OF
CRISIS IN LOS ANGELES CAN. AND
I WAS ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
MEDITECH PLEASE THE ROLL. ALAN
HI ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I BASE.
NO BACKER. FIVE FORGES NO
BRADFORD I KERR BIO I COURTESY
I DALLY. DODD FIVE TORONTO HI
EGGMAN HI PLEASE SIR. GONZALEZ
I GROSS. NO HERTZBERG. HI WITH
SO. HI HER TADO I JONES NO
KAMMERER I LAYERED. I LLEVA HI
LYNN MON HI MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S MAN I NEWMAN. HI
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH. HI
PAM I FORTUNE TINO. ROTH HI
RUBIO. HI SKINNER I STERN. HI
AMBERG. WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WINNER I WILL. NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLY NO.
GLAZER. MELINDA'S FORTUNE TINO.
AMBERG. ICE TWENTY NINE NO
SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM ONE FORTY ONE SENATOR
STERN IS PREPARED. PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX NINETY THREE BY
SENATOR STERN AN ACT RELATING
TO PEOPLE INSTRUCTION CENTER
STERN YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT IS B. SIX
NINETY THREE THE NEVER AGAIN
EDUCATION ACT. DOES IT MEAN
WHEN WE SAY NEVER AGAIN.
MEMBERS AND I ASK OF YOU TO
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR IF YOU COULD- IT'S
GETTING. S. AND YOUNGER
GENERATIONS THAN THEM. WHEN
ASKED IN A RECENT POLL DON'T
KNOW WHAT OUR IS. JEWS WERE
ATTACKED ON THE STREETS OF LOS
ANGELES LAST WEEK A CINDER
BLOCK WAS THROWN THROUGH A
SYNAGOGUE WINDOW THIS PAST
WEEKEND. PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
ATTACKING. PEOPLE OF THE JEWISH
FAITH ON TWITTER SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND TWEETS IN THE LAST
THREE WEEKS THAT HAD THE HASH
TAG HITLER WAS RIGHT EMANATING
FROM THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. THE HASHTAG HAS BEEN
TRENDING THIS PAST WEEK. EVEN
IN CALIFORNIA'S HASH TAG COVE
INTO NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT. AS
IN THE FOUNDING OF THE STATE OF
ISRAEL AFTER THE HOLOCAUST WAS
SOMEHOW. A VIRUS UNLEASHED UPON
THE PEOPLE OF THE WORLD. THE
VERY VALID DEBATES ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF THE MIDDLE EAST HAVE
BLED INTO OUTRIGHT XENOPHOBIA
AND ANTI SEMITISM IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. I WAS WALKING
THREE BLOCKS AWAY FROM. A GROUP
OF PEOPLE THAT WERE ATTACKED
WITH. MY WIFE IN FATHER IN LAW
WHO ACTUALLY SURVIVED AUSCHWITZ.
AND A WALK IN FEAR ON THE
STREETS OF LOS ANGELES WHEN YOU
ACTUALLY ARE WEARING A COUPON
OR HAVE A MUG IN DIRE NEED OF A
STAR OF DAVID ON YOUR CHEST AND
FEEL UNSAFE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS A SHAME. AND IT
STARTS WITH EDUCATION AT ITS
CORE THIS BILL HERE TODAY WOULD
MAKE OUR HOLOCAUST EDUCATION
PROCESS AND GENOCIDE EDUCATION
IN OUR SCHOOLS NOT JUST A CHECK
BOX WE READ IN FRANK. AND YOU
SAY THAT'S THAT'S I DID MY DUTY
I DID MY WORK. WE HAVE TO MAKE
THIS ACTION ORIENTED EDUCATION
AND NOT DIVIDE THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY. IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY FROM THE LATINO
COMMUNITY FROM THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY FROM API COMMUNITY
AND- ALL THE OTHERS. THIS
CANNOT BE- AND IDENTITY BASED
POLITICAL WARFARE SO THIS THIS
BILL HOPEFULLY WILL START TO
BRING ABOUT SOME HEALING BY
MODERNIZING. OUR CURRICULUM BY
EMPOWERING YOUNG PEOPLE TO TAKE
MATTERS INTO THEIR OWN HANDS.
AS WARRIORS FOR TOLERANCE AND
FOR DIVERSITY. THIS BILL IS
SACRED WORK I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION SUPPORT
AND TEACHERS FOR COMING ON
BOARD AND MINISTRY LEADERS AND
FOR THOSE INVOLVED WITH
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE EDUCATION FOR
STEPPING UP AND SAYING NEVER
AGAIN- MEMBERS. COLLECTIVE
MEMORY LOSS IS A IS A VERY
DANGEROUS. A DANGEROUS TREND IN
OUR SOCIETY WHEN YOU SEE PEOPLE
GOING INTO OUR CAPITAL IN
JANUARY SIX WEARING CAMP
AUSCHWITZ AND KIDS WATCHING
THAT ON TV HAS NO IDEA WHAT
THAT MEANS WE HAVE A PROBLEM ON
OUR HANDS SO SIX SP SIX NINETY
THREE HOPEFULLY WILL START TO
TURN THE PAGE ON THIS DARK HERE
OF IGNORANCE. AND WE CAN TRULY
SAY NEVER AGAIN I MEAN. SENATOR
BURGESS. I'D LIKE TO COMMEND-
THE AUTHOR THE SENATOR FROM LOS
ANGELES FOR THIS BILL- PROUD TO
SERVE AS A CO AUTHOR ON THIS I
THINK EVERYTHING THAT HE STATED
IS THAT EDUCATION. IS PROBABLY
THE MOST IMPORTANT ELEMENT AND
NOT JUST- RECOGNIZING AND
COMMEMORATING. THINGS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED IN THE PAST BUT
PREVENTING THOSE EVENTS THAT
MAY OCCUR IN THE FUTURE. SO IN
ADDITION TO THE HOLOCAUST I
BELIEVE THAT GENOCIDE
CURRICULA- NEEDS TO- GIVE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF- OF-
MATERIAL- THROUGH THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM THAT WOULD INVOLVE THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE THE GREEK
PONTIC GENOCIDE- CAMBODIAN
THERE THE PROBLEM IS THE LIST
IS LONG BUT I THINK IT'S
ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE- THAT WE
FORMALIZE- THIS TYPE OF
EDUCATION IN- THE SCHOOL SYSTEM
AND THIS IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. SO ONCE AGAIN THANK
YOU TO THE SENATOR FROM LOS
ANGELES PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS.
SENATOR PENN. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- CENTERS I TO RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIX NINETY
THREE AND- LIKE THANK MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM A SAND SPRINGS FORD
AND AS MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
FRESNO SAID THE LIST IS TOO
LONG. THIS IS VERY LONG AND
UNFORTUNATELY THE LIST COULD
GET LONGER IF PEOPLE DON'T
REMEMBER. TO ME IT IS- I THINK
AS I GET FROM LOS ANGELES POINT
INCIDENTS THAT ARE HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW WHICH INDICATES THAT
PEOPLE HAVE- DON'T REALIZE THE
SERIOUSNESS. OF WHAT HAPPENED
IN THESE PAST GENOCIDES
INCLUDING PARTICULARLY THE
HOLOCAUST- CERTAINLY I. HAVE
ALSO SEEN THIS AND HAVE BEEN
APPALLED AT THE FACT THAT YOU
HAVE A STORE OWNER DECIDES TO
SELL YELLOW STARS- IT'S A WAY
TO TRY TO MAKE A POLITICAL
POINT ABOUT VACCINES NOT
RECOGNIZING WHAT THAT REALLY
MEANT- DURING THE HOLOCAUST
DURING WORLD WAR TWO ****
GERMANY. AND CERTAINLY USING
OTHER SYMBOLS AS WELL AS OTHER
GENOCIDES AS WELL- IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE NEVER FORGET
AND WE CAN'T AND- IT'S SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE EDUCATE. OUR
USERS HERE IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT
HISTORY SO THAT WE DON'T
REPEAT- THE- NOW THE STAKES AND
THE HORRORS OF THE PAST. I
START TO STAND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. SENATOR NELSON.
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE THIS IS A
MOVING MOMENT FOR ME BASED ON
MY OWN EXPERIENCE IN ISRAEL. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE AS A PART
OF AGRICULTURAL FELLOWSHIP THAT
I'VE BEEN A PART OF FOR TWO
YEARS WE TRAVELED
INTERNATIONALLY MANY COUNTRIES.
EGYPT INDIA PAKISTAN ISRAEL AND
ITALY. WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME.
IN ITALY WE SPENT MORE TIME. IN
JERUSALEM AND TEL AVIV. IT
STRUCK ME COMING INTO ISRAEL
HAS. VIRTUALLY A MILITARY STATE.
MILITARY EVERYWHERE. AT FIRST I
KIND OF WONDERED WHY BUT I'VE
DONE A LOT OF STUDYING OF
MIDDLE EASTERN HISTORY. IT TOOK
AROUND NINETY EIGHT NINETEEN
FORTY EIGHT WHEN THE
PARTITIONING OCCURRED IN.
THINGS GOT PRETTY ROUGH OVER
THERE. BUT THEY HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN PRETTY ROUGH OVER THERE.
MR STUDY ANCIENT HISTORY OF
BIBLICAL HISTORY. IT'S ALWAYS
BEEN A CHALLENGE WE SPENT ONE
NIGHT WITH THE FAMILY. IN THEIR
HOME AND A WHOLE BUNCH. THAT'S
RIGHT NEXT TO TEL AVIV IN. I
ASKED THE WIFE WHAT IS IT LIKE.
THE LIVE ALL OF THE DAY'S. YOUR
LIFE. IN A MILITARY STATE.
UNDER THE CONSTANT THREATS THAT
YOU LIVE UNDER. SHE HAD A VERY
RESIGNED RESPONSE SHE SAID IN
SOME THINGS YOU HAVE NO CHOICE.
THAT GAVE ME GREAT INSIGHT.
INTO THE ISRAELI PEOPLE. THIS
IS ALL THE MORE IMPORTANT RIGHT
NOW. AMERICA HAS ALWAYS BEEN.
THAL ALLY. OF ISRAEL. BUT I SEE
IN AMERICA RIGHT NOW A GREAT
DIMINUTION. OF THAT SUPPORT. IN
FACT IN SOME PARTS. THE
DISCRIMINATION IN THIS COUNTRY.
OF THE ISRAELI PEOPLE. THAT'S A
VERY SAD THING TO SEE. HELLO
GOOD AND NOBLE ALLY. WELL
WORTHY OF OUR PROTECTION. THE
HISTORY OF THAT LAND HAS BEEN
SO BRUTAL. AND I GUESS I
THOUGHT I KNEW A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT IT TILL I WENT THERE AND
TALKED TO THE PEOPLE. MANY WHO
IS SERVED. IN THE NINETEEN
FORTY EIGHT WAR. AND IN
SUBSEQUENT CONFLICTS OVER THERE.
MY APPEAL HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF THE LEGISLATION. IS BASED ON
THAT PERSON'S EXPERIENCE. IN
THE WORDS OF THAT WIFE AND
REPUBLIC IN SOME THINGS YOU
HAVE NO CHOICE. AND SOME PEOPLE
WHO DO NOT DO NOT HAVE A CHOICE.
I THINK I DO DESERVE OUR
SUPPORT- GINGIVAL. CENTER GROVE
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT HERE
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN I
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF DOING WHAT
WAS CALLED THE POPE JOHN PAUL
MARGARET THATCHER REAGAN TOUR
AND- THE EMPHASIS ON POPE JOHN
PAUL'S PIECE WAS IN POLAND
WHERE YOU WENT TO ACTUALLY-
STAND AT THE BIRKENAU CAMPS A
LOT OF PEOPLE HERE ABOUT US
WHICH A LOT OF PEOPLE HEAR
ABOUT OTHER CAMPS THAT WHEN YOU
GO TO BIRKENAU IN THE HEAR THE
STORIES OF- WHAT HAPPENED IN
THE GENOCIDE THAT TOOK PLACE.
THERE IN THE RAIL CARS THAT
CAME IN AND THE. AND I WANT TO
SAY IT TOTALLY RUINED OUR DAY
BUT AFTER THAT YOU JUST WANTED
TO GO BACK INTO SOME REALLY
THINK ABOUT HOW CRUEL PEOPLE
CAN BE AND WHY SOMETHING LIKE
THAT COULD EVER HAPPEN IN THE
HISTORY OF THE WORLD AND SO I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR MAKING
SURE THAT THAT STUDENTS AND THE
NEXT GENERATION'S NEVER FORGET
WHAT HAPPENED TO OUR PEOPLE AND
WHAT CONTINUES ALMOST TO THIS
DAY NOT SO MUCH AS THE
HOLOCAUST BUT- THE ATTACK ON
THE JEWISH PEOPLE CONTINUES
TODAY. AND SO I APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR FOR MAKING SURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS NEVER FORGET THAT THEY
LEARN ABOUT IT THAT THEY MAKE
SURE THAT WE PASS THE MANTLE TO
THE NEXT GENERATION THAT THEY
MAKE SURE THAT SOMETHING LIKE
THIS NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN IN OUR
WORLD AND SO THANK YOU AND ASK
YOUR SUPPORT ON AN SP SIX
NINETY SIX NINETY THREE. IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SAYING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THIS- IT
IS ELIGIBLE FOR YOU UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION. I THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO
IBM ONE OH TWO. SENATOR ALAN IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE FORTY THREE BY
SENATOR ALLEN AN ACT RELATING
TO ENVIRONMENTAL ADVERTISING
SENATOR ALLEN THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS THIS IS A- OF
SIMPLE MEASURE THAT ULTIMATELY-
SAYS THAT IF YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO. CALL YOUR- PRODUCT
RECYCLABLE USE THE WORDS
RECYCLABLE ON YOUR- AS AN
UNTRUTHFUL CLAIMS YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED US TO PUT THAT ON YOUR
CONTAINER YOU SHOULDN'T BE
ALLOWED. TO PUT THE RECYCLING
SYMBOL ON YOUR ON YOUR PRODUCT
THE CHASING ARROW SYMBOL- THE
SAD TRUTH MEMBERS IS THAT LESS
THAN 15% OF SINGLE USE PLASTIC
IS ACTUALLY RECYCLED. BUT
CONSUMERS ARE DUTIFULLY FILLING
THEY BELIEVE ARE RECYCLABLE. HI
THIS IS WHAT WE CALL WISH
CYCLING IT'S SOMETHING THAT
CONTAMINATES THE RECYCLING
STREAM IT ACTUALLY MAKES IT
MORE COSTLY TO SORT AND CLEAN
THE TRULY RECYCLED MATERIAL.
MATERIAL THAT IS NOT ACTUALLY
RECYCLABLE ACTUALLY HAS TO THEN
BE REMOVED FROM THE CONVEYOR
BELT OUT THE RECYCLING FACILITY
IN CARTED AWAY. TO A LANDFILL
AND IT'S REALLY IMPACTING OUR
CITY'S EARLIEST CITIES JUST DID
A STUDY RELEASED THIS YEAR
FOUND THAT MORE THAN SEVEN OUT
OF TEN CITIES ANTICIPATE
INCREASING WASTE COLLECTION
RATES BY AS MUCH AS TWENTY
PERCENT. TO COVER THE COST OF
MANAGING THE ADDITIONAL WAYS I
KNOW THE COUNTY OF SACRAMENTO
FOR EXAMPLE JUST RAISE THE
RATES BY TEN DOLLARS. A MONTH-
CONSUMERS MISTAKENLY BELIEVE
THE CHASING EURO SYMBOL THE
RECYCLING SYMBOL MEANS THAT
THE- THAT THAT THAT THE PRODUCT
IS RECYCLABLE- AND OF COURSE WE
HAVE THE SYSTEM IF YOU LOOK AT
ANY PLASTIC PRODUCTS AND
THERE'S A- THIS RECYCLING
SYMBOL IN THE MIDDLE IS A
LITTLE NUMBER. AND IT BASICALLY
IS A CODE FOR THE RESIN THAT IS
USED. IN THE PRODUCTION OF THE
PLASTIC. AND I CLASSIFIED THE
PLASTIC TYPES FROM NUMBERS ONE
THREE SEVEN. AND IT WAS
DESIGNED AS A METHOD FOR WASTE
FACILITIES TO PROPERLY SORT
PLASTICS. NOT INTERESTINGLY AS
A WAY TO SUGGEST. A
RECYCLABILITY TO CONSUMERS GET
AFTER THIRTY YEARS AND USE THE
SYMBOL HAS. COME TO BE
UNDERSTOOD AS THE RECYCLING
SYMBOL IN FACT. SOMETIMES
PRODUCT. PRODUCERS WILL JUST
PUT THESE- THE RECYCLING SYMBOL
ON THERE WITHOUT ANY NUMBER IN
THE MIDDLE ND WHEN ASKED WHY
DID YOU PUT IT ON THERE THOUGH
SO WE JUST WANT TO ENCOURAGE
RECYCLING. IN GENERAL. EVEN
THOUGH THERE THAT PARTICULAR
PRODUCT IS NOT AT ALL
RECYCLABLE SO. I LOOK AT IT WE
DO RECYCLING IS COMPLICATED WE
KNOW THAT IT'S CONFUSING THE
CONSUMER BRANDS ASSOCIATION
JUST DID A STUDY. THEY FOUND
OUT THE RECYCLING RANKS AHEAD
OF SOME OF THE MOST CONFUSING
THINGS IN LIFE FOR MOST
AMERICANS. IT'S MORE CONFUSING
THAN BUILDING IKEA FURNITURE
MORE CONFUSING THAN THAN DOING
YOUR TAXES. PLAYING THE STOCK
MARKET OR UNDERSTANDING YOUR
SPOUSE. SO ACCORDING TO THE
STATEWIDE COMMISSION RECYCLING
MARKETS IN CURBSIDE RECYCLING
IS RECENT REPORT QUOTE SINCE
CONSUMERS EQUATE THAT WILL
RECYCLE WORD AND SYMBOL WITH
WHAT IS ACCEPTED. IN CURBSIDE
RECYCLING BINS TO RECYCLE WORD
AND SYMBOL MUST BE RESERVED FOR
MATERIALS. WHICH ARE ACCEPTED
IN CURBSIDE BINS AND DO NOT
CAUSE. CONTAMINATION SO OUR
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW SAY THAT
PRODUCERS CAN'T LIE TO
CONSUMERS ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
A PRETTY PRODUCT IS RECYCLABLE.
THIS BILL CLARIFIES IT THAT
THAT INCLUDES THE THIS INCLUDES
THE CHASING ARROW SYMBOL. AND.
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. IS THERE ANY DO. OR
DEBATE. SENATOR EDMUND. IF YOU
COULD JUST HOLD ON A SECOND
OKAY YOUR MIKE TURNED ON. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
AND- AND MEMBERS AT THAT. TIME
I WRITE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THE COMMISSION THE CENTER'S
REFERRING TO A SOME LEGISLATION
I DID IT A FEW YEARS AGO- TO
TRY TO GET OUR HANDS AROUND
THIS RECYCLING ISSUE AND- I
KNOW A LOT OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS
HAVE BEEN ANGRY LATELY WHEN
THEY'RE- EVERYONE GETTING
NOTICES THAT THEY HAVE TO DO A
BETTER JOB OF. CLEANING THEIR
STREAM AND EVERYONE'S ANGRY
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE THEY FEEL
LIKE THEY'VE BEEN FOLLOWING THE
RULES BUT THEY HAVE BEEN
TRICKED A LOT OF TIMES PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN TRICKED INTO RULES.
OUT BY BY SERVER MANUFACTURERS
WHO HAPPEN. TO GET THIS ISSUE-
WISH CYCLING- AND NOTHING AND
SO PEOPLE ARE FEELING LIKE
THEY'RE DOING THEIR VERY BEST
AND NOW THEY'RE GETTING CHARGED
MORE. SO HOPEFULLY AS WE
INCREASE. OUR PUBLIC AWARENESS
AND AS WE REALLY TRY TO HOLD
MANUFACTURERS. AT TWO EIGHT AT
A CONSISTENT STANDARD OF WHAT
IS ACTUALLY RECYCLING AND HELP
OUR CONSTITUENTS UNDERSTAND
THAT. WE GET A LOT FURTHER IN
HELPING REDUCE THE WASTE THAT
GOES INTO OUR OUR LANDFILL SO
I. WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING NONE SENATOR
ALAN- SENATOR RUBIO YEAH. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT AT BEST
BE THREE FORTY THREE I WANT TO
THANK OUR AUTHOR HERE- HE
UNDERSTANDS- FIRST OF ALL THAT
I HAVE READ ON AND DATA BUT YES
YOU- NOTED HERE HE IS- HE HAS
THE DATA HE HAS THE INFORMATION
I EVEN SENT ME. A VIDEO AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I HAVE TO
AGREE WITH EVERYONE IS THAT WE
HAVE TO EDUCATE- FOLKS ABOUT
RECYCLING AND FOR THOSE THAT
DON'T NECESSARILY MAKE IT A
PRACTICE TO DO SO WILL THEY
TAKE THAT SIMPLE OR THAT
MISLEADING- I WOULD SAY FALSE
ADVERTISEMENT TO RECYCLE AND I
THINK IT'S ABOUT EDUCATION
COMMUNITY AWARENESS ESPECIALLY
IN OUR INNER CITY COMMUNITIES
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE THE TIME
NECESSARY TO EDUCATE SO I THINK
THIS IS A- GOOD COMMON SENSE
BILL AND I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING A FORWARD
THINKING. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SINGMAN
SENATOR ALLEN YOU MAY CONCLUDE
WANTED JUST THINK GRAHAM MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR SUPPORT
AND I RESPECT FASTER THAN EVER.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. TH ALAN I ARCHULETA I CAN
FIVE BASE. BACKER HI FOR JUST.
BRADFORD HI BY ADAM I COURTESY
HI SALLY. DODD FIVE TORONTO BY
ADMIN I GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES
HI GROSS. HERTZBERG I WAS SO. I
HER TADO BY JONES NO CAMCORDER.
I LAYERED I LLEVA. I THE MON I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S MAN FIVE
NEWMAN. HI NIELSEN NO A CHOKE
NO PAN HI PERSONS YOU KNOW HI
RALPH I RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN I AMBER I LIKE OUR SKI I
WINNER I WILL. NO PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBERS. BAYTEX FOR
JEFF NO. DALLY GROWTH NO.
MELINDA'S. HIGHS THIRTY ONE
KNOWS FIVE THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE GO
BACK TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY NINE
AFTER WHICH WE WILL START TO
WORK ON THE CONSENT SO YOU
MIGHT WANNA PULL OUT YOUR LIST
AND- AND THE- WHAT WE WILL LIFT
THE CALLS. SO SENATOR MCGUIRE
IS READY ON ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
NINETY EIGHT BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
SERVICE SAFETY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH READING PRESIDENT
WONDERFUL JOB TODAY NO IT'S
BEEN A LONG LINE OF FREEDOM OF
THE PRESS IS ONE OF THE
FOUNDATIONS UPON WHICH THIS
NATION WAS BORN AND WE ALL
BENEFIT FROM THIS FREEDOM IS IT
HELPS STRENGTHEN OUR DEMOCRACY
THAT KEEPS CHECK ON GOVERNMENT
AS WELL AS INFORM OUR DECISION
STANDS LET'S BE CANDID WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE SOME CRACKS IN
THAT. THERE HAVE BEEN
APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED
INCIDENTS UNITED STATES ARE
REPORTED AT DETAINMENT
SUPPRESSANT ASSAULTS AGAINST
THE MEMBERS OF THE PRESS
ATTEMPTING TO DO THEIR JOB TO
BE ABLE TO UPHOLD THE FIRST
AMENDMENT THIS ALL HAPPEN IN
TWENTY TWENTY ALONE. CURRENTLY
IN STATE LAW REPORTERS ARE
GRANTED AUTHORITY TO ENTER
AREAS CLOSE BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
SUCH AS- WHEN THERE'S A NATURAL
DISASTER FIRE FLOOD OR
EARTHQUAKE IN ORDER TO GATHER
INFORMATION TO RELAY THAT
BREAKING NEWS TO THE PUBLIC.
THESE PROTECTIONS DO NOT THOUGH
EXPRESSIVELY EXTENDED THE FIRST
AMENDMENT IN FIRST AMENDMENT
DEMONSTRATIONS SUCH AS MARCHES
AND RALLIES AND DEMONSTRATIONS
AS WELL AS PROTESTS IT'S A
PRETTY SIMPLE BILL SB NINETY
EIGHT EXTENDS CRUCIAL
PROTECTIONS THE MEMBERS OF THE
PRESS AS THE INTERNAL REPORT ON
THESE AMENDMENTS AS WE ALREADY
ALLOW THEM TO DO WHEN IT COMES
TO A NATURAL DISASTER. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR AND I
VOTE. IS THERE ANY. OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SINGMAN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
I BASE. BACKER HI GORGEOUS. NO
BRADFORD. I HAVE A HI COURTESY
HI DALLY. DOT HI THERE ALSO HI
A GIVEN. GLAZER. HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
I JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED.
FIVE LLEVA I LIVE ALONE. I
REQUIRE FIVE MELINDA'S MAN FIVE
NEWMAN. I NIELSEN. BUT SHOW A
BOOK FIVE TEN FIVE FORTUNE TINO.
I. ROSS HI RUBIO HI SKINNER
FIVE STERN HI AMBERG I LIKE HOW
SKI FIVE WINNER I WILL. KNOW
PLEASE CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS.
BATES DALLY. EGGMAN I. GROVE I.
MELINDA'S NIELSEN. HIGHS THIRTY
FOUR NOSE TO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL SO YOU MIGHT WANT TO TAKE
YOUR SEATS AND GET READY TO- TO
VOTE ON THESE. BECAUSE WE'RE
GONNA MOVE THROUGH THESE PRETTY
FAST. I LIKE TO ASK ANYBODY
WHO'S- INVOLVED IN A
CONVERSATION TO WRAP IT UP SO
THAT WE CAN. IT RIGHT INTO THIS.
K. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO START
ON THE ON CALL LIST WE'LL START
WITH FILE NUMBER THIRTEEN
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS PLEASE
READ- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FAITH FOR JEFF. BRADFORD FIVE.
DALLY. THANK MAN I. GROWTH
JONES. MELINDA'S PHOTO OF BOTH.
PAN I. WILKE NO. HELLO. YEAH
PLEASE CALL PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BASED PORGES.
DALLY GROVE. JONES MELENDEZ
PATROL BOAT. I. THE ICE THIRTY
THREE KNOWS ONE DEPARTMENT IF
CONFIRMED MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FILE NUMBER TWENTY THREE
S. B. TWO EIGHTY BY SENATOR LEE
MON PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. FAITH I FOR JUST. I
BRADFORD I. MELINDA'S PAN HI.
HIGHS THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
ITEM FILE NUMBER THIRTY THREE
SB FORTY SEVEN. BY SENATOR LEE
MON PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BRADFORD I. COME BY
ADAM. DODD HER TADO. BELINDA'S
PAN. RUBIO I. AMBERG. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CABALLERO DODD I. HER TADO.
MELINDA'S PAN. AMBERG YEAH.
RIGHT BRADFORD I DON'T KNOW.
RUBIO I TO KNOW. ANY OTHER BOOK
ANY OTHER VOTE CHANGES. ALL
RIGHTS TWENTY FIVE KNOWS TEN
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SIX S.
B. TWO FORTY TWO SENATOR NEWMAN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
HERE. RATHER THAN. ALAN I.
BRADFORD I. GLAZER GROVE.
MELINDA'S PAN I RUBIO HI.
GROGAN GROVE NO. THE ICE THIRTY
KNOWS EIGHT ON THE URGENCY FIVE
THIRTY NO EIGHT ON THE MEASURE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ONTO FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN S. B.
TWO FORTY FIVE BY SENATOR%
GONZALES PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BRADFORD. I MELINDA'S.
PAM I. WELL NO. FIVE THIRTY ONE
KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORTY FIVE S. B. THREE
THREE EIGHT BY SENATOR GONZALEZ
PLEASE CALL THE UPSET MEMBERS.
GLAZER I. HER TADO. SKINNER.
FIVE TWENTY NINE KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORTY SIX SP THREE FIFTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR WIENER PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
HERTZBERG. SCANNER I AMBERG.
BUYS TWENTY NINE KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY SEVEN SB
THREE SIXTY EIGHT BY SAID
SENATOR LIEBERMAN PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD I.
COURTESY FIVE. GROVE. NIELSEN
NO. SKINNER I. GROVE NO. FIVE
THIRTY ONE KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY NINE S.
BEFORE 22% OR PAN PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN I.
MELINDA'S SKINNER HI. PRICE
THIRTY ONE NO NO EIGHT ASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY. S. BEFORE FIFTY
NINE BY SENATOR ALAN PLEASE
CALL THE M. SEVEN MEMBERS.
BATES FOR JUST I. BRADFORD
DALLY. THERE ALSO I. GROVE.
HERTZBERG I. CAN LONGER I. A
TRIO OF BOTH. I SKINNER I. WELK.
BRADFORD HI. I THIRTY TWO NO.
I'M SORRY HIGHS THIRTY THREE NO
THREE THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
ONE S. BEFORE SIXTY ONE BY
SENATOR CORTESE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. SCANNER I. FIVE
THIRTY ONE KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES. FILE NUMBER
FIFTY FOUR SP FIVE TWENTY THREE
BY SENATOR LEYVA. PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBERS. FAITH. GROVE.
MELINDA'S. SKINNER I. I THIRTY
TWO KNOWS FIVE MEASURE PASSES
PROBLEM FILE NUMBER FIFTY FIVE
SP FIVE SIXTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
PENN. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DALLY GLAZER. GROVE NO.
HER TADO. I. BUT SHOW BOTH. I
SKINNER. I NO. OUR DELANO DALLY
NO. FOR JUST I DON'T KNOW.
NUMBER ONE WE'RE JUST YEAH GOT.
ANYBODY ELSE. OUR EYES THIRTY
THREE NO SIX THE MEASURE PASSES.
THE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY SIX S. B.
FIVE NINETY EIGHT BY SENATOR
PENN. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SKINNER. HI. FIVE
THIRTY ONE KNOWS NINE MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
SEVEN SP SIX ELEVEN BY SENATOR
ALAN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MELINDA'S SKINNER I.
FIVE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. FILE I KNOW HIM
NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT SB SIX
THIRTY SEVEN BY SENATOR NEWMAN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FOR JUST. GROVE MELINDA'S.
NIELSEN NO SKINNER HI. HIGHS
THIRTY TWO KNOWS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIXTY ONE SB SIX NINETY
NINE BY SENATOR EDMUND. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. PLEASE
NO. DALLY. GROVE NO SKINNER I.
PRICE THIRTY THREE NO SIX THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY SIX SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX BY SENATOR
GONZALES. PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. HER TADO. I RUBIO. HI.
DAVID BATES I DON'T KNOW. FIVE
THIRTY TWO NO EIGHT YOUR PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FORTY EIGHT SP THREE NINETY
FIVE MY SENATOR KABBADI IT'LL.
PLEASE CALL THE UPSET MEMBERS.
ALAN I. BATES PORGES. HER TADO.
MEN. FIVE FORTUNE TINO. I
UMBERG. WE'RE FOR JUST NOW. I.
TWENTY NINE NO EIGHT MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE. ONE
ELEVEN SP FOUR SEVENTY TWO.
CENTER TO BUY IT- PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBERS. ALAN I FOR
JUST. GROVE I. FORTUNE TINO I.
THE ICE TWENTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. HELLO. OKAY
THERE ARE. K. YEAH I'D I DID
OKAY. MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
NINE FILE NUMBER NINETY SEVEN
S. B. TWO NINETY SIX BY SENATOR
EARLY MORNING. PLEASE CALL THE
OB TO MEMBERS ALAN. I FOR JUST.
FOURTEEN TINA. I. PORGES HI.
SORRY. YOUR EYES FOR EYES FORTY
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE OR
ONE S. B. THREE THREE NINE BY
SENATOR WIENER. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN I. HER
TADO. MAN. FORTUNE TINO I.
AMBERG MENINO MAN NO. NIELSEN I
DON'T KNOW. YOU ALREADY KNOW.
PLEASE CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS
JUST SO WE CAN BE SURE HER TADO.
NO AMBERG. FIVE TWENTY EIGHT NO
IT'S ELEVEN MEASURE PASSES
WE'RE GONNA FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE OH THREE. SB THREE SIXTY
TWO BY SENATOR NEWMAN. PLEASE
CALL THE APP TO MEMBERS. ALAN I.
BASE NO. DODD GLAZER I. FORTUNE
TINO. I. FIVE THIRTY NO NINE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON FILE
EITHER NUMBER ONE OH FOUR SP
THREE SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR
LEYVA. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN I. DALLY THE MON.
FORTUNE TINO I. HIGHS THIRTY.
PLEASE CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS
DALLY. BLUEMOUNTAIN I. FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS TOO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
MOVING ON TO ONE OF SEVEN FILE
NUMBER ONE OH SEVEN S. B. FOR
TWENTY THREE BY SENATOR STERN.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALAN. I BRADFORD. THE MON I BUT
SHOW BOTH. NO FORTUNE TINO. HI
BRADFORD I. HIGHS THIRTY ONE
KNOWS NINE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE TEN SP FOUR SIXTY FOUR
SENATOR HER TADO. PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBERS. ALAN I. THE
MON I NIELSEN NO. FORTUNE TINO
I. I THIRTY ONE KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM ONE
TWELVE S. BEFORE SEVENTY SIX BY
SENATOR MAN. PLEASE CALL THE
OPPOSITE MEMBERS ALAN I
ARCHULETA OR I. FOR JUST. THE
MON. I MCGUIRE. MELINDA'S BUT
SHOW BOTH I. FORTUNE TINO I
SKINNER. WHITE HOUSE SKI.
PLEASE CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS.
GORGEOUS MCGUIRE. MELINDA'S
SKINNER. WHITE HOUSE SKI. HIGHS
THIRTY ONE KNOWS FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTEEN S. B. FIVE OH THREE BY
SENATOR BAKER. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALAN I. GROVE.
WHEN MON I. NIELSEN NO. FORTUNE
TINO I WINNER. I. FIVE THIRTY
ONE KNOWS EIGHT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN SP FIVE
TEN BY SENATOR PENN. PLEASE
I'LL BE UP TO MEMBERS ALAN. I
GROVE. NO THE MON I. MELINDA'S
FORTUNE TINO HI. FIVE THIRTY
TWO NO SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
IF I GET THE. THIRTY TWO SEVEN
ON THE URGENCY. I THIRTY TWO NO
SEVEN ON THE MEASURE. TALK
ABOUT THE WHOLE. AND WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE ROOM ANY MEMBER
THAT WOULD LIKE A MEASURE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR PULLED FOR
SEPARATE DISCUSSION OR PULLED
SENATOR RUBIO. HELLO THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE ITEM SP FOUR TWENTY SIX
AND MOVED TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
SO ORDERED ANYONE ELSE. SAYING
NO OTHER US SENATOR EKMAN. AP
COULD WELL MAKE SURE YOU GET
YOUR MIKE IS ON IN JUST SECONDS.
I'D LIKE IS B. TWO FORTY AN S.
B. SIX FIFTY SIX TO BE PLACED
ON AN ACTIVE FILE. SORTER
SENATOR RUBIO I'M SORRY-
INCINERATE ME COULD YOU COULD
YOU- TELL US THOSE AGAIN. FIFTY
TO FORTY. S. B. SIX FIFTY SIX.
TO THE INACTIVE FILE. VERY GOOD
SO ORDERED AND SENATOR RUBIO.
YES THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE
FOLLOWING TO THE INACTIVE FILE
S. B. SEVENTY SP. FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN AND SB FIVE SIXTY. SO IN
ADDITION TO FOUR TWENTY SIX WE
HAVE SEVENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
AND FIVE SIXTY. CORRECT THANK
YOU SO ORDERED SENATOR WIENER.
IS JUST FIRST PRESIDENT SENT
ITEMS OR TO MOVE TO AN ACTIVE
IN GENERAL. HEY THIS IS TO MOVE
TO AN ACTIVE OKAY. YES I'D LIKE
TO DO FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN SP ONE
OH SEVEN TO BE INACTIVE FILE. I
ORDERED. SENATOR SKINNER YES.
WHAT IS YOUR LIFE S. P. THANK
YOU YES PLEASE MOVE S. B. SEVEN
FOUR SIX TWO INACTIVE.
DISORDERED THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE I CENTER IN AMMAN.
HE WOULD LIKE TO MOVE S. B.
FIVE FOUR TWO. SIX THREE THREE
AND FIVE FOUR THREE TO THE
INACTIVE FILE BUT WITH THAT
LAST NUMBER I'M SORRY. FIVE
FOUR TWO SIX THREE THREE AND
FIVE FOUR THREE FIVE FOUR
THREE. SORTERS SENATOR ALAN-
PLEASE MOVE THE ACTIVE FILE
FIGHT ON ITEM FIFTY THREE SP
FIVE ZERO TWO. NOW I'M BACK ON
IT WITH DEFERENCE TO OUR
MINORITY LEADER FIVE NINETY
FOUR SP TWO THIRTY FIVE. AND
FIVE AND ONE FORTY SIX SB SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR I WILL SEE THESE
BILLS BACK IN JANUARY. SO
ORDERED SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU
I WISH TO MOVE ITEMS- FOLLOWING
NUMBER SEVENTY ONE SP TWO
SEVENTY NINE TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. SP TWO SEVENTY NINE THE
ORDER YOU. POURTANT TINO HI I
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE- SP FORTY
FIVE MINUTES BEFORE EIGHTY FIVE
TO THE ENACTMENT FIVE IN ACTIVE
FILE. SO ORDER. ANYONE ELSE.
OKAY. ANYONE ANYONE ELSE ELSE.
ONE ITEMS PULLED FROM THE
CONSENT. OKAY. OKAY.
SIX
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO TAKE UP
THE SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDARS.
WE'RE NOT DONE YET SO- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. YEAH
SENATE BILL OF 1-923-374-026.
SIX SIXTY NINE SEVENTY TWO
SEVENTY SIX EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN
ONE TEN TWO OH SIX TWO OH EIGHT
TWO THIRTY TWO TO FORTY FOUR TO
FORTY SIX TO FORTY EIGHT. TWO
FIFTY SIX TO SIXTY EIGHT TO
EIGHTY SEVEN THREE FOURTEEN
THREE SIXTEEN THREE TWENTY
THREE THIRTY SIX THREE FORTY
EIGHT. 613-636-6418. FOR TWENTY
EIGHT FOUR FIFTY ONE FOUR
SEVENTY FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT. FOUR
NINETY ONE FOUR NINETY SIX FIVE
TWELVE FIVE TWENTY ONE FIVE
FORTY FIVE FIVE FORTY SEVEN.
FIVE FIFTY FIVE FIVE EIGHTY
NINE SIX SIXTY ONE SIX SIXTY
SEVEN SIX EIGHTY FOUR SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN SIX NINETY TWO
SEVEN OH FOUR SEVEN. FORTY
SEVEN OH FIVE SEVEN SIXTEEN
SEVEN EIGHTEEN. SEVEN TWENTY
TWO. SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT SEVEN
FIFTY FIVE SEVEN SEVENTY THREE
EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHT OH ONE
EIGHT OH SEVEN EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT. SENATE BILL.
TWENTY SIX ONE OH NINE TWO OH
SEVEN TO TWENTY FOUR TO THIRTY
SEVEN TO FORTY SEVEN TO FIFTY
FIVE TO NINETY THREE. THREE
FIFTY FIVE. THREE EIGHTY ONE
THREE NINETY THREE FOUR OH TWO
FOUR FIFTY THREE FOUR FIFTY SIX
FOUR SIXTY FIVE FIVE A
1-540-660-1609 SIX FORTY SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE. SEVEN NINETY AND
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTIONS
A. SIX FIFTY FIVE SEVENTY ONE
SEVENTY FIVE. EIGHTY ONE TWENTY
FIVE FORTY TO SIXTY NINE AND
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
SEVENTY SIX. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI AT KENS FIVE BASE
HI BECKER I FORGES I BRADFORD I
HAVE I HAD A. HI COURTESY HI
DALLY I DON. HI TORONTO HI A
GIVEN. HI BLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH HI
HERZBERG I WAS SO HI HER TADO.
HI JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED
I LIVE A HI THE MON I REQUIRE.
I MELINDA'S MAN I. NEWMAN I
NELSON I WOULD SHOW UP BOTH I
PAN HI FOURTEEN. HI ROSS. I
RUBIO. HI SKINNER I STERN I
NUMBER HI WHAT SKI I WE- I WILL.
I PLEASE PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. MELINDA'S I THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO ON ITEM ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN I THIRTY NINE NO ZERO ON
THAT SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR
MEMBERS I'M GONNA ASK YOU ALL
TO PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEAT WERE
NOT DONE TODAY WITH THE WITH
OUR SESSION. AND WE'RE GOING TO
RETURN. MEMBERS WE'RE NOT DONE
YET WE HAVE ONE MORE ITEM AND
WE'RE NOT READY TO SHUT DOWN
WE'RE GONNA RETURN TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS. I NEED FOR YOU
TO TAKE YOUR SEATS IF YOU COULD.
THIS IS THE TIME FOR AN ADJOURN
IN MEMORY AND I'D LIKE TO TURN
IT OVER TO SENATOR CORTESE FOR
THE CENTER'S EIGHT BTA TRAGEDY.
AND I'D LIKE ALL CONVERSATION
TO PLEASE CEASE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT BEEN COLLEAGUES SOME
THIS WILL BE. ONLY TWO MINUTES
THERE WILL BE A VERY PROFOUND
TWO MINUTES I THINK FOR ALL OF
US- I INTEND- WITH EXTREME
SADNESS AND EXTREME SORROW- TO
ASK. THE SENATE TO ADJOURN IN-
THE NAMES OF THE NINE VICTIMS
OF LAST WEEK'S MASS SHOOTING AT
THE SANTA CLARA VTA REAL YARD.
CAN ABDEL FATTAH HUB HELLO MOM
DONE SIXTY THREE YEARS OLD
WORKED WITH VTA FOR TWENTY
YEARS AS A SUBSTATION
MAINTAINER. ADRIAN BALL THAT'S
A TWENTY NINE YEARS OLD START
AS A BUS OPERATOR TRAINEE IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN ELEVATOR
MAINTENANCE WORKER AND LIGHT
RAIL OPERATOR. ALEX WARD
FRITSCH FORTY NINE YEARS OLD A
SUBSTATION MAINTAINER. JOSE DE
JESUS HERNANDEZ THE THIRD
THIRTY FIVE YEARS OLD STARTED
IN TWENTY TWELVE AS A TRANSIT
MECHANIC. LARS KEPLER LANE
SIXTY THREE YEARS OLD STARTED
IN TWO THOUSAND ONE AS AN
ELECTORAL MECHANIC WHO LATER
BECAME AN OVERHEAD LINE WORKER.
PAUL DEALER CREWS MAY HEAR
FORTY TWO YEARS OLD STARTED IN
TWO THOUSAND TWO AS BUS
OPERATOR TRAINEE AND LATER
BECAME A LIGHT RAIL OPERATOR.
TIMOTHY MICHAEL ROMO FORTY NINE
YEARS OLD SERVED OVER TWENTY
YEARS AS AN OVERHEAD LINE
WORKER. MICHAEL JOSEPH RUDE
AMERICAN FORTY YEARS OLD
STARTED IN TWENTY THIRTEEN AS A
MECHANIC LATER ELECTRO MECHANIC
AND THEN OVERHEAD LINE WORKER.
THESE MEN WERE SOCIAL WORKERS
WHO SERVED. AS A LIFELINE TO
THEIR COMMUNITY AND KEPT THE
LIGHT RAIL AND BUSES
OPERATIONAL DURING THE PANDEMIC.
THEY LEAVE BEHIND COUNTLESS
FAMILY MEMBERS AND FRIENDS
INCLUDING SMALL CHILDREN WILL
BE DEEPLY MISSED. I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT CONCURRENT
WITH TODAY'S THE GERMAN- OUR
OTHER HOUSE THE CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY HAS ALSO BEEN ASKED TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF THESE
NINE VICTIMS. I ASKED THE
SENATE TO ADJOURN IN THEIR
MEMORY. GETTING KNOWLEDGE MENT
OF THIS TRAGIC MASS SHOOTING
THANK YOU ALL. SENATOR CORTESE
MAKE SURE THAT THE NAMES ARE
PRESENTED TO THE DESK SO THAT
THEY MAY BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE SENATE AND
CONVEY OUR DEEP CONCERN
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILIES.
MEMBERS. IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS. YEAH YEAH IF THERE IS
NO OTHER BUSINESS. THERE IS
OTHER BUSINESS I WAS JUST
KIDDING. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION DR RULE SIXTY TWO AA
WILL BE WAIVED FOR THE BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE TO
MEET TOMORROW JUNE FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WITHOUT FOUR DAYS
NOTICE IN THE DAILY FILE. NOW
IF THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS.
SENATOR HERTZBERG THE DESK IS
CLEAR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MADAM PRESIDENT THE SENATE WILL
BE ADJOURNED AND WILL RECONVENE
TOMORROW WEDNESDAY MORNING AT
NINE O'CLOCK SHARP. WHO WORKS
SIX HOURS TILL ABOUT THREE
O'CLOCK FOLLOWED BY THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WHICH WILL CONVENE AT
THE END OF SESSION WITHIN SIX
HOURS TODAY WE GOT SIXTY BILLS
THE OBJECTIVE IS TO DO THE SAME
TOMORROW. HAVE A GOOD EVENING.
C. USE NINE O'CLOCK SHARP THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE SAN. WILL BE
AT WE WILL WE CAN WHEN. AT NINE
A.